COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES. TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL OF SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY ALL
SENATORSWHO ARE PARTICIPATING
ARE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS. PLEASE MUTE
YOUR MICROPHONE- COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. IT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU RAISE YOUR
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED SPEAK POP UP WINDOW
WILL APPEAR PROVIDING YOU
DIRECTIONS PLEASE FOLLOW THOSE.
ARE EIGHTY PER PERSON THAT WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
ARE DONE. ONE RECOGNIZED PLEASE
MAKE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE TO RECESS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE.
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. HE WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE FIVE THREE
ONE TWO EIGHT THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS. PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE INDOOR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. PROCESS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A VERY SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. EACH PERSON WILL GET
ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING FROM PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
AND OR HAVE YOUR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. INTO THESE. HEARING WILL
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR. GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
TO READ ASK THE- OF. SOME
DISCUSS THE IMPLEMENTATION. OF
INVESTMENTS MADE IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. THE NEW
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS
THE TREATMENT OF JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS DETERMINE
TO BE. INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL FOR I S. T. ALSO TODAY
WILL BE CONVENING A PANEL OF
STAKEHOLDERS AS WELL AS FOR A
FAMILY MEMBER OF AN INDIVIDUAL
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE NAVIGATING
THE I. S. T. PROCESS. TO SHARE
THEIR PERSPECTIVES ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S I S. T.
SOLUTIONS PROPOSAL. ONCE THESE
DISCUSSIONS HAVE CONCLUDED WILL
ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO VERY
BRIEFLY PERCENTAGE PROGRAM AND
CASELOAD UPDATES AS WELL AS ALL
THEIR BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS.
AFTER WHICH- I IN THE MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MAY HAVE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF
THE UPDATES ARE PROPOSALS.
BEFORE WE BEGIN DR PAN DID YOU
HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO SAY
TODAYTHE STARS SO OFTEN I WILL
NOTE THAT SENATOR MELENDEZ IS
NOT YET AND- AND BEFORE WE BEGIN
I SINGLE ASK- JUST TO ESTABLISH
THAT WHO WHO IS HERE. IT WILL
ASK THE SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL. EGGMAN AN AIR HONEST. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE PRESENTATION OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS. WE WANT TO WELCOME.
THE DEPARTMENT AND WE'RE READY
TO BEGIN. THREE TO OPEN IN A
YEAR YOUR I SEE. I DON'T HEAR
YOU. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES WE
CAN WELCOME DIRECTOR. GOOD
MORNING THE CLINTON AND DIRECTOR
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS AND TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
MANAGES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM OUR MISSION IS
TO PROVIDE EVALUATION AND
TREATMENT IN A SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE MANNER BY LEADING
INNOVATION AND EXCELLENCE ACROSS
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
SETTINGS WE OPERATE FIVE STATE
HOSPITALS LOCATED THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA A CONDITIONAL RELEASE
PROGRAM DESIGNED TO SAFELY
TRANSITION PATIENTS BACK INTO
THE aMUNITY
INPATIENT FRIENDS A COMMITMENT
TO THE DEPARTMENT. AND HAVE MANY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS IN
COUNTY JAILS TO PROVIDE
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION AND
DIVERSION OPPORTUNITIES IN JAIL
BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS THE INDIVIDUALS SERVED
BY OUR SYSTEM. OF CARE OR
TYPICALLY MANDATED FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT BY EITHER
CRIMINAL OR CIVIL COURT JUDGE
THE MAJORITY OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WE SERVE OUR FORENSIC
COMMITMENTS THEY HAVE EITHER
COMMITTED OR HAVE BEEN ACCUSED
OF COMMITTING CRIMES LINKED TO
THEIR MENTAL ILLNESS AND COME TO
US DIRECTLY THROUGH THE CRIMINAL
COURTS OR AFTER THEY HAVE
COMPLETED A SENTENCE AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
WE SERVE SIX DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PATIENTS INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE BEEN FOUND BY A COURT
TO BE INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
OR NOT GUILTY BY REASON OF
INSANITY CURRENT INMATES FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION'S
WHO HAVE SERIOUS BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND REQUIRE INPATIENT
HOSPITAL TREATMENT. INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE COMPLETED THE SENTENCE
OUT THE AT CDC ARE FURTHER
CRIMES AND HAVE EITHER BEEN
CERTIFIED BY THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS TO BE AN OFFENDER WITH
A MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER THAT
STILL REQUIRES TREATMENT AFTER
THE COMPLETION OF THEIR CDC
ARSONS OR HAVE BEEN FOUND BY A
COURT BEING A SEXUALLY VIOLENT
FINE EXCUSE ME SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATOR AND FINALLY INDIVIDUALS
CONSERVE UNDER THE LANTERN IN
PETRA SHORT ACT TO REQUIRE.
STATE HOSPITAL LEVEL OF
TREATMENT. THE TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNORS. INCLUDES A AND I HAVE
TO PAY SIX PER THE- OPERATION OF
WHICH POINT FOUR. BILLION IS
GENERAL FUND IN AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTEEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
GENERAL FUND OR CAPITAL OUTLAY.
THE PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES
INVESTMENTS TO CONTINUE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS IN THREE
MAIN AREAS MEETING THE INCREASED
DEMAND FOR SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS DEEMED INCOMPETENT
TO STAND TRIAL. IMPROVING THE
DEPARTMENT'S OPERATIONS AND
DELIVERY OF SERVICES AND STATE
HOSPITAL FACILITY REPAIRS AND
IMPROVEMENTS. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO GO AND ASK A
THE L. A. IF THEY HAVE ANY
COMMENTS AT THIS POINT. YOU DO
NOT OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING. OR DO YOU DID YOU DO
DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING MISTER.
OKAY THANK YOU- AND I AND I AND
I THINK IT IS A THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION DIRECTOR
AND BRAMBLE PUBLIC BE MOVING ON
QUICKLY BUT I JUST WANTED JUST
TO SAY FOR THE RECORD THAT WE DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND WE KNOW
AS WERE ALL REALLY STRUGGLING
WITH OUR CONTINUE OF CARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT THE STATE
HOSPITALS ARE ARE. THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE LEVEL OF CARE AND
WHERE WE WANT TO KEEP PEOPLE IN
A QUICKLY MOVING THROUGH AND WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS A HISTORIC BIG
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
RIGHT NOW BUT JUST TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT THIS IS THE
KIND OF THE LAST STEP ON THE OUR
CONTINUUM OF CARE AND THERE IS
SO MUCH WORK WE NEED TO DO PRIOR
TO THIS I THINK IT WAS WE JUST
GET IT KEEP SAYING THAT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN BEFORE PEOPLE REACH
THIS STEP AS WE UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE TRYING TO A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB- WHERE THE SYSTEM
HAS AN INDEPENDENT AND IN IN
CASES. AND HAS RESULTED IN IN
KIND OF WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH AT THIS MOMENT
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE ON GOING PLANS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO PRESENT TO US ABOUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO REALLY WORK ON I.
S. T. THANK YOU. IN A PRESS. THE
PRESS- EXCEPT QUESTION. WHY KNOW
WILL DIG MORE INTO IT WHEN YOU
WHEN WE TALK MORE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT ICE TEA BUT- GIVEN THE
POPULATION IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD
WHAT WHAT IS ETERNAL I GUESS-
THE TURNOVER RATE SO- THE PEOPLE
HOW HOW LONG PEOPLE TEND TO STAY
IN THESE HIGH RELEASE OF LOTS OF
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES AND SO
FORTH SO RIGHT SO YOU HAVE.
ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY BEDS WILL TRY TRY TO PUSH
THAT UP TO FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
FORTY. POINT TWENTY THREE AT
LEAST POSITION. AND- AND BUT IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW WHAT TO THE
TOUCH I GUESS THE TURNOVER RATE
AND THESE POPULATIONS FOR THE
LENGTH OF STAY IN OUR YEAH THE
LENGTH OF STAY I DOUBT REDUCE
LENGTH OF STAY- YEAH. AND I CAN
CERTAINLY ANSWER THAT QUESTION-
IT REALLY VARIES DEPENDING ON
THE COMMITMENT TYPE- BUT IN THE-
END THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT- ARE WE HAVE
SOME POPULATIONS THAT TURN
AROUND. PRETTY QUICKLY WHICH
WOULD BE ARE INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL I'M PATIENTS AS WELL
AS INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
COMMITTED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS ARE
CURRENT INMATES WHO ARE JUST
RECEIVING. A TREATMENT AT THE
HOSPITAL AND LEVEL AND THEN
RETURNED BACK TO CDC ARE FOR
THEIR- FOR THAT ARE AND CONTINUE
TO A MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
AND OTHER COMMITMENTS- HAVE. YOU
NO LONGER COMMITMENT TIME FRAMES
CERTAINLY SOME OF OUR LONGER AND
COMMITMENTS ARE THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE COMMITTED TO SS SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATORS- OFTEN WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS- UNDER THE
MANAGEMENT PATRICK SHORT ACT
THAT COULD YOU. CAN STAY A
LITTLE BIT LONGER AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE COMMITTED
AS OFFENDERS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS. AND THEN FINALLY THE
NOT GUILTY BY REASON OF INSANITY
AND INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
COMMITTED UNDER THAT COMMITMENT
COACH THEY ARE COMMITTED TO US
FOR THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE RECEIVED A
CRIMINAL SENTENCE IF THEY WOULD
HAVE. BEEN FOUND GUILTY AND NOT
BEEN FOUND GUILTY BY REASON OF
INSANITY SO THOSE TERMS CAN
OFTEN BE LONG DEPENDING ON THE
CRIME IN WHICH THE AND THEY WERE
FOUND NOT GUILTY BY REASON OF
INSANITY. AT THAT OKAY SO I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND- WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. BUT THIS IS ALSO
BUDGET COMMITTEE SOMEONE BE MORE
QUANTITATIVE SO LONG AS HOW LONG
SO AND I REALIZE YOU HAVE RIGHT
SO FOR EXAMPLE. THE ENCOMPASSED
ENTRIES THAT ARE SHORTER SO WHAT
IS THE AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY OF
SOMEONE WHO IS REFERRED TO AND I
REALIZE IT'S DIFFERENT EACH
DIFFERENT CASES THERE BUT WHAT
IS THE AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY.
FOR SOMEONE WHO'S IN. AND
COMPTANT STAND TRIAL VERSES. AND
I KNOW YOU KNOW YOU DON'T AND
YOU DON'T HAVE IT SO I JUST
GOTTA GET THAT'S WHAT THE
AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY IN THESE
HOSPITALS AND IF. YOU HAVE BY
THE CATEGORIES THAT'S GREAT IF
YOU DOWN JUST JUST A SENSE OF
WHAT IS NOW HOW LONG IS LONG HOW
SHORTAGE. SO LET US OF A BOOK
FOR THE IN. TO TRIAL. IN A IT'S
REALLY TO THAT THINGS ARE GOING
A LITTLE BIT DURING THE- OR-
THAT'S ABOUT FREE. RATES AND SO
TOOK. FOR WHO AT WHO ARE CA AS-
TO STAND AND TO THIS HOUSE. WE
TURN OUR SOMEWHERE THE HOME AND
FIFTY DAY MARK- AND IN BEING
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TREATED IN
OUR JAIL BASED COMPETENCY
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THOSE ARE
DESIGNED TO TREAT INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE GOING TO RESTORE MORE
QUICKLY. THEY OFTEN HAD I'M
COMMITMENTS LESS THAN NINETY
DAYS OR HARD AND EVERY TURN TECH
COMPETENCY WITHIN NINETY DAYS
AND THOSE WHO DON'T RESTORE
QUICKLY. ARE THEN TRANSFERRED TO
A STATE HOSPITAL FOR CONTINUED
TREATMENT- SO AND THEN IN THE
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
PROGRAMS THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE COUNTING COMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. ARE REMAIN IN THAT
COMMITMENT A LITTLE BIT LONGER
I'M ALMOST UP TO THE TWO YEAR
COMMITMENT TIME FRAME THAT'S
BECAUSE IT'S DESIGNED TO BEING
OF LONGER TERM COMMUNITY BASED
TREATMENT- THAT'S PREPARING THEM
BURKE CONNECTION TO COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT AFTER THEIR
COMMITMENT TIME. ON COMPARING
THAT TO SOMEBODY WHO IS ANNIE ON
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR THEY
CAN BE AND FOR YOU KNOW I DON'T
KNOW THAT. THAT AVERAGE LIKE TO
STAFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD FOR
THAT I'M COMMITMENTS TIGHT BUT
WE'RE TALKING MORE LIKE A DECADE
OKAY AND SO IT REALLY DEBT AND
THE OTHERS FALL IN BETWEEN
THERE. OKAY THAT. HELPFUL I'M
EIGHTY COULD BECAUSE A SENSE OF
LIKE WHAT THE CAPACITY THE
HOSPITAL YOU KNOW MEAN THAT YOU
HAVE YOU. GROUP HERE BUT- NO.
KNOW HOW MANY HOW MANY OUT TO
OKAY YOU THE YOU AND I'M SURE
WE'LL DO MORE DO INTO THIS WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT ISSUE TWO THANK
YOU. IN A THE DIRECTOR. CAN
RELATED TO THAT HOW WOULD YOUR
EX. WITH ABLE TO MAKE. YOUR
STAFFING LEVELS. AS APPROPRIATE
. FOR ABOUT STEP CRAZY ALL AND-
HEALTH CARE FOR. ALTHOUGH THE
STATE. HOW ABOUT FOR YOU AND HOW
THAT IMPACTED YOU ABILITY. TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE. THE YOUR BAKER
POPULATION. CERTAINLY ALL CARE
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW DURING PANDA
STOPPING CERTAINLY HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE AND ULTIMATELY YOU
KNOW REALLY THAT HAS A LOT OF IT
IS THAT WE HAVE STAFF WHO ARE
THEMSELVES ARE BECOMING L. OR
THEIR FAMILIES ARE BECOMING ILL
AND THEY NEED TO TAKE THE TIME
OFF SO IT DEFINITELY HAS BEEN- A
CHALLENGE I WITH RESPECT TO THE
STAFFING AND ALSO IT IS
DIFFICULT TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
INDIVIDUALS AND HEALTH CARE
DURING THE PANDEMIC AS WELL AND
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAINTAIN
OUR STAFFING LEVELS THAT ARE
REQUIRED AND BUT FOR THE SERVICE
OF OUR OF OUR HOSPITALS. AND
CERTAINLY HAVEN'T HAD TO REDUCE
OUR POPULATIONS OR I'M CLOSE
UNITS OR ANYTHING RELATED TO-
THE INABILITY TO STAFF BUT IT IS
A CHALLENGE AND WE'RE CONSTANTLY
WORKING TO TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE
CHALLENGES AND EVEN PRE PANDEMIC
I MEAN WE HAVE MANY PARTNERSHIPS
WITH A TRAINING INSTITUTIONS TO
DEVELOP THAT KIND OF A PATHWAY
AND PIPELINE INTO OUR FACILITIES
AND GET RID INDIVIDUALS
OPPORTUNITIES DURING THEIR
TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO COME TO
ME- HAVE EXPERIENCE WITHIN THE
STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM- AND SO TO
HELP WITH THAT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION SO IT'S AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE- AND I ALWAYS HAS BEEN
AN ONGOING CHALLENGE IT'S A-
VERY DIFFICULT. OUR SYSTEM TO
FOREIGN VERY DIFFICULT PATIENT
POPULATION TO SIR I'M SO IT'S A
HISTORICAL PROBLEM AND
DEFINITELY BANNED FURTHER
IMPACTED BY THE POUND DUMP. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY AND I
BELIEVE WE'RE TO PROCEED ON TO
IS NUMBER TWO YOU CAN TO TALK-
IN. STAN TRIAL AND YEARS.
PACKAGE CERTAINLY AGAIN I'M JUST
FOR THE STUFF CLINTON AND DURING
. AT. CHRIS STEVENS WHO IS OUR
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF PROGRAM
SERVICES. AND THE BUDGET THE
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES NINETY
THREE MILLION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AN ONGOING IN ASSOCIATED TRAILER
BILL FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
IMPLEMENT SEVERAL SOLUTIONS
RELATED TO INCREASING ACCESS TO
SERVICES FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
FOUND IN COMPANIES TO STAND
TRIAL ON FELONY CHARGES AND
THESE INCLUDE STABILIZATION. AND
EARLY ACCESS TO TREATMENT CARE
COORDINATION AND WAIT LIST
MANAGEMENT AND SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPANDING COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION AND DIVERSION
OPPORTUNITIES. IN ADDITION TO
THE SOLUTIONS THE PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES IMPLEMENTING A BROKE
CAP ON HIGHEST YOU REFERRALS FOR
ALL COUNTIES THAT'S AIMED AT
ENCOURAGING THE EXPANSION OF
COMMUNITY CARE BUT GUARDING
AGAINST ANY UNINTENDED
INCENTIVES THAT MIGHT DRIVE
INCREASED. ON THE HIGHEST HE
REFERRALS. RIGHT BACKGROUND ON
THIS. AS WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA
AS HOME TO THOUSANDS OF
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS WITH
SERIOUS BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONDITIONS IN MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS CYCLE IN AND OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. I AM VERY REASON
THIS HAPPENS IS BECAUSE OF GAPS
AS YOU NOTED I'M SURE. IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE CONTINUUM
IN UPSTREAM TREATMENT AND
SUPPORT INTERVENTIONS CAN BEING
UNAVAILABLE SOME INDIVIDUALS
BECOME IMPAIRED TO A POINT WHERE
ENGAGEMENT IN TREATMENT IS
DIFFICULT. INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ACCUSED AND ARRESTED FOR CRIME
AND WHO AS A RESULT OF THEIR
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONDITION ARE
UNABLE TO UNDERSTAND THEIR
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS OR SISTER
COUNCIL IN THEIR DEFENSE CAN BE
DETERMINED BY A COURT TO BE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE BEEN DEEMED
BY A COURT TO BE I S. T. ON
FELONY CHARGES ARE COMMITTED TO
THE DEPARTMENT FOR RESTORATION
OF COMPETENCY SERVICES.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DEEMED ICY
ON MISDEMEANOR CHARGES REMAIN AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL FOR THEIR
SERVICES. OVER THE LAST DECADE
THE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPERIENCED
INCREASING REFERRALS FROM THE
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT. OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DEEMED IS
CHAMP BONNIE CHARGES THE CURRENT
AND PRIOR YEAR BUDGET ACTS HAVE
MADE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
INCREASING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
FOR AYE ISSUES INCLUDING
ACTIVATING ADDITIONAL STATE
HOSPITAL BEDS. PARTNERING WITH
COUNTY SHERIFF'S PROVIDE JAIL
BASED COMPETENCY TREATMENT
PROGRAMS COLLABORATING WITH THE
L. A. COUNTY TO OFFER COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION AND PARTNERING
WITH NUMEROUS COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE TO IMPLEMENT AN
EXPANDABLE REGION PILOT PROGRAMS
FOR FELONY ISD'S. DESPITE TO
INCREASE TREATMENT CAPACITY AND
LEGISLATIVE AND OTHER
DEPARTMENTAL EFFORTS TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES TOWARD REDUCING THE
LENGTH OF STAY FOR I ISSUES.
INCREASING NUMBER OF COURT
REFERRALS HAS RESULTED IN THE
CONTINUED WAITLISTS FOR IDEAS TO
USE MEANING PSH SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY THE IMPACTS OF THE
KOBE INETEEN PANDEMIC AND
NECESSARY INFECTION CONTROL
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE HAD TO
IMPLEMENT AT THE STATE HOSPITAL.
HAS RESULTED IN LOWER ADMISSIONS
REDUCE CAPACITY FOR THE
TREATMENT OF FELONY ISPS IDEAS
STAGE. FURTHER INCREASING THE
WAY OF US TODAY THERE ARE OVER
NINETEEN HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
AWAITING ADMISSION INTO AN I. S.
T. TREATMENT PROGRAM. WHILE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING
AGGRESSIVELY OVER THE YEARS TO
ADDRESS THE GROWING WAITLIST IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION DENSITY
THE DEPARTMENT IT'S ON A CASE
ARE RIGHT NOW ANNOUNCED YOU HAVE
ANY- BE CLINTON. THIS CASE
ALLEGE THAT THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT I ISSUE DEPENDS FOR WAITING
FOR ADMISSION INTO IT IS
TREATMENT PROGRAM VIOLATED THE
INDIVIDUALS DUE PROCESS RIGHTS.
AND ULTIMATELY THE COURT DID
DECIDE THAT PSH MUST COMMENCE
SUBSTANTIVE TREATMENT SERVICES
FOR AYE ISSUES WITHIN TWENTY
EIGHT DAYS FROM RECEIPT OF THE
COMMITMENT FROM THE COURT. AND
THE COURT ALSO ESTABLISHED THAT
THE DEPARTMENT MUST COME INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE TWENTY EIGHT
DEADLINE BY FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND
SAID INTERIM DEADLINES AND TIME
FRAMES FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
MEET. AND WORKING TOWARDS THE
TWENTY BIG BALL. IT'S PAST FALL
AS REQUIRED BY WILL INSTITUTION
CODE STUFF FORTY ONE BOARD SEVEN
WHICH WAS AND- THREE TRAILER
BILL LAST YEAR. CALIFORNIA
HELPING HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
AND THE DEPARTMENT CONVENE AN
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
SOLUTIONS WORKGROUP. THE STATUTE
CHARGE THIS WORKGROUP WITH
IDENTIFYING ACTIONABLE SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS THE INCREASING
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS YOU
BECOME JUSTICE INVOLVED IN
DEEMED ARTIST YOUNG FELONY
CHARGES. THE WORKGROUP WHAT IS
COMPRISED OF REPRESENTATIVES AND
STAKEHOLDERS FROM MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
LOCAL GOVERNMENT JUSTICE SYSTEM
PARTNERS AND REPRESENTATIVES OF
PATIENTS AND FAMILY MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS IN FACT SEVERAL
THE PANEL MEMBERS HERE TODAY.
EITHER SERVICE WORK GROUP
MEMBERS ARE AS MEMBERS AND. THE
SUMMER BREAKS. THIS WORKGROUP BY
TIME IN A AND ISSUE SPECIFIC
SOME WORK GROUPS THAT WERE
FORMED ABOUT NINE TIMES WE ALL.
AND NOVEMBER TWO TWENTY ONE IT
WAS QUITE A MARATHON AND THEN
THROUGH THOSE FOUR MONTHS. AS
REQUIRED BY THE STATUTE THE
WORKGROUP IDENTIFY SHORT MEDIUM
AND LONG TERM I. S. T. SOLUTIONS
THAT ADVANCE ALTERNATIVES TO
PLACEMENT AND DSHS RESTORATION
OF COMPETENCY PROGRAMS. THE
WORKGROUP REPORT THAT INCLUDED
FORTY ONE STRATEGIES AND
SOLUTIONS WAS RELEASED BY THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE NOVEMBER
THIRTIETH. AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS CENTERED ON THE
THEMES OF EARLY STABILIZATION
INCREASING ACCESS AND TRAINING
OF COURT APPOINTED EVALUATORS
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NEEDS INCREASING
ACCESS TO COMMUNITY BASED FOR
TREATMENT AND DIVERSION
INCREASING HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR FELONY I ISSUES AND MORE
BROADLY FOR JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS WITH VARIOUS
BEHAVIORAL. HEALTH CONDITIONS.
ON THE I S. T. SOLUTION PURPOSE
THAT. AND HEARING WASN'T FORMED
BY THE RECOMMEND. DEVELOPED THE
ICE T. SALUTE WORK. AND WOULD
EMPLOY MANY OF THE- AND INCLUDES
BUG CURRENT YEAR AND BUDGET YOUR
COMPONENTS AND UTILIZES A
COMBINATION OF EXISTING FUNDING
FOR ICE TEA PROGRAMS. FUNDING
THAT WAS SET ASIDE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR AN ON GOING TO. I.
S. T. SOLUTIONS IN ADDITION TO
ADDITIONAL IS THE SOLUTION
SPENDING IN PROPOSED THE
COMPONENTS OF THIS PROPOSAL WILL
ASSIST THE DEPARTMENT IN MEETING
THE TREATMENT TIME LINES ORDERED
BY THE COURT. WHILE ALSO MAKING
MEANINGFUL CHANGES TOWARD
REVERSING THE TREND OF
CRIMINALIZATION OF INDIVIDUALS
WITH VARIOUS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS I'D LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER NOW TO CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR EVENS TO BRIEFLY
DESCRIBE. THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS
OF THE PROPOSAL. THANK YOU
WELCOME DEPUTY. GOOD MORNING
CHRISTINE ENDS I OKAY SO THE FOR
COMPLAINT OF THE I. USUALLY
PROPOSAL FOR STATE AND- EARLY
ACCESS TO TREE. THE SERVICES ARE
DESIGN TO PROVIDE EARLY ACCESS
TO TREATMENT TIES T. INDIVIDUALS
ON THE PSH WAITLIST WHILE WE
WORK TO COORDINATE PLACEMENT IN
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE SETTING.
THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE WITHIN THE
HIGHEST TO CONTINUE ON THE GOAL
REALLY IS TO FACILITATE THE
STABILIZATION BY ASKING PATIENTS
TO PROMOTE INCREASED ELIGIBILITY
AND PLACEMENT IN DIVERSION OR
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. THIS PROGRAM COME WILL
ACT TO TREATMENT AT THE EARLIEST
POINT POSSIBLE UPON I AS CHIEF
AMENDMENT AFTER INDIVIDUALS ARE
ARRESTED AND BOOKED INTO JAIL.
D. S. H. WILL FACILITATE THE
SAME PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY
JAIL NOW HELD PROVIDERS AND
FUNDS REQUESTED WILL SUPPORT THE
COST YOU PSYCHIATRIC MEDICATIONS
INCLUDING LONG ACTING.
MEDICATIONS MEDICATION
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT. INCREASE
CLINICAL PSYCHIATRY ENGAGEMENT
AND COMPETENCY EDUCATION WHEN
APPROPRIATE. THE NEXT COMPONENT
OF THE I. ISSUE SOLUTIONS
PROPOSAL FOCUSES ON CARE
COORDINATION AND WAIT LIST
MANAGEMENT. AS THE S. H.
CONTINUES TO ADD COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS TO THE MANUAL PLACEMENT
OPTIONS TO MITIGATE THE I. S. T.
CRISIS YES AGES PATIENT
MANAGEMENT UNITS ROLE AS THE HUB
LOCATION INFORMATION
COORDINATION. CONTINUES TO GROW
MORE COMPLEX. THE RESOURCES
REQUESTED WILL IDEA SKETCH TO
SCREEN ALL FELONY I. S. T.
PATIENTS DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY
FOR COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
PROVIDE ENHANCED MONITORING THE
WAIT LIST. I COMMITMENT TO
ADMISSION CASE MANAGEMENT TO
COORDINATE APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENTS AND MAXIMIZE BAD
USAGE FOR I. S. G. INDIVIDUALS.
TO SUPPORT THIS WORK ESSENTIAL
ENHANCE EXISTING TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS AND DEVELOPMENT
STATEWIDE TRANSPORTATION
CONTRACT TO TRANSPORT PATIENTS
BETWEEN FACILITIES WITHIN THE D.
S. H. CONTINUUM OF CARE TO
BETTER FACILITATE EDUCATION
ADMISSIONS AND TRANSFERS.
CONDITIONALLY RESOURCES ARE
INCLUDED AS SYSTEM CAPTURING AND
MAINTAINING HIGH QUALITY DATA-
AND MEETING DATA REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER STATE ATTY.
THE NEXT THREE COMPONENTS I
SUPPORT THE SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION OF COMMUNITY PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE FELONY ISP
POPULATION AND THIS IS ACHIEVED
THROUGH THE EXPANSION OF
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION
CONVERSION PROGRAMS. THE TRAGEDY
IS BELOW FOCUS ON BOTH SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM SOLUTIONS.
THE FIRST COMPONENT IS A SHORT
TERM SOLUTION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF FELONY I S. T.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CURRENTLY ON
THE TSCH WAITLISTS. SERVED IN I
COUNTY DIVERSION PROGRAMS ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
PLACING MORE I. S. T.
INDIVIDUALS AND A DIVERSION
PROGRAM IS THE COST AND
AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING THE COST
AND AVAILABILITY OF HOUSING. YES
H. PROPOSES TO PROVIDE ONE TIME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO COUNTIES
FOR HOUSING TO HELP ADDRESS THIS
RESOURCE GAP. COUNTIES CAN
UTILIZE FUNDING TO PROVIDE
HOUSING TO DIVERSION CLIENTS IN
THE MOST APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
CARE INCLUDING- BUT NOT LIMITED
TO SHORT TERM TREATMENT
FACILITIES SUCH AS DIABETES OR
MENTAL HEALTH REHAB CENTERS.
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING WAS
CLINICALLY ENHANCED SERVICES
BORN HERE'S- OR OTHER
APPROPRIATE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES. THE NEXT COMPONENT
IS A SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT TO DEVELOP OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIODTHE DEDICATED
HOUSING THAT'S NEEDED TO SUPPORT
THE HIGHEST YOU POPULATION
SERVED IN THE COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION OR DIVERSION
PROGRAMS DISEASE PROPOSES TO
PARTNER WITH COUNTIES AND OR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATIONS TO FUND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF APPROXIMATELY
FIVE THOUSAND COMMUNITY BANDS.
ASSUMING AN AVERAGE LENGTH OF
STAY OF ABOUT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
MONTHS YES AGE ESTIMATES THAT
THESE BEDS WITH THE SERVER
PROXIMALLY THREE THOUSAND NEW
ISP INDIVIDUALS REFERRED TO THE
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. ISRAEL FOR WOULD PROVIDES
UP FINE TO COVER THE DOWN
PAYMENT OF A RESIDENTIAL UNIT.
RETROFITTING AND FURNISHINGS FOR
CLIENTS AND STAFF. THE ONGOING
COST OF OPERATING THE HOMES
WOULD THEN BE PROVIDED THROUGH
THE PER PATIENT RATE- THAT WOULD
THAT WE'RE PROPOSING BE PAID TO
THE SERVICE PROVIDERS WHO WOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
THE CLIENT'S PLACEMENT IN
HOUSING AS WELL AS PROVIDING
THOSE WRAPAROUND TREATMENT
SERVICES. AS A COMPLIMENT TO
THIS INVESTMENT IN THE DEDICATED
HOUSING DS EACH PROPOSES
DEPARTMENT PARTNER WITH COUNTIES
TO CREATE OR EXPAND PERMANENT
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. FOR FELONY ISG
INDIVIDUALS THE RESOURCES HE
REQUESTED HERE WILL PROVIDE A
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PER CLIENT RATE.
SUPPORTING EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AVERAGE LENGTH OF STAY IN EITHER
EASTSIDE COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION OR DIVERSION
PROGRAM. SERVICES ARE ENVISIONED
AS AN INTENSIVE COMMUNITY
TREATMENT MODEL OF CARE WITH
INCREASED CLINICAL ENGAGEMENT IN
PSYCHIATRY SERVICES AS WELL AS
OTHER WRAPAROUND SERVICES. AND
ONGOING HOUSING SUPPORTS.
GINNELLY THE PERKS PATIENT RATE
- HER CLIENT RATE WANTS. THEY
USED FRIENDS CARE SUCH. AND
ENHANCE SUPERMAN THROUGH
PARTNERSHIP WITH PROBATE. IN
ADDITION TO THE DOOR TREATMENT
ACROSS THE TOTAL REESE WERE
WOULD SUPORT NON TREE BECAUSE-
RELATED TO PLANT COURT AND THESE
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTY. AS WELL
AS PROVIDING TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL RESOURCE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE RESOURCES TO HELP ON
PROVIDE SUPPORT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS- AS WELL AS TRACKING
OUTCOMES DATA AND CONDUCTING AN
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM. ON
THE NEXT COMPONENT OF THE ICE
YOU SOLUTIONS PROPOSAL PROPOSES
TO PILOT A NEW INDEPENDENT
PLACEMENT DETERMINATION PANEL TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF STATE
HOSPITAL PATIENTS SERVED IN THE
COMMUNITY B.R. CONDITIONAL
RELEASE PROGRAM. THIS NEW PANEL
WERE WILL REVISE THE COMMUNITY
PROGRAM DIRECTOR ROLE THAT IS
PART OF THE CONRAD. AND IMPROVE
THE ASSESSMENT PROCESS FOR
PATIENTS FOR EITHER NOT GUILTY
BY REASON OF INSANITY OR FAST.
AND ALEXANDER WITH MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDER WHO CURRENTLY RESIDE IN
OUR STATE HOSPITALS THE OVERALL
INCREASE UTILIZATION CONRAD WELL
THREE BEDS IN THE STATE
HOSPITALS ALLOW PLACEMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TRULY IN
NEED OF. THE HIGHEST LEVELS OUR
SYSTEM. AND LASTLY AS THE
DIRECTOR MANAGED. I CAN SURE
THAT EXPAND OF THE S. C. FUNDED
BASED CARE TO NOT CREATE AN-
INCENTIVES THAT MAY DRIVE
ADDITIONALI ASKED YOU REFERRALS
WE ARE PROPOSING TO IMPLEMENT
GROWTH CAP THAT WOULD APPLY TO
ALL COUNTIES. AND INCLUDE A COST
SHARING METHODOLOGY OF THE
GROWTH CAP IS EXCEEDED. YES AGE
PROPOSES TO SET EACH COUNTIES
REFERRAL. NOW OF FELLOW AS CAN.
TO THAT IN THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
IF COUNTY SPEAKS EITHER ANNUAL
BASELINE NUMBER OF REFERRALS
BEGINNING- AND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE THEY
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR PORTION
OF TREATMENT COSTS. BASED ON THE
NUMBER OF I. S. G. REFERRALS.
ABOVE THEIR BASELINE. THERE IS
TRADE BILL LANG AT THIS PROPOSAL
AND I DID D. WILL BE. MADE
AVAILABLE WHEN THE TV EXTREMELY. I'M. THERE WERE ALSO SEVERAL
QUESTIONS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
IN THE AGENDA- AS PART OF OUR
PRESENTATION WE ANSWERED
QUESTIONS ONE THREE AND FOUR.
DURING THAT PRESENTATION SO
WILL. GO AHEAD AND FOCUS ON THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE NOT.
ANSWERED WITH REGARD TO QUESTION
NUMBER QUEUE THIS IS AN UPDATE
ON OUR I AND D. SEVEN Q. THAT
CAN PASS THE PROGRAM. SHE JUST
BY WAY BACK. IN THE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT WE
RECEIVED A TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ONE
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
POINT ONE MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
POSITIONS. ON THIS THE SCHOOL
YEAR AS WELL AS EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SIX MILLION. ON GOING TO ADDRESS
THE SIGNIFICANT ESTEEM WAIT
RESPECT. WITH PRIVATE PROVIDERS
WORK COUNTIES TO DEVELOP NEW OR
RENOVATED EXISTING FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT
OPTIONS TO STATE HOSPITALS. OF
THE TOTAL RECEIVED WE DIDN'T
RECEIVE A TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDING. TO
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS FOR
THESE FACILITIES. SO WE REALLY
CONSIDER THAT THIS PROGRAM IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT. TO THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REQUIRED TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY TREATMENT AND
PLACEMENT OF ICED TEA
INDIVIDUALS IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING POSSIBLE. TO
THAT END WE WANT TO BE
THOUGHTFUL. AS TO WHERE THIS
INVESTMENT IS TARGETED SO WE
HAVE A BROAD COVERAGE OF I AM
DEEP BEDS ACROSS THE STATE THE
SERVICE POPULATION. AS AS FAR AS
UPDATE DID BEGAN- OVER THE
SUMMER ENGAGEMENT MEETINGS WITH
MULTIPLE PROVIDERS- WOULD NOT
WITH OVER TEN DIFFERENT
PROVIDERS- SINCE LAST SUMMER AND
THIS IS REALLY TO HELP US TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THE INVENTORY OF.
POTENTIAL PROJECTS- ARE.
IDENTIFIED SEVERAL. BOB PROVIDER
PROJECTS TO DATE AND- HAVE
CONTINUED OUR WORK WITH THESE
PROVIDERS SHE REALLY FLESH OUT
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENTS- AND
THROUGH BUT HOWEVER THROUGH
THESE DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR
PROVIDERS WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
NEED TO SUPPORT- BEYOND JUST I
AM D. AND Q. LEVEL OF CARE- AS A
COMPLIMENT TO THE I AM D. TO
PROMOTE THAT STABILIZATION THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT FOR PORTION OF
THE FELONY I S. T. POPULATION
WHO MAY REQUIRE INVOLUNTARY
MEDICATIONS. AND SO MOST
RECENTLY AND NOT REALLY IT. A
REFLECTED IN OUR ESTIMATE WE ARE
FINALIZING CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS
WITH AND HUGE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
HOSPITAL PROVIDER TO ACTIVATE UP
TO A HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN BEDS
A SOLID HIT BY PSYCHIATRIC
STABILIZATION AND SUPPORT A
PATHWAY FOR I. S. T. INDIVIDUALS
TO PARTICIPATE IN DIVERSION OR
OTHER OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. ONE I CAN CLOSE MY
UPDATE ALTERNATE OVER TO
DIRECTOR CLINTON TO PROVIDE
RESPONSES JUNE QUESTIONS FIVE
AND SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BOOK YOUR MUTE DIRECTOR. YOU'D
THINK BY NOW AMAZEMENT MONTHS
UNTIL WORLD IN A GROUNDHOG DAY.
MY APOLOGIES- SO WITH RESPECT TO
QUESTION NUMBER FIVE- THE END
WHICH IS AROUND TO IN
ADDITIONAL- RECOMMENDATION
RECOMMENDATIONS BACK FROM THE IC
SOLUTIONS WORK GROUP THAT WE
MIGHT BE CONSIDERING FOR FUTURE
ACTION THE PROPOSAL ACTUALLY
WOULD IMPLEMENT MANY COMPONENTS
OF THE I. S. G. SOLUTIONS
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDATIONS AND
LAST FALL WE IMPLEMENTED ONE OF
THE RECOMMENDED SOLUTIONS AROUND
DIVERSION. THERE WERE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CENTERED ON
TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND DEVELOPMENT OF
BEST PRACTICE GUIDES AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PREVIOUSLY AND
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO OUR COUNTY IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PARTNERS
REGARDING BEST PRACTICES AND IS
WORKING TO DEVELOP SOME BEST
PRACTICE GUIDES AND TOTAL
SIXTEEN OF THE FORTY ONE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE UNDER
IMPLEMENTATION OR PROPOSED FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THE REPORT OF
SOLUTIONS WHAT THE CENSUS OF
ACTIONABLE SOLUTIONS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED BY WORK REMEMBERS AND
THROUGH THE PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
THEY DIDN'T NECESSARILY
REPRESENT CONSENSUS OF THE
WORKGROUP MEMBERS AND SOME WORK
REMEMBERS MIGHT HAVE EITHER
SUPPORTED OR OPPOSED SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ALL OF THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE DID RECEIVE-
AROUND SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION IS
AVAILABLE ON THE I. S. T.
SOLUTIONS WORK GROUP WEBSITE.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO SHARE
THAT SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE ITEMS THAT WOULD BE OUTSIDE
OF THE DEPARTMENT RUBIO TO
IMPLEMENT AND WILL TAKE FURTHER
EXPLORATION AND DISCUSSION WITH
OTHER STATE- PARTNERS OR OTHER-
PARTNERS OUTSIDE OF THIS AND
STATE DEPARTMENTS ON POTENTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION SO ULTIMATELY THE
SOLUTIONS THAT WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AND THOSE PROPOSED
TO BE IMPLEMENTED REPRESENTS
LESIONS THAT WOULD HAVE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON OUR
ABILITY TO MEET THE COURT
ORDERED TIME LINES. AND WILL
HAVE SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE.
IMPACTS FOR THOSE WE SERVE. AND
THEN WITH RESPECT TO. NUMBER SIX
WHICH IS. PERFORMING IN A- TO ON
- THE END. AS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY THE GOAL OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO DO TWO THINGS TO
ME WINDS ARE REQUIRED BY THE
COURT AND MAKE MEANINGFUL
CHANGES TOWARD SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS. AND TO RESIDE IN
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE SETTING
THAT'S APPROPRIATE. HAVING THE
LIVES OF THOSE WE SERVE AND
BREAKING THE CYCLE OF
CRIMINALIZATION AS CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
PROPOSAL DOES INCLUDE FUNDING
FOR FIVE THOUSAND BANDS WHICH
REPRESENTS WHAT WE IS NEEDED TO
START APPROXIMATELY THREE
THOUSAND NEW AYE ISSUES
ANNUALLY. WHICH REPRESENTS
TREATING ABOUT 60% OF AYE ISSUES
ANNUALLY IN THE COMMUNITY.
ADDITIONALLY IT INVEST IN
PROVIDING EARLY ACCESS TO
TREATMENT AND STABILIZATION-
WHICH I USE TNCS- WHICH WOULD
ALLOW US TO BEGIN DELIVERING
TREATMENT MORE QUICKLY. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THERE ARE
MANY FORCES A PLANE THAT CAN ALL
IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO MEET
TIMELINES FOR EXAMPLE INCREASING
REFERRALS FROM THECOURT THIS
YEAR WE ARE EXPERIENCING A 13%
INCREASE OVER PRE PANDEMIC
REFERRAL RATES. AND ADDITIONALLY
THAT PANDEMIC IMPACTS ON OUR
HOSPITALS AND THOSE WE PARTNER
WITH AND SERVING ICE TEAS CAN
ALSO SLOW ACCESS TO TREATMENT
IMPACT EXPANSION EFFORTS. SO
ULTIMATELY THIS PROPOSAL DOES
MAKE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS.
TOWARD MEETING THOSE TIMELINES.
WE'RE HAVING TAKE ANY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND YOU GUYS ARE
CERTAINLY BEEN BUSY THIS LAST
YEAR I BY APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING- A LET'S
GO TO THE L. A. O. FIRST TO SEE
I SEE MISTER SHOULD WITH HIS
HAND UP THERE HE GOES. THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN HIGH
COURT ISSUED A WITH THE L. A. L.
I JUST SOME COMMENTS ON ON THIS
ISSUE. FIRST WE WOULD JUST SHARE
THAT WE DO INTEND TO PROVIDE AN
ANALYSIS OF THIS ISSUE IN A
FORTHCOMING POST. FOCUSED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAJOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PROPOSALS. WHICH WE
EXPECT TO RELEASE IN THE IN THE
COMING WEEKS- SECOND WE WOULD
NOW ASK THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
MENTIONED THAT- THE PLAN IS FOR
THE ADMIN TO PROVIDE FORTHCOMING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
IMPLEMENT. MAJOR PORTIONS OF THE
IC SOLUTIONS PACKAGE- BUT THIS
LANGUAGE IS NOT YET AVAILABLE
FOR REVIEW. NEXT WE WOULD NOTE
THAT AS AS THE ADMIN MENTION
EARLIER THE ADMINISTRATION VIEWS
THIS PROPOSED PACKAGE OF IC
SOLUTIONS. AS A STARTING POINT
FOR DISCUSSIONS ESPECIALLY WITH.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION INTENDS TO UPDATE
THIS PROPOSED PACKAGE AT ME
REVISED TO INCLUDE ANY CHANGES
OR REFINEMENTS SO. THE
LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN. LATER
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS AS WELL
I'M ON THIS ITEM. SPEAKING TO
THE CURRENT ITERATION OF THIS
PACKAGE THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
INCLUDED REFLECT A FEW OF THE
IDEAS FROM THE ICY WORKGROUP BUT
NOT ALL OF THEM- YOU KNOW SIMPLY
I'LL JUST SAY THAT THEY
INCLUDED- A FEW PRIORITIES SUCH
AS- FURTHER EXPANSIONS OF THE
COMMUNITY CAN YOU COMMUNITY
BASED IN DIVERSION. OPTIONS
EARLY STABILIZATION- IMPROVE
PATIENT TRACKING SYSTEMS AND
HOUSING RELATED INVESTMENTS BOTH
IN THE SHORTER TERM AND IN THE
LONGER TERM- THAT ARE SORT OF
INTENDED TO COMPLEMENT THE
FUNDING FOR ACUTE AND SUB ACUTE
BEDS THAT. WAS PROVIDED TO TEACH
SAY THE SHN ME ON TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET. AS
MENTIONED THE PROPOSAL DOESN'T A
- PROPOSED CAP ON CAL RIGHT YOU
REFER. AND REQUIRE FOR COUNTIES
TO ENSURE. FOR TREATMENT IF THEY
EXCEED THAT CAP. GUARDS TO
PROPOSED FUND YOU KNOW GENERAL
FIND THESE REASONABLE. TO FIND
THIS YEAR YOU KNOW THE EARLY
STABILIZATION INVESTMENTS
ESPECIALLY SEEM PROMISING GIVEN
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT LACK OF
EARLY STABILIZATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS COMING INTO THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR BARRIERS TO ENSURING THAT
AN INDIVIDUAL CAN PARTICIPATE IN
THE COMMUNITY OPTIONS. PROVIDED
THROUGH TSA H. HOWEVER YOU KNOW
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE IC
SOLUTIONS WORKGROUP INCLUDED A
VARIETY OF IDEAS ALTHOUGH SOME
OF THESE ARE VERY CONCEPTUAL AT
THIS POINT- AS WAS ALLUDED TO IN
THE AGENDA TODAY YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO. MONITOR
PROGRESS AND DEVELOPMENT OF
SOLUTIONS BASED ON THE OTHER
IDEAS IN THE WORKGROUP. FOR
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE WORK GROUP DISCUSSED
OPTIONS RELATED TO IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF IT- INITIAL COMPANY
COMPETENCY EVALUATION PROCESS
THESE- WHICH IN CONCEPTS SEEM
SEEM PROMISING- WE WOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER WHERE PSH CAN
COORDINATE WITH OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS- WHICH ARE MAKING.
AVAILABLE RELATIVELY SIMILAR
HOUSING RELATED AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BED CAPACITY OPTIONS SUCH
AS THE H. CSS BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM. TO SEE IF THOSE
PROGRAMS CAN BE LEVERAGED
PRIVACY ISSUES AS WELL- WHILE
THERE MAY STILL BE VALUE IN V.
S. AGE SPECIFIC HOUSING AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. TAKING A BIT
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THESE OTHER
AVAILABLE OPTIONS MAY SORT OF
ADD ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL
SIGNIFICANT VALUE. FINALLY WHILE
WE DON'T DISAGREE IN CONCEPT
WITH A REFERRAL CAP ON COUNTIES
FOR ISPS YOU KNOW THESE THESE
CAPS MAY ULTIMATELY INCENTIVIZE
COUNTIES TO PARTNER WITH THE S.
H. ON SOME OF THE SOLUTIONS THAT
WERE MENTIONED TODAY. ON THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO SORT OF
CONSIDER WELCOME. CAPACITY
COUNTIES HAD CURRENTLY TO SORT
OF REMAIN UNDER THESE CAPS- AND
HOW SORT OF COUNTIES CAN
LEVERAGE. THE PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
TO THEM IN ORDER TO INSURE THAT
THEY ASKING YOU TO STAY ON THOSE
CASH. ARE SUPPOSED ARE ALL L. A.
O. AT THIS TIME OR WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE A QUESTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT FIND. I
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING AT THIS TIME
. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THAT THAT WAS GOING TO BE AROUND
MY QUESTIONS TO THERE WAS A
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT AND
I CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THAT
HOUSING AND STEP DOWN BEDS AND
ALL OF THAT ARE ARE- IMPERATIVE
TO THIS. BUT HOW WE'RE HOW WE'RE
GONNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT.
FOUR NINE DOUBLE DOUBLES AND IN
THE COUNTY. MONEY WITHOUT ALL OF
THIS BEING. A COORDINATED AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT RIGHT NOW
DIRECTOR OR- HAS THERE BEEN ANY
EARLY CONCEPTUAL THOUGHTS ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE.
WE'RE NOT JUST. CONTINUING
THROWING MONEY TO THE COUNTY
FROM DIFFERENT PARTS OF FOR THE
SAME BED. THANK YOU. AND SO WITH
RESPECT TO COORDINATION YOU KNOW
WE ARE WORKING WITH CAL HHS AND
OF THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS THAT
HAVE RECEIVED FUNDING- TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE COUNTIES-
SO THERE IS A LOT OF
COORDINATION GOING ON ACROSS OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND WHAT THE AGENCY.
BUT ALSO WOULD NOTE THAT THE AND
THE HI THE- THERE IS DISTINCT
FOCUSES OF EACH OF THE DIFFERENT
INVESTMENTS- AND SO. FOR THEM
FOR THE- DOLLARS THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING THIS WOULD BE
DEDICATED HOUSING TO TREAT
INDIVIDUALS WHILE THEY'RE IN THE
I. S. T. COMMENCEMENT. TEAM
FUNDING THAT IS PROPOSED UNDER
HOMELESSNESS UNDER THE-
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUING
DOLLARS AND THE OTHER
INVESTMENTS THOSE ARE LARGELY
AROUND SERVING. THEIR TO
ESTABLISH THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CONTINUE THAT WILL. HOPEFULLY
PREVENT INDIVIDUALS FROM
BECOMING AYE ISSUE BECAUSE THERE
WILL BE A BROADER CONTINUUM TO
SERVE INDIVIDUALS- WHO ARE IN-
WHO LIVE WITH BEHAVIORAL HALTH
CONDITIONS. AND THEN WE'LL ALSO
HAVE A CONTINUING TO CATCH THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO ALTERNATELY
AND UP IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ON THE BEAT AFTER THE END
OF THEIR COMMITMENT OR AFTER
THEIR I. S. T. COMMITMENT. SO
ULTIMATELY THESE ARE VERY
DIFFERENT POTS OF MONEY- AND
THAT WE ARE ALL WORKING.
TOGETHER TO TRY TO COORDINATE
ENSURE THAT THE SYSTEM IS IN A
WORK TOGETHER- AND THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE LEVERAGING ARE
BEING LEVERAGED AND HIS THAT
I'M- BEST BENEFIT FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS. THAT ARE BEING
SEARCHED. I THINK YOU CAN CAN
YOU DESCRIBE AT THE AVERAGE OF
PAY FOR EACH PERSON IN THE- IN
THE DIVERSE PROGRAM. HELLO THIS
IS CHRIS- WE HEY- OUT IT IS JUST
OVER FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND AND-
ANNUALLY OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD- CLIENT. PER CLIENT PER
YEAR FORTY THREE THOUSAND YEAH
BUT WE ALLOCATE THAT TO COUNTIES
ACTUALLY IS A FLAT RATE PAYMENT
ACROSS THAT THREE YEAR PERIOD
OKAY AND I WOULD JUST ALSO NOTE
THAT A LOT OF THE A LOT A LOT OF
THE SOLUTIONS WHICH AGAIN ON OCT
THEY ALL MAKE SENSE- DEPEND A
LOT. ON CONTRACTING WITH
COMMUNITY ARTNERS- AND HOW MANY
OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE OR ARE THOSE
AND AGAIN AS WE CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT WORK FORCE OR ARE YOU
GONNA BE ABLE TO FIND THOSE
PARTNERS. OUT THERE. SURE UNDER
THE DIVERSION PROGRAM WEEK WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE. CONTRACTS WITH
TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES AND OUR-
THROUGH THE EXPANSION DOLLARS
THAT WE RECEIVED IN IN THIS
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET- AN
ADDITIONAL SIX COUNTIES ARE
GOING TO BE COMING ON BOARD AND
WE'VE BEEN AND- CONTINUAL
CONVERSATION WITH MANY OF THESE
COUNTY IS AND- IN IN TERMS OF
DEVELOPING THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
AND WORKING WITH THEM ON THE
DIVERSION PROGRAMS BUT ALSO- IN
THIS LAST YEAR. OR SO- HAVE BEEN
PARTNERING WITH THEM CAN YOU
TALK TALKING ABOUT THIS BROADER
CONTINUE ON AND REALLY LOOKING
AT ALL OF THE VARIOUS OPTIONS
THAT WE HAVE WITH OUR I AND D.
SEGMENT. WHEN IT'S OUR COMMUNITY
BASED RESTORATION AND DIVERSION
AND REALLY LOOKING AT THIS
HOLISTICALLY WHAT ARE THE GAPS
IN THOSE- INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES
THAT WE NEED TO REALLY TACKLE
AND HOW DO WE STRATEGICALLY SORT
OF DIRECT THESE DOLLARS TO FILL
THOSE GAPS- AND SO. WE CAN
REALLY REACHING OUT TO THEM THE
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTIES THAT WE
CURRENTLY. WORK WITH. THANK YOU
A I JUST THINK I IS TO BE AN
ISSUE THAT WE THAT WE- AGAIN I'M
GLAD HEAR YOUR CALL. WITH ALL
THESE DIFFERENT POTS OF MONEY
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE PART OF THE
BIG INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY WHAT
WAS A DIRECTLY FOR BEDS AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE SAYING WOULD
YOU NEED. SEPARATE IN DIFFERENT
BEDS BUT LET'S JUST MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE KEEPING OUR EYES ON
ALL THE DIFFERENT BUCKETS AND
POTS. AND WHERE THAT MONEY'S
GOING. TO DEPEND. THANK YOU AND-
AND I KNOW THAT WILL PLANT MORE
QUESTIONS AFTER THE PANEL BUT-
SEVERAL QUESTIONS SO THEY HAVE
TO FIRST OF ALL- YEAH. THE
ADVANTAGE OF HAVING BEEN AROUND
FOR A LITTLE WHILE IS THAT I
REMEMBER BACK IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN
PROPOSED- FUNDING FOR.
ESTABLISHING THE- THE PROGRAM-
AND- I SEE DIVERSION PROGRAM. IT
WILL. SO NOW THIS MANY YEARS
LATER- TO WHAT'S THE VALUATION
SO I KNOW THAT BACK THEN I EVEN
TRIED TO ASK THE ADMINISTRATION
SO HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU THINK
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO DIVERT
SO THAT- IN TO TRY TO REDUCE THE
BURDEN ON STATE HOSPITALS AND-
THEY'RE KIND OF VAGUE ABOUT THAT
BUT- I GUESS AND NOW AND NOW
THAT WE'RE- DONE THIS FOR MANY
YEARS AND CLEARLY. ISN'T ENOUGH
BUT- HOW SUCCESSFUL OR
UNSUCCESSFUL WAS THAT HAS- WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE ARE NOW
DIVERTED YEAH HAVE YOU SEE WE
NEED TO DO MORE WE STILL HAVE
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE-
THIS THAN WHAT IN A WAITLIST
SUCCESSFUL TWENTY EIGHT EFFORT.
GLORIA I COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT IT DID TAKE US SOME
TIME TO- BRING UP THESE THESE
PROGRAMS SO- I WILL SAY LIKE I
MENTIONED- EARLIER IS THAT WE
ARE CURRENTLY CONTRACTING WITH.
WITH TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES AND SO
ON THAT ORIGINAL HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS INCORPORATED WE
HAVE- OBLIGATED NINETY THREE
POINT ONE MILLION- OF THOSE OF
THOSE DOLLARS AND- I OF THE
TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES- THE WAY
THAT WE HAD ORIGINALLY DESIGNED
THIS PROGRAM. WAS NOT DIRECTLY-
OR EXCLUSIVELY I SHOULD SAY. KIM
DIVERT INDIVIDUALS OFF OF THE
FELONY I ASKED YOU WAIT LIST
FROM THE ESTATE WE ORIGINALLY
DESIGNED THIS PROGRAM TO SERVE
BOTH THE ASKED HE- POPULATION.
ON FELONY CHARGES FOR THOSE
LIKELY TO BE FOUND I ASKED SHE
REPLIED BACK AND THEN WAS. CAN
WE INTERRUPT THAT THE- THAT
CERTAIN THE CYCLE THE PATHWAY
TOWARDS THAT I AS CHIEF
COMMITMENT AND THEN REALLY
DIVERT THEM BEFORE THAT HAPPENS.
AND SO SINCE THAT TIME- ALL ALL
COUNTIES HAVE BEEN- ACTIVATED
THEIR PROGRAMS. NOW THERE WERE
SOME DELAYS DUE TO THE THAT THE
PANDEMIC- AND SO IN TOTAL THEY
ANTICIPATED DIVERTING. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWENTY- INDIVIDUALS
AND AS OF JAN THIRTY YES- FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT AT ELIGIBLE. INDIVIDUALS HAVE. THE PROBE.
AND THIS. A HUNDRED AND NINETY
SEVEN THOSE I TEACHERS WERE
PRIOR TO REFER TO DO STAGE TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO JUST LIKE
WE CAN BE I T. AND FIFTY TWO OUR
- BIASED HE'S WORK. FROM OUR-
OKAY AND THIS IS AS OF FOR DATE
IS THAT AS OF THE ACTUALLY A
JUNE THIRD. WE HAVE SAID A LACK
IN THE RIVER WHICH YEAR WHICH.
THIS PAST YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAH.
OKAY SO THE GOAL WAS A HUNDRED-
WE FOR. WE ACTUALLY GOT FOR TO
FIFTY EIGHT. I MEAN YES WE HAD
TO PAY. BUT THIS WAS BACK IN
TWENTY. I REALIZED SOMETIME
STAND UP. WITH A SCORE YEARS
LATER SO. OKAY- ALL RIGHT-
READING'S TO LEARN LESSONS THE
PAST SO WE'RE NOT START FROM
SCRATCH- THE OTHERS I GUESS THE
OTHER I HAD IS. OF THE CURRENT
BACK. THE THINK ABOUT SEVEN SOME
PEOPLE ARE WHAT PER. OF THOSE
ARE FALLIN. AND WHAT PERCENT OF
THOSE ARE MISDEMEANOR AND THEY
ALL FELONY OR DAY IS A MIX OF
THE TWO. SO THE- THEY SHOULD ALL
BE FELONY CHARGES- BUT BECAUSE
THE WAIT LIST HAS BEEN SO LONG.
YES I'M- YES I AM SORRY- SO THEY
THEY SHOULD ALL BE FELONY
CHARGES BIG SPOT AT NOW
CURRENTLY- UNDER CURRENT LAW.
WHICH WAS CHANGED LAST YEAR. I'M
ALL MISDEMEANORS ARE TREATED AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL OKAY ARE USED
TO BE ABLE TO READ FOR
INDIVIDUALS- TO THE DEPARTMENT
WHO WERE MISDEMEANORS- THAT AND
PAY FOR THOSE SERVICES. BUT THAT
WE DID- THERE WAS. AT THE
CHANGING NOT STATUTE ENACTED
LAST YEAR THAT NOW REQUIRES ALL
THE MISTER MINUTES REMAIN AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND ONLY FELONIES
CAN BE DIVERTED SO TO THE EXTENT
THAT- THERE AREN'T ANY
REMAINDER. AND MISDEMEANOR THAT
MIGHT BE ON THE LIST AND FROM
PRIOR TO THAT STATUTORY CHANGE
BUT IT SHOULD BE IN MAJORITY OF
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE AT LEAST
GOING FORWARD THEY'RE GOING TO
SPEAK SOMEBODY. EVEN ESTIMATES
FOR ONLY A VERY SMALL FRACTION
OKAY I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT
THAT'S THAT SO THEN THE NEXT
QUESTION I HAVE THEN. IS THAT-
EIGHT THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO FIND
THESE COMMITTEES NEED THAT- YOU
KNOW NEED TO PUT THE MONEY FIND
HOW ITSELF. AND THEN YOU JUST BE
REALLY BLIND- TELLING THEIR BE
SOMETHING DOWN THIS. IS BECAUSE
YOU TALK ABOUT EVEN BAD IDEA.
BOARD CARE ROOM. IS GOING TO
HAVE SOMEONE WHO'S EIGHT- YOU
KNOW I S. T. WELL THEN THAT'S
OUT THERE GARCIA RIGHT. D. THINK
THERE'S TO BE ISSUES RELATED TO
FINDING SOME PLACES FOR THEM
BECAUSE OF POTENTIAL COMMITTEE
PUSH BACK. BECAUSE THESE ARE
AGAINST. BIAS. YEAH I DON'T
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE EASY- BUT
YOU KNOW WE REALLY DO HAVE SOME
VERY SUCCESSFUL MODELS WILL LOOK
TO- LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE- I
THINK AS YOU KNOW I MEAN THROW
IN THE END INVESTMENTS IN THE
CAREERS WE ARE OPERATING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN. BAD
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION FOR
THAT FELONY ASKING POPULATION
PREDOMINANTLY THE MAJORITY OF
THOSE BAGS ARE IN RESIDENTIAL
SETTINGS AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THE KEY TO THEIR SUCCESS IS
RALLIED HOUSING PROVIDERS THAT
THEY DO WORK WITH YOU TO DO A
LOT OF FUN AND WORK IN TERMS OF
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE COMMUNITY
AND SHARING WHAT WHAT SORT OF
THE GOALS OF- AND TREATING THE
POPULATION AND WHAT THEIR-
STRIVING TO DO. AND SO IT IS
THROUGH A LOT OF THAT THAT COULD
WELL HARD WORK ON THE FRONT AND
THAT THAT HELPS TO- STRESSED OUT
WHICH SHOWS RELATIONSHIPS THAT'S
WHAT WE GET OUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MONITOR I DON'T
MISS THIS AGREE WITH YOU I
THINK- AND NO I WOULD SAY CAN
YOU PLACE IT WOULD BE BETTER
ANYWAY BUT- I ALSO KNOW THE
REALITY OF SODA YEAH- OF THAT
SOMETIMES. DO YOU YOU DO GET
PUSHED BACK AND- SO IT'S NOT A
SIMPLE SIMPLY- WE HAVE SOME
MONEY AND WE JUST NEED TO BUY
SOME RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES OR
WHATEVER IT'S A AND I NEED TO
YOU KNOW THAT. BUT- NO THERE'S A
TO BE DIVERSE. ON FIND WHAT THE
PER OF IT IS SO- IN THAT MAY
MAKE A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT. SO
INTO OF TRYING TO MONITOR
WHAT'S- OF. YOUR PER. WE NEED TO
BE PAINT. AND THE OTHERS. I HAVE
IS THAT- IN TERMS OF THE- HE
SAID THERE'S A 13% INCREASING
COURT REFERRALS- WHAT'S CAUSING
SILVA OF COURSE THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT PART RIGHT AND I GET
THE IDEA OF PLAYING REFERRAL
CAPS BUT IT'S NOT THE COUNTIES
THAT MAKE THE DECISION UNLESS
UNLESS I GOT SOMETHING WRONG
THAT SOMEONE GETS AN ICY
REFERRAL IT'S A JUDGE FREIGHTERS
AND EVALUATION THE JUDGE SAYS
OKAY. AND SO WHAT WHAT'S DRIVING
THAT 13% INCREASE IS THERE SOME
EDUCATION GOING ON WITH THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM IN TERMS OF THE
NORTH THINK ABOUT THAT DECISION
PASSED THE HOUSE ONE ENDS UP
HERE AND- AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THE REGIONAL PLAN WAS NOT JUST
TELL PEOPLE HONESTLY BUT PEOPLE
POTENTIALLY BEYOND I. ESTY BUT-
SO. YEAH WELL ARE WE EVERY DAY
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE- INCREASE
IN COURT REFERRALS BECAUSE
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE PUT IN
PUT PRESSURE ON THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE BACKLOG. AND IS
EARLY ON AND ARE WE AND OTHERS
PLAN TO HAVE A FIGURE OUT OF
DRESS THAT. ASIDE FROM SIMPLY
PUTTING A CAP ON THE COUNTY
SUMMIT COUNTY UP CAP ON THERE
BUT THE COUNTY IS THE ONE YOU
MAKING DECISIONS. AS TO WHO'S
GETTING THAT WHO'S THE REFERRALS
RIGHT. SO TO GET IT GOING TO
TIGHT TOUCH ON A COUPLE OF
POINTS RELATED. BEING I CAN'T
TAKE A BREAK WITH THAT DO I'M
ABLE TO MAKES DISK. ON WHO- IS
VERY COMMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
THAT IS- THAT IS- THE CASE AND
ABOUT THE- INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE I.
S. T. IS REFLECTIVE. OF THE
INABILITY OR THE AND NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE GOING
UNTREATED. AND TARGET NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO TREATMENT OR UNDER
TREATED I'M IN THE COMMUNITY SO
THERE IS A CORRELATION BETWEEN
WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE COURTS
AND THE SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED IN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM. SO WHILE THE-
COUNTIES THEMSELVES DO NOT
DIRECTLY MAKE THE DECISION ON
WHO IS COMMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT THERE IS A ROLE IN
DEAN- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE AND-
ENDING UP IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND THERE IS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE COUNTIES
AND THE COURTS TO- TO COORDINATE
AND COLLABORATE AROUND
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION OKAY REVERSION FROM
THE ARRESTED THERE'S LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO I DON'T THINK
SO AND IF I WHICH I THINK I GET
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING SO THEN I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT- IS
THAT 13% INCREASE HAPPENING
BECAUSE THERE'S FEWER MENTAL
HEALTH OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
COUNTIES OF THEIR FOR THE JUDGES
FEEL COMPELLED TO NOW REFER THEM
TO. TRY S. T. OR IS AT 13%
BECAUSE THEY CHANGE THEIR
STANDARDS FOR WHO NEEDS I. S. T.
SO WHAT'S DRIVING. THIS INCREASE
IN REFERRALS. THAT'S REALLY HARD
TO DO SAY I MEAN THIS IS BEEN IN
ON. YOUR OVER YEAR RIGHT YEAH IT
PROBLEM I WE CERTAINLY HAVE DONE
OUR OWN LOOKING AT THE DATA THAT
WE HAVE ON OUR SIDE TO SEE IF IT
WAS LARGE ONLY- ARE DRIVEN BY A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE- DIFFERENT
THINGS AND POLICY ISSUES THAT
WE'VE HEARD OVER THE YEARS AND
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE HEARD AND-
CERTAINLY HAVEN'T. SEEN ANY
MAJOR DIRECT IDENTIFICATION OF
WHAT IS CAUSING- THE POPULATION
pINDIVIDUALS INNING UP IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. OTHER
THAN AND ULTIMATELY THERE IS- WE
DEFINITELY DIDN'T LOOK AT DATA
ANGLER AND- MASTER DATA TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES MEDICAL RECORDS AND DID
SEE THAT NEARLY 50% WE'RE NOT
ACCESSING THEIR SERVICES- WITHIN
SIX MONTHS OF THEIR ARREST. 65%
OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT- COME
INTO ISN'T AS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL WERE HOMELESS AT THE
TME OF THEIR ARREST. SO THERE
CERTAINLY INDICATORS OF WHAT IS
CONTRIBUTING BUT- NO DIRAC'S YOU
KNOW. ANYTHING THAT DIRECTLY
SAYS THAT THIS IS ME- THE FACTOR
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS OTHER
THAN TO ULTIMATELY THAT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE ON.
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE HOUSING
AND SUPPORTS FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAVE SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
THAT'S ALL THINGS THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON AS AN ADMINISTRATION
CURRENTLY AND LOTS OF
INVESTMENTS IN ALL OF THE AND
THOSE AREAS THAT WILL HELP
ULTIMATELY- HELP ADDRESS THIS AT
ON GOING INCREASE AND HOPEFULLY
VERY QUICKLY. ONCE INVESTMENTS
ARE START TO MEET AND BE
IMPLEMENTED TO HELP REDUCE THAT
TREND OKAY SO I GUESS WHAT I
WOULD. SAY IS THAT- LIES IT'S
NOT NECESSARY TO HAND. BUT NO
LESS WE INDEMNIFY. SOME OF THESE
CAUSE IT'S BE AN EXTRA IN FOR.
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU'RE RIGHT- THE
COW YOU CAN PLAY A ROLE IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW EITHER PROVIDING OR
NOT PROVIDING SERVICES WHICH
THEN WOULD COMPEL A JUDGE TO
FEEL LIKE WHAT I DO NEED TO
REFER NOTS AYE ANDERSON OLY
UNDERSTAND YOU EXPLAIN THAT
DYNAMIC. AT THE SAME TIME IF WE
CAN IDENTIFY WHY THE NUMBER OF
CASES INCREASES THIS POINTED OUT
IN THAT ANALYSIS FAILED TO THAT
THE BACKLOG HAS INCREASED FROM A
COUPLE HUNDRED TO NOW THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED. BUT WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S DRIVING THAT. THE AND ALL
ARE AND THEN WE'RE NOT GOING TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER INTERVENTIONS
ARE WORKING OR NOT RIGHT- YOU
KNOW MAYBE ON THE GROUND LEVEL
WORLD BOWL. HOPEFULLY THE
NUMBERS TO GO DOWN BUT THEY'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
TEASE OUT WHAT WHICH ONES ARE
WORKING WHICH ONES ARE. ARE NOT
AND IN FACT WE TOUCHED ON THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE IMPLEMENTED
SOME OF THEM WHEN I AND SO MANY
OTHERS TO MAYBE DISAGREE ABOUT
SOME. BUT IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
DATA DRIVEN EFFORT AND WE'RE
INVESTING A LOT OF MONEY IN
THIS- RIGHT- I THINK FIGHT OVER
FIVE HUNDRED. MILLION. CORRECT
SO THAT'S- IN A IN. THE I THINK
WE NEED TO ALSO FIRST. HOW DO WE
PUT THINGS IN PLACE THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT LIKE OKAY
WHAT'S DRIVING THIS RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE OF THE JUDGES CONTINUE
THE INCREASE THAT ARE. AFRAID OF
REFERRALS FOR ICE TEA. WE MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THAT
RIGHT AND SO WHY ARE THEY DOING
THAT AND IF IT IS BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES ARE DELIVERING ENOUGH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN THE
COUNTY THEN. WE CAN POINT OUT
THE ROOT CAUSE AND THAT'S WHERE
YOU DIRECT THE MONEY IN THE
EFFORTS. BUT LOOK AT IT OR IF
IT'S NOT ENOUGH HOUSING RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU SAID YOU'RE HOMELESS
IT'S SO FORTH. SO AND I KNOW
YOU'RE SORT OF. TOUCHING ON THE
THESE THINGS- BUT- SO I GUESS
MY- AND NOT SO MUCH A QUESTION
FOR ELLIE- BUT ONE OF THINGS
THAT- MORE OF A COMMENT. SO AS
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS WHAT'S-
AT LEAST FOR ME. THE HELP. IS
ACTUALLY DOING A DIAGRAM OF THE
SYSTEM RIGHT THIS IS THE INPUT
RIGHT SO WE HAVE PEOPLE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES SOME OF THEM END
UP UNFORTUNATELY IN DOWN. IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM RIGHT
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY HOPEFULLY
WITH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THAT. SOME OF THEM WON'T MAKE IT
THERE RIGHT SO THAT'S AN EXIT
POINT. NOW YOUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. YOU KNOW THE COURT. YOU
KNOW ANOTHER EXIT POINT YOU KNOW
COMMUNITY SERVICES VERSUS THE
HOSPITAL AND SO FORTH AND HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE. EXITING AND
ENTERING AT THESE DIFFERENT
POINTS. RIGHT AND THEN SO AT
LEAST WE CAN MONITOR. THE FIGURE
OUT OKAY WE'RE DOING THESE
INTERVENTIONS ARE WE SEEING A
CHANGE IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
EITHER ON RAMPING- OFF RAMPING
THIS PATHWAY THAT LEADS TO. YOU
KNOW ESSENTIALLY DYNASTY PROGRAM
AND EITHER STATE HOSPITALIZATION
OR COMMITTEE SERVICES- SO. I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. TO
AND THEN SAY OKAY AND HOW IS
THAT CHANGING OVER TIME AS WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING THIS AS WE'RE
INVESTING OUR FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY. HOW IS THAT
CHANGING IS A CHANGING AT ALL IS
IT HOW THE CHANGING AND- AND
TRYING TO SEE WERE CONCERNED
THAT IF I SOME OF THE RECENT
ROOT CAUSES BECAUSE IT SAID WE-
YOU KNOW WE INVESTED. PROBABLY
NOT ENOUGH BACK IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. LOOKS LIKE IT MADE
LITTLE DENT HERE. BUT IF WE
CAN'T QUANTIFY SOME OF THESE
THINGS WERE NOT GOING TO KNOW
FOR YEARS I MEAN I WILL BE IN
OFFICE BUT- MAY CENTER EGGMAN.
AND SHE'S KIND OF THE SEATS
OPENED UP HER TIME HERE- WITH
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT.
WILL ACTUALLY. WE SOLVE THE
PROBLEM OF HAVEN'T SAW. AT LEAST
WE IDENTIFIED. HOW TO SOLVE THE-
BY THE END. AND I SERVE. LIKE
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S A TO BE NO
FOR. COMPONENT SO WE KNOW WELL
WHAT'S MAKING DIFFERENCE. AND
THEN FINALLY I GUESS I WOULD
JUST ALSO SAY AS I APPRECIATE
THAT. SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF COURSE DON'T
DIRECTLY INVOLVE THIS DEPARTMENT
BUT I THINK OF THE HELPFUL.
OTHERS FINANCES JOBBER ARTSY
HOUSE WILL HELP US WITH THIS.
AND IF I WHICH OTHER AGENCIES
ARE THE ONES BECAUSE THOSE WERE
OVERSEEING THE OTHER. AGENCIES
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WE
WANT TO BE SURE LOOKING BACK TO
THEM AND SAYING HEY BY THE WAY.
WE HAVE AN ICY PROBLEM- THERE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ARE YOU
GOING TO BE D. TAKING YOUR OF
THIS PART OF THE PROBLEM BECAUSE
THAT STEP INTO PER YOUR AGENCY-
SO. WITH THAT I AGAIN APPRECIATE
THE- THE CONVERSATION LOOKING
FOR TO THE PANEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MUCH- AT AND I THINK
THE POINT DR PANDA'S MAKING OKAY
AS IN THE YOU ARE THE MOST
EXPENSIVE STOP- ON ON THE ON THE
PATH OF CARE. AND I WOULD GUESS
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
LIMIT THE AMOUNT UP COUNTY CAN
REFER. IS THAT IT WOULD
ENCOURAGE THEM PEARL TO PROVIDE
MORE RELENTLESS ENGAGEMENT
THAT'S ONE THAT I MEAN TWENTY
HUGE ISSUES A LOT OF THESE FOLKS
ARE VERY HARD TO ENGAGE. AND IT
TAKES RELENTLESS ENGAGEMENT
WHICH TO HOPEFULLY WE ARE. WE
ARE. PUTTING A LOT OF MONEYINTO
THE PIPELINE TO KEEP FOLKS FROM
GETTING TO YOUR POINT. BUT I
GUESS I WOULD I WOULD ASK- ED.
MISTER SHEET WHEN YOU DO DO THIS
ANALYSIS IF WE IF THE UPSTREAM
AND DOWNSTREAM THAT DOCTOR PAN
IS TALKING ABOUT I DON'T KNOW
PERHAPS H. CHI WOULD BE THE
AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR LOOKING
AT SOME OF THAT DATA. VERSUS
PUTTING IT YOU KNOW ALL IN THE
STATE HOSPITAL WHEN THEY ARE
THERE THE BLAST OBVERSES THE END
POINT I THINK IT WOULD TAKE NEED
MORE. MORE PEOPLE IDENTIFYING ON
THE ENDPOINT HOW DO WE PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM GETTING TO THE STATE
HOSPITALS. AND I DON'T KNOW. AND
I'M JUST THINKING MAYBE IT CUT
AS THEIR NEW. ROLE WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THE DATA FROM ALL OVER
DH YES I'M- SO. ANYWAY JUST. I
THINK IT DEPENDS VERY ACCURATE
THAT WE NEED TO IDENTIFY. HOW
IT'S ACTUALLY WORKING AND SINCE
IT'S SUCH A BIG COMPLEX SYSTEM.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR ONE
COMPONENT OF THAT SYSTEM. TO DO
THE EVALUATION OF ALL OF IT SO-
SO I GUESS WITH THAT THEN. WE
WILL GET TO OUR PANEL AND- JUST
FOR THE PUBLIC OUR PANEL WAS
COMPRISED. AND THE STAFF WERE
ASKED. EACH PERSON TO GO TO
ANSWER A SERIES OF QUESTIONS AS
WE DO FOR ALL OF OUR FOLKS TO
HELP GUIDE OUR CONVERSATIONS. SO
FAR THE PANEL AGAIN ARE GOING TO
DISCUSS THE ADMINISTRATION'S I.
S. T. SOLUTIONS. THAT WE HAVE
WITH US- DR VERONICA KELLY CHIEF
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
RECOVERY SERVICES. ORANGE COUNTY
HEALTH CARE AGENCY. WE HAVE KIM
PETERSON SENIOR ATTORNEY IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTICE FOR THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS GROUP OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE STEPHANIE
REGULAR. SYSTEM PUBLIC DEFENDER
FOR THE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. WE
HAVE BRANDED. GREALISH EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE COUNSELING.
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WE HAVE MICHELLE.
FRAZIER OF FOR THE AMERICAN OF
ACLU OF NORTHERN. AND WE HAVE
SANDRA. C. STEVEN BERG WHO WAS A
FAMILY MEMBER OF A PERSON WITH
I. S. T. O. N. N. I. S. T.
PATIENT. OKAY SO WE'LL ASK OUR
PANELISTS TO PRESENT THEIR
PERSPECTIVES FOR THE THREE
MINUTES FOLLOWED BY QUESTIONS
FROM THE SUBCOMMITTEE WHEN
YOU'RE ALL DONE- DONE. AND WE'LL
BEGIN WITH DR KELLY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SENATOR AND MANAGING
CENTER PAMPER THE OPPORTUNITY
AND DOCTOR BROWN CAL AND BE A
HOPE DIRECTORS JUST STATED FOR
ORANGE COUNTY AND PAST PRESIDENT
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF CAN BE A
HEALTH DIRECTORS WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HELP INFORM
THE I. S. T. PROPOSAL BEFORE US
TODAY DOWN THE PROCESS TO BE
VERY COLLABORATIVE IN NATURE. WE
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S PROPOSAL
HERE AND ELSEWHERE IN THE BUDGET
TO PRIORITIZE ACCESS TO HOUSING
HOUSING INDIVIDUALS THERE'S
MENTAL ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER NAMES ARE ALREADY
CHALLENGING. DUE TO FEDERAL
RULES THAT DISADVANTAGE OUR
CLIENTS FROM HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE
AND INDIVIDUALS COMING OUT OF
INCARCERATION OR TREATMENT
FACILITY THEY NEED TO WAIT
LONGER TO ACCESS HOUSING
RESOURCES. EVEN IF THEY WERE
HOMELESS PRIOR TO THOSE DAYS AND
IT CAN BE DIFFICULT TO HOUSE
INDIVIDUALS WITH ANY SORT OF
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND USED
UNDERCOUNTS POINT. ON TOP OF
THEIR BEHAVIOR HEALTH CONDITION-
WE NOTE THAT 66% OF INDIVIDUALS
WERE CHARGED WITH FELONIES ARE
FOUND TO BE INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL WERE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AT THE TIME OF
THEIR ARREST. AND WE BELIEVE
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS A
SIGNIFICANT RISK FACTOR THAT IS
DRIVING INCARCERATIONS AND THE
RISK OF RECIDIVISM AND BELIEVE
THAT ALL STATE HOUSING EFFORTS
SHOULD SEEK. TO PRIORITIZE. AND
INTO EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
WHO HAVE A ZERO MENTAL AND THE
OUT OF WITH THIS USED. AS A URGE
STATE YOUR- ORANGE COUNTY ARE.
RELEASE FROM CONRAD THIS WORKING
DO. WITH DISH AND WE- IT VERY
MUCH TO ESTABLISH ALL. LEVELS OF
CARE WITH THE COMMUNITY WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE STATE IS
EXPANDING ITS LEVEL OF CARE
CAPACITY AND BELIEVED THIS
DOESN'T. REFLECT ABOUT THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE EXISTING
LAKE FOREST. NEEDS CANNOT BE
MATCHED. EITHER THROUGH THE
EXISTING DISH OR THE EXISTING
LOCAL CAPACITY THE REALITY IS
THAT WE NEED TO EXPAND CAPACITY
FOR THIS POPULATION. WE NEED
MORE. CAN BE EVER HELD AGENCIES
ARE BUILDING OUT THAT CAPACITY
AS WE SPEAK FOR COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION. FOR INDIVIDUALS
CHARGED WITH FELONIES AND ONE
COUNT TO BE I. S. T. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL CONTINUE THAT
INVESTMENT. AS WE SHARED WITH
DISH THE BUILD OUT OF THIS
CAPACITY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL WILL
TAKESOME TIME AND A SHIFT IN
POLICIES CULTURE AND PRACTICE.
PUTTING GREATER RISK TOLERANCE
BY LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE
THAT COURTS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
STAKEHOLDERS ARE PARDONING
PARTNERING WITH US. AND THE
STATE JUST LIKE WE ALL DID IN
CRAFTING THIS IMPORTANT PROPOSAL
TO MAKE LEVEL OF CARE DECISIONS
REGARDING WHO IS BEST SERVED IN
COMMUNITY. IS BEST SERVED IN
CUSTODY OR AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
COUNTY PROVIDES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE TO MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES. LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARRESTS D. A. PROSECUTE PUBLIC
DEFENDER DEFENSE AND THE COURT
SENTENCED AS- WE ALL HAVE A ROLE. IN THESE PROPOSED SOLUTIONS.
CBS DID A VERY. FOR THE FOCUS OF
BEACHES ONYX. THE CURRENT
INDUSTRY AND- ON HIS DOOR GAS.
IN THE BEHAVIORAL AND TERM CARE
. FOR PEOPLE WE SERVE TOGETHER
THE BEACH DOLLAR AND THE C.
DAHLE WILL BE AN AMAZING STAR.
AND WE AGREED THAT ALL EFFORTS
BY THE STATE NEED TO ADDRESS
EQUITY AND LEVERAGE ON GOING
MEDICAL INVESTMENTS IN ADDITION
WE HAVE PROPOSED IDEAS FOR
IMPROVING THE PREVENTION AND
TREATMENT. OF ISPS INCLUDING
ESTABLISHING STATEWIDE STANDARDS
FOR ALIENIST. AND DEVELOPING A
STATE CERTIFICATION STANDARD
IMPROVING DISTANCE CHARGING
PRACTICES TO IMPROVE CONNECTION
TO LOCAL COUNTY ENTITIES. OR
INDIVIDUALS LEADING STATE
HOSPITAL TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
RECIDIVISM AND IMPROVING
IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
COMPREHENSIVE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDING LONG ACTING
INJECTABLES AND MEDICATED
ASSISTED TREATMENT IN CUSTODY.
TEMPERATURES THE LIKELIHOOD OF
STABILITY ONCE A PERSON WALKS
OUT THE DOOR. COUNTIES ARE
INDUSTRIOUS WE MAKE DO WITH WHAT
WE HAVE AND WE LEVERAGE WE HAVE
FOCUSED ON INTERCEPT MODELS SUCH
AS OUR DATA DRIVEN RECOVERY
PROJECT MADE ABOUT COUNTIES
INCLUDING SACRAMENTO SAMPOERNA
DINO YELLOW NO DATA LIMITS.
RENDON MERCED THESE THIS PROJECT
INCLUDES ONLINE. PARTNERS WILL
LAB WE LEVERAGE THE DATA WE HAVE
FROM CUSTODY FROM PROBATION FROM
HOMELESSNESS AND BEHAVIOR HOW.
TO ENSURE WE CAN WORK ACROSS
LARGE AND AGENCIES. TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF OUR SHARED CLIENTS
. COUNTIES WORK WITH OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS ADDRESS TO
HER WITH OUT INTO FIVE. WE'VE
BEEN UP TO TREAT PROGRAM PARTNER
WITH OUR DE ATTORNEYS ARE THE-
OUR TRY AGAIN IF I THOSE PEOPLE
UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS AND TO
AND PROVIDE TREATMENT. SO THEY
DON'T DOT AS AN I. S. T.
SACRAMENTO COUNTY HAS DONE A IN
JAIL TO EVERY CENTER PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION. COLLABO WITH
PROBATION PUBLIC TO. ALONG WITH
A CHRONIC NOOSE OFFEND PROGRAM
NEVADA COUNTY LEVERAGES THEIR
CHAPLAIN GRANT AND GOT FORTY
PROGRAMMING EACH USE CASE
MANAGERS IN THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE TO ENSURE
TREATMENT AND HOUSING AS PART OF
THEIR DIVERSION. VENTURA COUNTY
HAS COMMUNITY SERVICES
COORDINATORS THAT WORK AND
DEPLOYED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT SH
CHIU AS SENATOR EGGMAN TALKED
ABOUT TO BUILD TRUST AND ENGAGE
HIGH RSK PEOPLE AND COMMUNITY.
AND SEPARATE IN A COUNTY THEY
FOUND THAT IT TAKES FORTY FOUR
ZERO VISITS TO ESTABLISH A TRUST
WITH SOMEONE WHO WAS ON HOUSING
AND GET THEM TO ACTIVATE TO
TREATMENT BUT ONCE THOSE FORTY
VISITS ARE MADE. 92% SUCCESS
SUCCESS RATE AN ACTIVATION.
VOLUNTARILY ENTER TREATMENT. HM
MEMBERS. THE NUMEROUS YOU NEED
TO THAT COME WITH. COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT FOR AND WITH
SERIOUS MY ILLNESS SUBSTANCE USE
NAMES. AND WE HELPED IMPLEMENT.
AS WE HELPED IMPLEMENT STATE'S.
WE MUST BE CLEAR THAT IT WILL
TAKE TIME RESOURCE INVESTMENT
AND COLLABORATION THE MOST
IMPORTANT ACROSS MULTIPLE STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERS I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
OUR- PERSPECTIVE AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I KNOW OIL THE
OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PEOPLE
WANTED YOU TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S GO NOW TO- KIM
PETERSON A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS- MY NAME
IS COMPUTER ST AND I AM A SENIOR
ATTORNEY WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ON
THIS PANEL. WE ARE KNOWLEDGES
THAT DSHS I ASKED SOLUTIONS.
REFLECTS STAKEHOLDER INPUT THAT
URGED IMPLEMENTATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED SOLUTIONS THE
ISP WEIGHTLESS CRISIS. FIFTY S.
H. ABLE TO CARE OUT THE MASSIVE
EXPAND OF FELONY I ASKED YOU TO
VERSION AND COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION THAT IT PROPOSED IT
IS. THESE EFFORTS WILL HOPEFULLY
LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR GREATER
REFORMS THAT WILL POSITIVELY
IMPACT THE. JUSTICE INVOLVED ARE
AT RISK. DSHS IDENTIFIED THAT A
CYCLE OF HOMELESSNESS
DISENGAGEMENT FROM BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND INVOLVEMENT
IN THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM IS
A LEADING DRIVER OF INCREASING
FELONY I ISSUE REFERRALS AS SUCH
D. R. C. AND OTHERS ON THIS
PANEL INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
THE ACLU. I REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO ALLOW
DSHS DIVERSION PROGRAM TO SERVE
PEOPLE AT RISK OF BEING FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL ON
FELONY CHARGES. WHAT MEETING DSA
STARBURST AND ONLY TWO PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY BEEN DOWN
INCOMPETENT AS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
BREAK THE CYCLE FOR PEOPLE WHO
MAY EVENTUALLY BE FOUND I. ESTY
AND FIND THEMSELVES ON A WAIT
LIST. TURNING TO THE SECOND
QUESTION POSED TO THE R. C.
ABOUT OTHER SUGGESTED REFORMS TO
ENSURE APPROPRIATE. TREATMENT
OPTIONS FOR JUSTICE INVOLVED
PEOPLE WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS. WE AND- JUST STATE
DOCKS POLICIES THAT ENCOURAGE
EXPANSION OF EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES THAT ARE PROVEN TO
DISRUPT THE CYCLE OF
HOMELESSNESS DISENGAGEMENT FROM
TREATMENT. AND INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. TO
THIS POINT DSHS RESEARCH SHOWS A
LEADING FACTOR IN THE NATION
WIDE INCREASE IN HIGHEST YOU
REFERRALS IT'S AN ADEQUATE
GENERAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN THE COMMUNITY INCLUDING
ASSERTIVE COMMUNITY TREATMENT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ACT. THE R.
C. WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE STATE
TAKES STEPS TO EXPAND THE AREA
THE AVAILABILITY OF ACT WHICH IS
AN EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICE THAT
OFFERS A WIDE RANGE OF COMMUNITY
BASED MEDICAL AND SOCIAL
SERVICES TO PEOPLE LIVING WITH
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS. IF
DELIVERED WITH FIDELITY TO THE
MODEL ACT IMPROVES OUTCOMES FOR
PEOPLE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS YOU ARE MOST AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS
IN HOSPITALIZATION AND
INVOLVEMENT IN THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM. THERE IS ALSO A
FORENSIC MODEL OF ACT
SPECIFICALLY TAILORED TO THE
NEEDS OF JUSTICE INVOLVED PEOPLE
. THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM
ASSESSMENT PUBLISHED LAST MONTH
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. INDICATES THAT A. C.
T. THAT IS PROVIDED WITH
FINALITY TO EVIDENCED BASED
MODEL IS NOT WIDELY AVAILABLE IN
CALIFORNIA. TWO IDEAS COME TO
MIND FOR EXPANDING THE
AVAILABILITY OF A CTR STATE.
FIRST THE STATE COULD ALIGN THE
REGULATIONS GOVERNING FULL
SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS ARE FSP IS
WHAT THE EVIDENCE BASED MODEL
FOR A. C. T. THOUGH THE ADDRESS
P. IS DESIGNED TO BE A WHATEVER
IT TAKES APPROACH IT DOES NOT
HAVE TO ADHERE STEP PROVEN MODEL
OF ACT. IN ADDITION THERE IS
GREAT VARIABILITY ACROSS THE
STATE AND HOW COUNTIES OPERATOR
AT THIS PROGRAM. SECOND CAL
COULD STICK APPROVAL FROM CMS TO
INCLUDE A C. T. AS A MEDIC CAL
SPECIALTYMENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
UNDER SECTION ONE ONE ONE FIVE
WAIVER. AS OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE. AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR INVITING DRC'S BE PART OF
THIS PANEL AND I AM HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- NOW LET'S GO TO OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDER STEPHANIE. REGULAR.
KAREN COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAME
STEPHANIE REGULAR I'M A BOARD
MEMBER CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDER ASOCIATION A PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
THE SUPERVISOR OF THE CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
MENTAL HEALTH YET I TESTIFIED
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CPA AND NOT
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. ON BEHALF
OF. I AM GIVING US ATTENTION TO
THE SEVENTEEN HUNDRED MEN AND
WOMEN CURRENTLY CONFINED IN JAIL
CELLS WAITING FOR NECESSARY
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT. AND I
SUPPORT THE PROPOSALS TO
INCREASE THAT CAPACITY EXPANDS
COMMUNITY BASED RESTORATION. AND
THE DEFENSE FUND IS A SMALL
DIVERSION PROGRAMS. HOWEVER TO
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE NINETEEN
WEIGHTLESS AND TO TREAT THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO SUFFER FROM MENTAL
ILLNESS. BUT THE TECHNIQUE CARE
THAT THEY DESERVE. FINDING TO
DIVERT THESE INDIVIDUALS SHOULD
OCCUR AT ALL STAGES OF THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. INCLUDING
AT THE FIRST PLEASE CONTACT.
AFTER REST AFTER I NEED A
COMPETENCY AND AFTER RESTORATION
. THIS PURPOSE TWENTY FOUR POINT
NINE MILLION AN ADDITIONAL SIXTY
SIX POINT EIGHT MILLION FOR
STABILIZATION EARLY ACCESS TO
TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS I
GUESS IT JUST WAIT. BUT AN
INDIVIDUAL IS NOT PLACED ON THE
ESTATE JUST WAIT LIST
IMMEDIATELY UPON ARREST THE TIME
BETWEEN ARREST AND COMMITMENT
TAKES MONTHS IF NOT YEARS. THAT
MEANS THAT NINETY ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED
FOR EARLY TREATMENT WILL ONLY BE
PUT TO USE SEVERAL MONTHS AFTER
MENTALLY ILL PERSONS INITIAL
CONFINEMENT. AND ONLY FOR THOSE
IN JAIL. BASED ON DSP DESIGN
RESEARCH 45% OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ON THE WAIT LIST. JUST YOU
KNOW MORE TIME. MANY OF THOSE
INITIAL ARRESTS FOR MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSES RESULTING FROM ACUTE
SYMPTOMS OF MENTAL ILLNESS. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT ALLOCATED
ANY FUNDING TO SUPPORT MENTALLY
ILL PEOPLE CHARGED WITH
MISDEMEANORS. NOR DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
SUPPORT THOSE TANSITIONING FROM
JAILS TO THE COMMUNITY. EARLY
ACCESS TO TREATMENT AND
DIVERSION SURE CARL LONG BEFORE
THE FIFTEENTH ARREST IN PLACE
SPENT ON THE STATE HOSPITAL WAIT
LAST. WE CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT
EXPECT REDUCE THE WAIT LIST IF
THE STATE DOES NOT ADDRESS THOSE
UPSTREAM AT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
TARGETED SOLUTIONS. TO MAXIMIZE
OPPORTUNITIES OPPORTUNITIES TO
DIVERT INDIVIDUALS LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUST HAVE ACCESS TO
SEPARATE CENTRIST CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL FOR THOSE IN NEED OF
IMMEDIATE CARE. COUNTIES NEED
FUNDING TO BURKE TO DIVERT ALL
INDIVIDUALS ELIGIBLE FOR
COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT NOT
JUST THOSE IDEAS SIX WEEKS LAST.
AND THOSE WHO ARE UNLIKELY TO BE
RESTORING GREATLY DISABLED MUST
BE REDIRECTED TO APPROPRIATE
SYSTEMS OF CARE AT THE BEGINNING
RATHER THAN THE END OF
COMPETENCY PROCEEDINGS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT CONRAD AND KEEPS THE
PROGRESS OF THE STATE I FAILING
TO RECOMMEND COMMUNITY BASED
TREATMENT OR DIVERSION. THE
ANSWER SHOULD NOT BE TO FIND AN
INDEPENDENT PANEL TO DO
CONTRACTS JOB. WHILE STILL
FINDING CONRAD. THE ANSWER
SHOULD BE TO DISPATCH CONRAD.
THE MINISTRY CERTAINLY. IT'S
JUST PROPOSAL FIFTY DECREE.
FRAME MANY'S COMMITTEE WITH CARE. BUT I THE COMMITTEE AND THE
ACCORDING ASK OF PROPOSAL FIRST
DEFINING PROVIDES GRET NEW BAD
AND NOT SOMETHING REPURPOSE IT
BY FOR D. YES. IT IS WOULD ONLY
PUT FURTHER STRAIN AND GREAT I
JUST COME FOR THE LIMIT NUMBER
MENTAL THAT'S CURRENTLY IN.
SECOND THE STATE DO MORE TO HELP
THOSE IN NEED OF THE AND THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AS UPON THEIR-
NOT JUST FOR THE- PERIOD OF
TIME. AT THE- LESS. AND FINE. WE
CONTINUE TO USE OUR- AS A CRUTCH
ARE VERY BROKEN MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM. AS LONG AS THE STATE
CONTINUES TO POUR MONEY INTO
JAIL TREAT MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE
ARE DEALS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
OUR DE FACTO CRISIS CENTERS. I
HAVE TO BELIEVE THAT JUST
BECAUSE WE FIND YES SILENCE AT A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO DEPLORABLE
THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS WILL
FIND OUR STATE JAIL BASED
TREATMENT EQUALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE RIGHT NEXT
TO CRISIS DOES NOT MAKE IT ANY
MORE JUSTIFIABLE OR ANY LAST.
THANK YOU. FOR HEY MAN. LET'S GO
TO BRENDA GRAIN LASH FROM THE
COUNCIL CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE GOOD
MORNING I THANK YOU SENATOR
EGGMAN CENTER POUND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH OR C. C. G. B. H. MY NAME
IS BRENDA GREALISH AND I'M
CURRENTLY CCG BEATRICE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER PRIOR TO THAT I WAS
ACTUALLY COUNCIL MEMBER SINCE
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
CCB WHICH IS A TWELVE MEMBER
COUNCIL CHAIRED BY THE SECRETARY
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
AND IS COMPRISED OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AS WELL AS APPOINTED
REPRESENTATIVES WHO ARE EXPERTS
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH FIELD SUCH AS
PROBATION COURTS AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AS WELL AS EDUCATION. AND
CONSUMERS ARE FAMILY MEMBERS. A.
B. H. CONTRACT WITH NO. OR ARE
REPRESENTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE IN THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEMS. SO THAT THEIR
PERSPECTIVES ARE INCLUDED WHEN
DEVELOPING OUR ANNUAL
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
IN OUR ANNUAL LEGISLATIVE
REPORT. AND TRANSFORM OUR
DISCUSSIONS AND OUR WORK
PRODUCTS. OVER TWENTY YEARS PAGE
HAS WORKED TO DECREASE THE
PREVALENCE OF INDIVIDUAL
SUFFERING WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESSES WHO BECOME
INCARCERATED IN JAILS AND
PRISONS BY ADVOCATING FOR MORE
ROBUST COMMUNITY BASED TREATMENT
AND SUPPORT SYSTEMS.
UNFORTUNATELY EXISTENCE ON OUR
OUR LEGISLATIVE REPORTS THERE
CONTINUES TO REMAIN A STUBBORNLY
PERSISTENT OVER REPRESENTATION
OF INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
ILLNESSES IN JAILS AND PRISONS
WHICH IS ALSO REFLECTED IN THE
HIGH NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS ON
THE APARTMENT SHE HOSPITAL'S
FELONY I JUST YOU WAIT LISTS.
AND GIVEN OUT RIGHT NOW WE JUST
HAVE AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
TO RIGHT THIS WRONG USING
INVESTMENTS AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE. IN THE PAST COUPLE OF
YEARS AS WELL AS THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN ARE BEING PROPOSED FOR THE
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR. I CAN SAY
I'VE BEEN IN THIS FIELD FOR
TWENTY YEARS AND GOVERNMENT AND
THIS IS JUST. AN UNPRECEDENTED
TIME FOR INVESTMENTS IN OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEMS ARE
VERY EXCITED. TO BE PART. OF
THIS THESE EFFORTS. OTHER BURKE
STATE HOSPITAL I S. T. SO.
PROPOSAL IS AND- SHE COMES. OF
OUT THE M. BUT IT'S BEEN SORELY
NEEDED FOR DECADES. CCAB H. AS
LONG ADVOCATED FOR COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT RATHER THAN
PLACING INDIVIDUALS AND LOCAL
JAILS PRETTY MUCH THREW. OUT THE
ENTIRE DURATION OF OUR EXISTENCE
I CAN GO BACK TO THE EARLIEST
LET'S REPORTS ARM AND SEE THAT
THAT THIS CONGRESS CONVERSATIONS
WERE- WERE BEING MADE-
OCCURRING. SH AND THE DISH
DIVERSION PROGRAM. PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITIES. TO ACHIEVE THIS
VISION. SINCE TWO EIGHTEEN
SEASON GBH COLOR CLOSELY WITH
DISH ON THEIR DIVERSION PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDED A- QUITE A BIT
OF. DIVERSION TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BECAUSE
DIVERSION IS AN EFFECTIVE
INTERVENTION AND STABILIZATION
ALONG WITH. THE RESULTS FROM THE
RISK ASSESSMENTS ARE KEYS TO
UNLOCKING THE CONFIDENCE AMONG
CRIMINAL JUSTICE PARTNERS SO
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE TOO.
SO THAT THEY KNOW THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL NOT POSE A
THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY. AS SUCH
BY PROVIDING STABILIZATION
SERVICES LONG WITH THE
NECESSARY CARE COORDINATION
DISHES PROPOSAL WILL MOVE THESE
INDIVIDUALS CLOSER TO COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT RATHER THAN
INCARCERATION BASED TREATMENT TO
THE POINT OF START MY SUMMER
ME. I'M WITH THREE TO DISHES
PROPOSED TRICKS YOUR FELONY I
TEACHING PRO. VIA COMMITTEE
BASED REST- AND DIVERT AND THEN
INCREASE CHRISTMAS TO CONRAD AND
TRANSITION TO COUNTY SERVICES.
AGAIN YOU SEE GBH LONG ADVOCATED
FOR MORE HOUSING AS WELL AS A
RESIDENTIAL AND PSYCHIATRIC IN
PATIENT TREATMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS USED INCLUDING THOSE WHO
BECOME. WITH THE CRIMINAL JUST
INVOLVED WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM- FOR HOUSING
WE'VE MADE. IS RIGHT. ON OUR AND
LARGEST REPORTS I DEVELOPED FACT
AND FULL REPORT I'M SO. MOST
RECENTLY LAST WE- LAUNCHED A
REPORT FUNDED BY THE MELVILLE.
TRUST WITH THE COUNCIL ON STATE
GOVERNMENT'S JUSTICE CENTER OUR
ENTITLED REDUCING HOMELESSNESS
FOR PEOPLE WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS LEAVING PRISONS AND
JAILS. AND LATE LAST YEAR AND ON
UNTIL APRIL THIS YEAR WE WERE
EXCITED TO LAUNCH A WEB IN OUR
SERIES WITH ERIC JOHNSON STATE
GOVERNMENT'S JUSTICE CENTER
FUNDED BY THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE FOUNDATION- TO. EDUCATE ON
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THAT
REPORT ON YOUR WEB IN OUR SERIES
ENTITLED BUILDING BLOCKS FOR
COMING HOME. HOW CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES CAN CREATE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE WITH
COMPLEX NEEDS. LEADING THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM. CCJ BEAD ALSO.
FEEDBACK THE U. S. IN. COUNCIL
ON. SEVEN FORMER DEVELOPMENT IN
THEIR NEXT FEDERAL STRATEGIC
PLAN TO THE DOCTOR KELLY'S POINT
ABOUT ON SOME OF THE- POLICIES
THAT ARE IN PLACE THAT BUT OFTEN
PREVENT OUR POPULATION- I. FROM
READ BUT SHE BEING ACCESS TO
HOUSING SERVICES SO I KNOW
THERE'S AFTER IT'S UNDER WAY TO
TRY TO ALLEVIATE- AND REMOVE
THOSE BARRIERS. AND THEN WENT ON
TO ACTUALLY. OR- HOMELESSNESS
AND HOUSING FIRST. IN ADDITION
ARE WITH REGARD TO RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN FOR OUR COUNCIL MEMBERS-
WHICH AGAIN PUT PUT
RECOMMENDATIONS ON OUR PRIOR
YEAR LEGISLATIVE REPORTS AND
COMES FROM SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LACK OF TREATMENT
CAPACITY WAS EXPRESSED AS
RECENTLY AS- DECEMBER AND
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
JANUARY TWENTY TWO. KOK COUNCIL
MEETINGS. ADDITIONS PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR HOUSING
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT CAPACITY
IS JUST ABSOLUTELY FOUNDATIONAL
IN ORDER FOR THEIR TREATMENT FOR
DIVERSION OF CLIENTS TO HAVE A
CHANCE OF BEING AFFECTED I CAN'T
STRESS HOW IMPORTANT HOUSING IS
A TRUE AND I'M SURE AFFECT OF
TREATMENT IT'S JUST IT'S JUST
ACTUALLY FOUNDATIONAL. ARE ON A
PARALLEL PATHS- OTHER EFFORTS
SUCH AS DHS'S CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INNOVATING MEDIKAL
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM OR EGYPT
AND CRISIS CARE MOBILE UNITS
PROGRAM PLUS OUR SOCIAL SERVICES
CALIFORNIA BERMAN SOCIAL
SERVICES COMMUNITY CARE
EXPANSION AND HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
AND CAL ICHR INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS IS EFFORTS I
WILL CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT THE
COMMUNITY INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WILL IDEALLY PREVENT ANY OR
FURTHER CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
MENTAL ILLNESSES. SO BASICALLY
IN SOME ADDITIONAL IDEAS TO
SOLUTIONS PROPOSAL OFFERS A
STABLE ONGOING. MUCH NEEDED.
BONDING SOURCE FOR FROM I AM YOU
DIVERT. WHICH IS A KEY. FOR THAT
FULL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUE
ON AND SOMETHING THAT I KNOW BAY
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH HAS
BEEN REQUESTING IN ORDER FOR
THEIR TREATMENTS TO BE A FACTOR
. ENCLOSING I'D ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
THAT WILL BENEFIT THIS
POPULATION. INCLUDING THOSE
RELATED TO PREVENTION EXPANDING
TREATMENT CAPACITY IN
INFRASTRUCTURE SO AGAIN CALENDAR
CRISIS RESPONSE EXTRA EXPANDING
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
WORKFORCE SO FORENSIC YOUR
SUPPORT SPECIALIST AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AND THE
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENT PROGRAM
SPOHR EXAMPLES AND HOUSING SO
THE BRIDGE HOUSING RETURNING
HOME WHILE AND HOUSING PROPOSED
AND- DISHES I S. T. SOLUTIONS
PROPOSAL. ALSO ANY EFFORTS THAT
CAN PROMOTE AND ENCOURAGE
COLLABORATION AMONG STATE
ENTITIES STATE AND LOCAL
ENTITIES AND AMONG LOCAL
ENTITIES. AND FORMER INDIVIDUALS
WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE AND THEIR
FAMILIES WILL BE ABSOLUTE KEY TO
MAXIMIZING THE- EFFICACY OF AND
EFFICIENCY OF THESE INVESTMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. LET'S NOW GO. TO
MICHAEL RATIO WITH THE ACLU. MY
NAME IS MICHAEL RESTORED-
COUNCIL. NORTHERN CALIFORNIA I
INVITING OUR INPUTS ARE ENGINE
COMES BE CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLES ARE AT ISSUE HERE.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE
SERVICE. WHAT LEGISLATURE CAN DO
TO PREVENT OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATIONS OF. THE RIGHTS OF ICE
TWO DEFENDANTS. STATE AND
FEDERAL COUNTY PROHIBIT THE
PROSECUTION OF A PURSE WHO IS
UNABLE TO ANSWER THOSE ON OUR
DEFENSE. WHAT THAT MEANS WHEN
ELSE DOWN ABOUT THE DEFENDANT'S
COMPETENCE CRIMINAL BUSQUETS.
THE DANGER THIS IS THAT WHEN
THAT HAPPENS OF THE CURRENT A
PROVISION THAT PROTECT CRIMINAL
DEFENDANTS RATES ARE EVAPORATES
AND PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANT
IMPORTANTLY THAT INCLUDES THE
RIGHT TO A SPEEDY TRIAL AND THE
RIGHT TO BAIL. FOR INGRAHAM TIME
THE COPS BACK THANK YOU CHARGED
WITH MINOR YOU FOUNDER. TO STAND
LITERALLY THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES IN PRISON FIFTY YEARS AGO
THE SUPREME COURT HELD THAT
VIOLATED DUE PROCESS. AND ANY
CONFINEMENT APPLIES TO DISTRACT
THEM OR SOMEONE SUSPECT BRST
MUST BE JUSTIFIED TOWARDS
EVALUATION AND THE ATTAINMENT OF
COMPLIMENTS. BASED ON THAT WILL
TWENTY CHANGE BECAUSE YOU'RE
YOU'RE CONTACTED THE STATE
HOSPITALS AND THE START BOUNCE
DEPARTMENT MITCHELL STARC. TO
STAY THAT THEY WERE BY. THIS
PRESS WAS CAUGHT. PRINCIPLE
BECAUSE THEY WERE. FAILING TO
PROVIDE TIMELY TREATMENT PEOPLE
. FOUND ISDN TO THEIR CAR BY OF
COURSE THE LANES RANGE JOHNSON
MONTHS MORE WE CONTACTED THEM
TRIED TO RESOLVE THE- SITUATION
THEY REFUSE THAT WE SUED THEM
AND AS YOU KNOW THE COURT AGREED
WITH US AND ISSUE THIS TWENTY
EIGHT DAY DEADLINE. NOW BECAUSE
OF. COURT RULING DSHS FINALLY TO
STEP TO ADDRESS THE LONG
STANDING PROBLEM HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
AT THIS POINT. IN TERMS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS ARE
LIKE THE REST OF THE PANELISTS
ARE WE AGREE WITH THE
OVERWHELMING GOALS. COMMUNITY
TREATMENT AND DIVERSION ARE MUCH
MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND MUCH
BETTER FOR HONESTY INDIVIDUALS
ARE NOT ONLY DO THEY FOR THE NEW
FOREIGN CARS RUSSIAN BUT THEY
HAVE BETTER LONG TERM. OUTCOMES
BECAUSE THEY ARE THEY INVOLVED
HOUSING IN THE COMMUNITY. ARE
THEY HAVE A BROADER FOCUS.
NEVERTHELESS THE DOUBLES THE
DETAILS AND I SHARE THE CONCERNS
RAISED ON PARTICULAR BY MISS
PETERSON IN THIS REGULAR- AND
ALSO I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GROWTH CAP THAT'S BEEN MENTIONED
BEFORE. ARE ALSO WE WILL NEED TO
MONITOR AND SEE HOW THE ON STAGE
IS ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING THESE-
THESE NEW PROPOSALS WITH
LEGISLATURE. YOU IN TERMS OF
PREVENTING OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL
VIOLATIONS OF THE RIGHT. THE
STATE REGULATOR GAUGING AFFECTED
ONLY ONE SLICE OF THE STOP OF
THIS. S. S. AND AS YOU HEARD
FROM HIS REGULAR THE DELAYS THAT
PROCEED YOU CAN COMPENSATE AND A
COMMITMENT TO THE STATE HOSPITAL
CAN CAN BE TRUSTED LONG CAN BE
LONGER AND CERTAINLY ARE JUST AS
HARMFUL AS THOSE DELAYS THAT WE
DEALT WITH AND STEER READY. TO
LEGISLATION TO REDRESS THOSE- BY
IMPOSING DEADLINES FOR THE
PROCESS OF APPOINTING ALIEN AS-
MAKING THE TERMINATION OF
INCUMBENCY OR NOT AND ALSO THE
COMMITMENT ACTUAL COMMITMENT
AFTER THAT. IT SHOULD ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE NONE. SPECIALIST
EVALUATE. OUR DEFENSE SEE
WHETHER THERE SPECTRUM. AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY SHE
THAT. IS AVAILABLE BEFORE THAT
COMMITMENT HERE AND IT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE THAT SOMEONE HAS
TO WAIT BE EVALUATED. MULTIPLE
EVALUATIONS BEFORE THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION NEEDS TO
HAPPEN MUCH EARLIER IN THE
PROCESS SO WE CAN DIVERT PEOPLE
OUT OF THIS EXTREMELY
LANDSCAPING- ONEROUS AND
EXPENSIVE PROCESS. AND OF COURSE
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS BUT IT'S NOT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANNELISE HEAR FROM SANDRA THIS
IS A MEMBER OF A FAMILY MEMBER
OF AN I. S. T. PATIENT WELCOME.
YOU'RE STILL ON MUTE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MY COUSIN CAN YOU CAN
YOU TURN UP THE VOLUME A LITTLE
BIT OR MOVE A LITTLE BIT CLOSER
TO THE MICROPHONE. IS THAT
BETTER THAT'S MUCH BETTER THANK
YOU. MY CONCERN WAS. CHRISTMAS
DAY IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND HE WAS
CHARGED WITH MAKING TERRORIST
THREATS. R. THIS WAS DIRECTLY
LINKED TO HIS MENTAL. HE'S HAD
NO PRIOR CONVICTIONS IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A JUDGE FOUND
HIM INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
HE HAS BEEN IN CUSTODY FOR FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWELVE DAYS SINCE
HIS ARREST. A THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT DAYS. SINCE HIS
COMPETENCY DETERMINATION HE HAS
NOT BEEN TRANSFERRED TO A STATE
HOSPITAL HE HAS NOT BEEN
DIVERTED. HE DOESN'T REALLY
RECEIVE ANY KIND OF TREATMENT WE
WERE HOPING THAT HE WOULD GET
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION BUT THAT
DID NOT HAPPEN. AT THIS TIME MY
COUSIN IS LOCKED UP IN A CELL
FOR OVER TWENTY THREE HOURS A
DAY. FOR THE FORTY FIVE MINUTES
IT IS ALLOWED OUT HE TAKES A
SHOWER AND HE CALLS ME. EVERY
DAY WHEN HE CALLS ME HE ASKED ME
THE SAME QUESTION. WHEN AM I
GOING TO GET OUT. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S TÌM KIÞM. MY COUSIN IS
AUTISTIC. HE HAS SCHIZO
AFFECTIVE DISORDER. FROM THE
TIME THAT HE WAS A YOUNG BOY HE
WAS PLACED IN AND OUT OF MENTAL
HOSPITALS HE ALSO SUFFERED
SEVERE PHYSICAL ABUSE. AT HOME
AND AT SCHOOL. MIKE IS NOT. HE
DOES HAVE MELTDOWNS BECAUSE OF
THE AUTISM. HE DOES STRUGGLE
WITH HEARING VOICES IN HIS HEAD
. BUT WHEN HE HAS A GOOD SUPPORT
STRUCTURE AND YOU READ IRAQ JIM.
YOU CAN GET THROUGH THOSE
MELTDOWNS. JOHN SMALL WAS HIS
ROCK AND HE WAS VERY PROTECTIVE
OF HER. SHE PASSED AWAY ONE
MONTH. AFTER JOHN GOT ARRESTED.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND
THAT HIS MOM IS GONE HE THINKS
THAT WHEN HE COMES BACK OVER
HERE THAT. SHOWING ERROR. I'M
SORRY. BUT WHEN JOHN WAS TAKEN
INTO CUSTODY HE LOST HIS HOUSING
I HAVE FOUND IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING HE'S LOST HIS SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS HE LOST HIS
PERSONAL POSSESSIONS BECAUSE WE
HAD TO VACATE THE APARTMENT I
BELIEVE THAT MY COUSIN HAD BEEN
PLACED IN A COMMUNITY TREATMENT
PROGRAM HE WOULD HAVE RESPONDED
TO TREATMENT ONCE AGAIN HE'S
NEVER BEEN VIOLENT HE'S NEVER
HIT ANYBODY HE JUST USES WORDS
HEARING HAS NOT FOUND. AT THE
TIME THAT HE WAS TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY. I TRIED SO HARD TO FIND
PSYCHIATRIST. SOCIAL WORKERS
CASE MANAGEMENT FOR HIM BUT
BECAUSE THE CULPRIT I THINK THE
SERVICES ONE LIKE WHAT EXISTED
SO AT THE LAST MINUTE THE
APPOINTMENTS WOULD BE CANCELED.
NOW WHILE HE'S IN CUSTODY HE
DOES SEE A PSYCHIATRIST I
BELIEVE OVER. THE TELEVISION AND
HE SEES THIS DOCTOR EVERY THREE
MONTHS FOR ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES
AND THEN ON OCCASION A SOCIAL
WORKER MAY COME TO VISIT. I'D
LIKE TO SEE MY COUSIN COME HOME
AND RECLAIM HIS LIFE. I BELIEVE
THAT HE WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERSION PROGRAM
THAT WOULD ALLOW HIM TO GET
CLOSE TO HOME AND HE'S WELCOME
IN MY HOME. AND IT WOULD AVOID
CONVICTION. ON HIS RECORD. IT
WOULD ALLOW HIM TO BE ABLE TO
SIX CARE AFFORDABLE HOUSING ONCE
AGAIN. I HOPE THE CALIFORNIA
REFORM SEX CRIMINAL MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM ALL PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE ACCESS TO TREATMENT THEY
NEED WITHIN THE COMMUNITY I
DON'T THINK SHE WAS A PLACE FOR
PEOPLE LIKE JOHN. WHO STRUGGLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESSES AND IN
ESSENCE ARE ABANDONED WAREHOUSE
AND FORGOTTEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
IN AND THANK YOU FOR BEING SUCH
A GOOD COUSIN. I KNOW THAT'S A
TOUGH JOURNEY TO TEST. TO GO ON
AND I'M ALSO SORRY FOR THE LOSS
OF YOUR AUNT- WHAT COUNTY DO YOU
LIVE IN MA'AM. UNDER CURRENT
RATE KERN COUNTY OKAY AND I
DISCUSSED OUR STUFF TO FOLLOW UP
TO SURE ACCESSING REESE WE CAN.
MMHM BERMAN SANDBERG AND HER
COUSIN- THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS AND THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS THAT YOU'VE BEEN WILLING
TO ENGAGE IN A AND OF COURSE ALL
OF YOU POINT TO THE AT THE- BUT-
THE WHOLE THE GAPS. IN OUR
SYSTEM AND THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN FALLING THROUGH FOR YEARS
AND YOU ALL OF KNOWLEDGE THAT.
IN THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE HAVE
MADE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS. IN
ALL OF KNOWLEDGE THAT IT WILL
TAKE A WHILE FOR ALL OF THESE.
DOLLARS IN INVESTMENTS TO HIM TO
BE WHERE THEIR SUPPOSED TO BE.
BUT AS WERE ENVISIONING THIS-
THIS GREAT NEW FUTURE- I WANTED
TO ASK DR KELLY IF SHE COULD
RESPOND- IF YOU COULD RESPOND
BOTH TO- I DIDN'T MISS REGULARS
A POINT ABOUT HOW MANY TIMES.
THAT THAT THERE IS NO THERE'S NO
CONTACT WHILE PEOPLE ARE HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED SOME BABY FORTY
TIMES UNDER MISDEMEANORS REYES
AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED THAT BEFORE
THAT IS A HUGE ISSUE TO SPEAK TO
THAT WHAT WHAT THE COUNTIES ARE
DOING ARE THERE ANY. OTHER ANY
COUNTIES THAT ARE DOING IT A LOT
BETTER. AT BEING ABLE TO DO
EARLIER INTERVENTIONS AND
PREVENTIONS AND THEN ALSO TO
RESPOND TO- THE COMPUTER SINCE
POINT ABOUT THE- ACT OR A PACKED
OR SOME KIND OF EVIDENCE BASED.
ON A TREATMENT THAT THEN COULD
BE. IS ANYBODY USING ONE- IS OUR
OWN A. O. T. N. N. LINEUP I'M
LOOKING AT THE COMPONENTS OF IT
IN LINE WITH WITH SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AND WHEN PEOPLE TELL ME
STOP THERE BECAUSE IT WAS OF A
COUPLE QUESTIONS SO THEY RESPOND
TO. THEM WHAT IS THE COUNTIES
HAVE IN PLACE AND IS THERE ANY
CONSISTENCY- BUT THEN AGAIN I'M
AND I HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS TO
HOWARD HOWARD THE- THROUGH AN
HSA ENGAGED- OF THE PEOPLE
BEFORE WAY BEFORE THE
MISDEMEANOR THAT ARE THAT ARE
PILING UP. WHAT KIND OF EARLIER-
IDENTIFICATION AND INTERVENTION
ARE THE COUNTIES DOING ANSWER
ANY BEST PRACTICE MODEL. OKAY
THANK YOU VERYMUCH SENATOR
SOLOMON TRYING. FROM CUSTOMER.
ALMOST ALL OF OUR COUNTIES ARE
DOING OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT IN
SOME CAPACITY AND I CAN TALK TO
HEAR AN ORANGE COUNTY WE HAVE
ENTIRE TEAM ABOUT REACH AND
ENGAGEMENT WORKERS WHO THAT'S
WHAT THEY DO THEY GO OUT THEY
LOOK FOR FOLKS. WHO MIGHT BE IN
NEED OF SERVICES AND THEY START
BACK. INTENSA RELATIONSHIP
BUILDING THAT YOU ADDRESSED IN
ADDITION THEY ALSO ARE DEPLOYED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL CALL IF THEY
HAVE SOMEONE THAT THEY KNOW IS
PROBABLY DEALING WITH A MENTAL
ILLNESS OR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER AND THE TEAM ALSO GOES
AND TRIES TO ENGAGE THEM. 20% OF
THE FOLKS THAT WE AND WE ASK
CMS'S ABOUT STANDARD DROUGHT ALL
OF OUR COUNTIES AND- PRIVATE
INSURANCE COVERAGE WE STILL SEE
THEM WE STILL HOOKED THEM UP
WITH RESOURCES I WANT TO JUST
DROP THAT DIFFERENTIATION THAT
COUNTY IS CERTAINLY MEDIKAL
PROVIDER BUT WE ALSO ARE THAT
THE- SAFETY NET AND SO. WHEN WE
SEE SOMEONE IN NEED WE'RE NOT
JUST SAYING ARE YOU DON'T HAVE
AN ACCOUNT LIVING ON WE. ARE
CONNECTING THEM WITH THEIR
PROVIDER. ALSO PROVIDER. AND SO
THERE ARE OTHER. EVIDENCE BASE
PRACTICES AND SOME. FOR COUNTIES
OR DO IN SAN DINO THEY- AND-
FOR. ON ACTIVATION- ED TREATMENT
FROM. IN THAT WILL DEPLOYS. THE
SHARE. ARE HOMELESS. GROUP THEY
GO TO WHERE PEOPLE ARE IN NEED
IMPROVED. HOME YOU CAN AND THEY
STAR TO REALLY. BUILDING THEY GO
WITH EIGHT PUBLIC NURSE. I GO
WITH A- THESE SERVICE PARKED. OF
CAN MAKE PEOPLE HAVE. AND THEY
KNOW WHAT THIS BE AT WHAT IS A
TO THE- WE ACTIVATE THE TO TREAT
RIGHT NOW SO WE START ON
MEDICAID. AND WHILE WE ARE
GETTING THEM READY FOR HOUSING
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THAT CONNECTION WITH THEM.
AT YOUR POINT ABOUT GETTING
TREATMENT OUT IN ADDITION WE
ALSO NEED THEY ALSO USE
VETERINARY CARE THEY BRING UP
THAT WAS FOUND THAT'S ABOUT A
REALLY GOOD PRACTICE TO GET IN
WITH. A PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING ON
THE STREETS ENCAMPMENTS AND
SUCH. A LOT OF OTHER COUNTIES DO
THE VERY SAME THING THAT THEY
RESPOND. TO THE LARA IS. LARGELY
A O. T. PROCESS. NEVADA COUNTY
AS YOU NOW IS THERE VERY SIX.
WITH THAT. BY THE NUMBERS ARE
NOT VERY LOW ONE LOOKING AT A T.
H. MOVING TO THE- START OF A
TRAIN EACH. I'LL COUNTY JULY ACT
IT DOESN'T BASED PRACTICE MUCH
BY THIS HE'S ARE AN AVID BASED.
IN ORANGE AND NEW CAL HERE AND
CAL WE USE FS PEACE A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY AND WE HAVE THEM
FOR. A DIFFERENT POPULATION SO
ALL COUNTIES ARE DOING THEM
STANDARDIZED BUT WE ARE USING
THEM WITH POPULATIONS THAT MAKES
SENSE SO YOU MIGHT HAVE A
HOMELESS FSP WE WILL HAVE A
FORENSIC FSP SO THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE EXPERTISE IN PARTICULAR
POPULATION. SO THOSE ARE ALL
PRACTICES THAT WE ARE DOING AND
I'M A I WANT TO MAKE SURE I
POINT OUT THAT THOSE ARE NOT
MEDICAL BILLABLE SERVICES WE
MOSTLY USE I JUST EIGHT DOLLARS
AND NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT TO
LEVERAGE THAT WORK FORCE. WE ARE
NOT OPENING A CASE FOR SOMEONE
IN THE FIELD BECAUSE THEY DON'T
TRUST US ENOUGH TO COMPLETE OUR
FULL ASSESSMENT TO SIGN A
TREATMENT PLAN FOR US TO BEGIN
BUILDING YOU KNOW CALTRAIN WILL
CHANGE SOME OF THAT. THAT IS NOT
PRECLUDING **** OR PROHIBITING
US FROM ENGAGING IN SERVICES
WHEN WE FIND PEOPLE RECEIVE
REFERRALS WE ARE OUT THERE BUT
AS YOU STATED AS WELL A LOT OF
FOLKS ARE JUST NOT INTERESTED IN
OUR SERVICES AND IT IS UP TO US
AS CLINICIANS TO TALK THEM INTO
THAT. MOST OF THAT COMES WITH
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING AGAIN
FORTY VISITS FOR IN PERSON.
TWENTY FOR SOMEONE WHO IS LIVING
WITH THEIR FAMILY. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND I. EVERYBODY
WHO TO TALK TO HAS ALL. I MEAN
TECHNOLOGY RECORD. THE FEE. THE
CREW ROLE THAT HOUSE PLACE AND
ALL OF THIS. HE WE HAVE
SOMETHING GOING OFF YEARS. OKAY
THAT THAT HOUSING PLACE AND ALL
OF THIS- AND AGAIN THAT WE HAVE
REALLY BEEN WORKING VERY HARD TO
MAKE THOSE KINDS OF INVESTMENTS
AND OF COURSE THE FRUSTRATING
PART IS IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
TIME ANOTHER ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK WOULD DO ALLUDE TO
. OR I JUST HERE. IS THE A LACK
OF. DATA IN COORDINATION THAT WE
HAVE TO KNOW THE IMPACT OF SOME
OF THE INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY MADE. AND I OF COURSE IN
ALL OF US ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THAT- THANK YOU AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE PANEL- IN
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT- WE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT THE AND THE
CONTINUE ON WHICH INCLUDES THE
HIGH RISK AND I DO WANT TO. JUST
SIT ALSO SECOND- WHAT- CARE
EGGMAN SAID MAYBE THEY REALIZE
THAT THIS IS IN THE- YOU KNOW IN
SECTION FOR THE STATE HOSPITALS
AND THEY'RE ASKING A LOT OF TIME
WE'RE ASKING A LOT OF TOUGH
QUESTIONS BUT THIS IS OBVIOUS TO
SCOPE IT IS MUCH LARGER RIGHT.
AND IT THE AND SO FOR EXAMPLE WE
TALK ABOUT TAKING CARE OF PEOPLE
ARE AT RISK- HELLO WE SHOULD
HAVE. DGS HERE AND WE SHOULD
HAVE OTHER AGENCIES HERE AS WELL
ALL RIGHT BECAUSE- THEY'RE
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BEFORE PEOPLE GET HE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH IS. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
RIGHT AND TRYING TO- SO. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT I GUESS IF IT
THE FEW QUESTIONS I HAVE HERE-
SO. MAYBE FOR FIRST OF ALL FOR
DR KELLY- WITH- TO BE FOR HEALTH
DIRECTOR SO- DISABILITY RIGHTS-
TOUTED THIS- THE THING CALLED
THE START OF COMMITTEE
TREATMENT. AND SAYS CALIFORNIA
ISN'T DOING THAT- ARE YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS CAN YOU
ADDRESSES IT IS THAT I MEAN
IT'S- IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
THAT WE SHOULD BE EXPLORING.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE AS A
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL. THANK YOU
THE SENATE PANEL I WE ARE USING
THAT OKAY SO THAT IS REALLY
ACCESS TO CARE. RIGHT WELL
THERE'S OKAY WELL THEN I THINK
PERHAPS AS A CONVERSATION THERE
AND THAT- THAT NEED TO BE HAD
BECAUSE- AND THEN- THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD. WAS WAS
MENTIONED BY THE- A PUBLIC
DEFENDER AN AT NIGHT I CERTAINLY
AND- AGREED- WE TALK ABOUT
GETTING NEW BEDS IN THE
PROPOSAL- THAT THE- THESE WILL
GAIN BETTER WE'RE NOT JUST
DRAWING FROM THE EXISTING WELL
OF PSYCHIATRIC OR- MENTAL
HEALTH- BEDS BUT- TRYING TO
CREATE NEW BED SO- PERHAPS-
MAYBE SHOULD GO BACK TO THE- THE
POOREST. THE HOUSE WAS IS THE
FUNDING FOR THIS IT WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT GETTING MORE
HOUSING SO FORTH I KNOW SOME OF
THEM DO THIS REFERRED SOME OF IT
SEEM LIKE IT WAS NEW. PADS BUT-
ARE WE ARE WE PARTICULARLY
DIRECTING TOWARD ACTUALLY BILL
INCREASING THE CAPACITY NOT
CONTRACTING FOR BEDS THAT ARE
READY. FOR MENTAL HEALTH BUT AND
NOW THEY'VE TOLD PEOPLE. THE WAY
TO PLEASE FOR ICE TEA. THIS IS
CHRIS YES THAT'S CORRECT THIS
WOULD BE BUILDING NEW CAPACITY
NOT TAKING FROM THE EXISTING
COMMITTEE ASKING AVAILABLE. OKAY
ALL RIGHT- AND I GUESS THE
OTHER. THING IS AND I KNOW THE
INDIRECT EMENDATIONS AND- MANY
PEOPLE REFERRED TO CALTRAIN AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING TO
TEACHERS ABOUT CALLING- BUT I
ALSO. FOUND SOME BECAUSE JUST AS
THE WORLD CERTAINLY TREATING
OPPORTUNITIES- WE GOT TO DELVE
INTO THIS MORE AND MORE DETAIL
DTS. I ALSO KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW
TERMS OF PARTICULAR INTENSIVES
SERVICE KOREA- CARE COORDINATION
SO FORTH. I BELIEVE ONLY IF. THE
TICKET IF IT NOT IT'S NOT TO BE
BILLED EVERY IT'S ACTUALLY A
FAIRLY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE. SO ONE OF THINGS THAT WE
CAN BE HELPFUL IS- EXACTLY HOW
WHAT KIND OF KIND OF WHAT KIND
OF CAPACITY ARE WE LOOKING FOR
FROM CAL AIM TO SERVE CITIES
PARTICULARLY- TALENT YOU KNOW
HOW. MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGE TO
PATIENTS AND THEN SO QUICKLY
BECAUSE WE GO TO DHS WANTED SAY
OKAY WELL WHEN YOU'RE YOU KNOW
UNDER CALAMP. HOW MUCH OF THOSE
RESOURCES ARE YOU GONNA BE ON
THE RACKS TOWARD THIS PARTICULAR
PATIENT POPULATION SO IS. AND
MAYBE THIS IS A QUESTION BACK TO
DOCTOR KELLY SHE HAPPENS AND- OR
MAYBE THE COUNCIL. IN THEIR
DISCUSSIONS- BRENDA WILLIS. HAD
SOMEONE TRY TO QUANTIFY- WHAT'S
THE POPULAR ROUGHLY THE SIZE OF
THE POPULATION AND THE NEED THAT
WE'RE LOOKING TO- TO SERVE-
THROUGH CAL AIM TO IS AS A WAY
TO. ADDRESS ESSENTIALLY THE YOU
KNOW AT RISK POPULATION FORTY OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. SO
CAN I CAN EITHER ONE IF YOU
PERHAPS SPEAK TO- WHAT THE WHAT
THE NEED IS AND TO TAKE A
QUANTITATIVE LEVEL ALL RIGHT I.
SELL HOW. HOW MANY PEOPLE HOW
MUCH MONEY. I'LL TRY DO A I
MIGHT NOT KNOW OF EXACT BETTER
CALL IN FOR US ON THE BEACH
HEALTH SITES BEYOND WHAT THE MAN
CARE PLAN ARE DOING. IT WILL
ALLOW US. JAIL IN REACH WE HOPE
THAT WE CAN START NOW THAT YOU
KNOW THIS IT WHEN SOMEONE IS IN
JAIL THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY TURN
ON THE MEDIC CAL. NINETY DAYS
PRIOR AND TREAT THEM AND GET
PAID FOR THAT TREATMENT SO THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO EXPAND THE
AMOUNT OF SERVICES THAT WOULD BE
PROVIDING CUSTODY. FOR US ON THE
GROUND IT ALLOWS FOR NO WRONG
DOOR AND ALLOWS FOR AN EXPANSION
OF WHAT SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH
IS SO THAT IF I CAME ACROSS. A
YOUNG MAN WHO NEEDED SERVICES
BUT HE WASN'T AT MY LEVEL YET HE
WASN'T SEVERELY AND PERSISTENTLY
MENTALLY ILL. AND HE HAD A MILD
OR MODERATE ON THIS THE STANDARD
OF CARE IS THAT I WOULD REFER
HIM WARM YOU KNOW WARM HAND OFF
TO. A HAS MANAGED CARE PROVIDER
CALLING WILL ALLOW ME TO START
TREATMENT IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
PERHAPS I'VE DEVELOPED REPORT
WITH THEM. I CAN START TREATMENT
I CAN. BEGIN TO HELP AND TO
DETERMINE WHAT IT DIAGNOSES IT
IS HOW WE CAN BEST HELP CAPTURE
AND THEN IF IT IF HE IS IN NEED
OF A LOWER LEVEL CARE THEN
TRANSITION TOWN BUT I CAN
PROVIDE THE CARE RIGHT AWAY AND-
TO SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE I CAN
START TO BUILD MEDIKAL. WE DON'T
DO ANY OF THAT WE DON'T BILL FOR
AS I STATED IN CENTER EGGMAN
QUESTION WHEN WE'RE OUT DOING
CRISIS. STABILIZATION CRISIS
RESPONSE AND COMMUNITY WE DON'T
BILL FOR THE SERVICES SO IT
MAKES OUR RESOURCES WHICH ARE
ALREADY LIMITED BERRIES- EVEN
MORE LIMITED. YEAH SO. I'M SORRY
GO AHEAD. AND I'M TRYING TO ITS
AND EVERY TO YOU'RE SAYING- AND-
IT. I GUESS I'M TRYING TO DRILL
DOWN MORE AROUND THE- AREA. OKAY
SO YOU. S. MY- BUT IN THE END WE
CAN LOOK AT THE I STEEP I GUESS
IS THE PROGRESS MANY OF THE
UNFORCED TO MORE SO THEY SET UP
TIME MORE INTENSIVE CASE I TYPES
OF THINGS PRIOR TO IT HITTING
CHRONOLOGY SYSTEM. SO SANDRA
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE POPULATION
IS. SO WE START TALKING THE DCS
MORE TALK ABOUT CALAMP. SO YES I
THINK THERE'S AN OPERA IS ARE WE
GONNA TRY TO MEASURE THE SAMPLE
WHAT IS THIS FREE AT RISK
POPULATION. CANADA GETTING THE
SERVICES AND TO WHAT DEGREE DOES
ASIDE FROM THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IN THIS PARTICULAR YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH OF THIS. NEED TO AT RISK
YOU NEED RIGHTS TO TALK ABOUT
THIS NOW CREATE A FLOW CHART. WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY SERVE
THROUGH CAL AIM THAT WOULD ALSO
THAT IDEALLY HELP DIVERT THEM
FROM EVER HITTING THE COLONEL
JUSTICE SYSTEM SO. I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO QUANTIFY THAT.
I THIS IS BRENDA GREALISH- AND I
WOULD DEFER TO DH CS BECAUSE
VERY- YOU KNOW HOW TO DEVELOP
THE ESTIMATES FOR- ENHANCED YOUR
MANAGEMENT SO I'M NOT SURE. WHAT
WENT INTO THOSE ASSUMPTIONS FOR
OR FOR HOW TO GET QUANTIFY THAT
BUT THEY PROBABLY GET THE BEST
SOURCE FOR THAT INFORMATION.
OKAY SO- I WILL ASK THEM THAT
BUT I ALSO WANT TO KNOW ON THIS
AND MAYBE SOMEONE CAN IF YOU
DON'T HAVE IT NOW SO I CAN GET
BACK TO THIS WE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION WITH MURDER TALKING
MANY OF CARE MANAGEMENT AGO BY
TALK ABOUT. LOTS OF DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS RIGHT. I'M ACTUALLY
INTERESTED IN AS PARTICULAR ON
THE MENTAL HEALTH SIDE AND- MADE
A RELATION TO I WILL HI STEVE
DIRECTOR TO COME A JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT SO THE AT RISK
POPULATION. IS ONLY BE SURE WHEN
I HEAR FROM DH CS ABOUT ENHANCE
CARE MANAGEMENT. THAT IS
INCLUSIVE OF ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE WHO ARE
AT RISK FOR I. S. T. AND THAT-
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PROGRAM THAT STARTING FROM AT
RISK NOT JUST WHEN YOU FINALLY
END UP IN JAIL. SO FORTH MORE
DOWNSTREAM THAT WE ACTUALLY ARE
BUILDING UP THOSE RESOURCES AS
WELL SO- SO THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL BECAUSE WHEN WE HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION WITH DCS WE
WANT AT LEAST HAVE THAT IN OUR
MIND- AND- KNOW WHAT TO ASK. THE
CELLS ANYWAY ABLE TO HELP QUAN.
THE. I SEE SOUNDS. DIRECTOR
MOBILE CLINTON YOU WANNA TRY TO
RECORD. YEAH I DON'T KNOW IF
THE- IF AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW
RIGHT NOW I MEAN IT'S OKAY TO
SAY WILL WILL GET BACK TO YOU
WITH THAT AND MY APOLOGIES I
DIDN'T QUITE CATCH WHAT IS IT
WE'RE TRYING TO BUT IT WAS SO
AND ACTUALLY YEAH THAT'S WHAT I
WAS ASKING ABOUT WAS IS THAT-
YEAH PEOPLE TALKED ABOUT THE
CONTINUE ON RIGHT AND SO THAT
FOR EXAMPLE DISABILITY RIGHTS
AND I AGREE WITH THEM AND I
THINK MANY OTHER SAID WELL WE
NEED TO START WITH THE AT RISK
POPULATION RIGHT HOW MANY DINNER
AT RISK POPULATIONS TALK RIGHT.
BEFORE LEAVING HIS TELEPHONE
JUSTICE AND THEN- YOU CAN JUST
SENSE AND THEN THE JUDGE GOES-
BY THE WAY WE DO THE VALUATION
YOUR AND I. S. T. SO IT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY BE DIRECTOR YOU MAY
NOT ACTUALLY NO ACTUALLY IT
MIGHT ASK YOU FOR HELP DIRECTORS
BECAUSE YOU DEAL WITH PEOPLE
FARTHER UPSTREAM- BUT I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT IS
THE MAGNITUDE WHETHER THERE'S.
ANY EVALUATION OF OKAY. WHAT IS
THE AT RISK PART. GIVEN WHAT WE
SEE IN THE EYES TO. BASICALLY
WHAT'S THAT AT RISK POPULATION.
FEEDING THE ICE. THAT CREATING
THE ICY POPULOUS. YEAH JUST IT
YOU KNOW YOUR CRY WE WANT
WITNESS. BE ABLE TO SAY WHAT IS
THE TOTALING. POPULAR BUT YOUR
PRIME. INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
BEING COMMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT IS INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL A GREAT PORTION OF
THEM ARE INDIVIDUALS WITH
PSYCHOTIC DISORDERS. AND SO WE'D
BE LOOKING AT THAT THAT THAT YOU
KNOW INDIVIDUALS AND THE
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE YOU KNOW
I'M- VERY DIFFICULT TO TREAT- IT
MEANT YOU KNOW SERIOUS ILLNESS-
THE IS GONNA IN THAT. ROUND BUT
WHAT THAT UNIFORM BY WHAT THAT
UNIVERSE LOOKS LIKE AND THE SIZE
OF THAT UNIVERSE I CERTAINLY
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA. OKAY AND I
DON'T KNOW WITH THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS- MAIN DR KELLY
WIZARD IS THERE A WAY TO I MEAN
I JUST I HOPE. AND FOURTEEN
SEEMS LIKE MANY OF DON'T GET
HAVEN'T GOTTEN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
I S. T. BUT- IS THERE SOME
WEIGHTS IT DO YOU ARE YOU AWARE
OF US. SOURCE OF DATA FOR THAT
INFORMATION. I AM NOT ON THE TOP
HEAD BECAUSE OF ONE WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT. THESE FOLKS HOW
THEY GET TO THIS PLACE AND EVEN
HOW PEOPLE GET TO THAT YEAH THE
MEDICAL POPULATION THESE ARE
FOLKS WHO MIGHT HAVE PROBABLY
STARTED WITH COMMERCIAL
INSURANCE COVERAGE. AND THEN
THAT LAPSED BECAUSE THEY WERE
UNABLE TO WORK MAY BE COVERED BY
PARENTS AND WHATNOT OR IN THEIR
OWN. THROUGH THEIR THEIR JOB. SO
WE WOULD HAVE TO DRILL DOWN FOR
THAT AND WE DO A LOT WE HAVE A
LOT OF DATA. FOR A PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION AND FOLKS
WERE JUSTICE INVOLVED IN THE
JUVENILE JUSICE SYSTEM SO WE
COULD LOOK AT THAT AND GET BACK
TO YOU OKAY THAT THAT WOULD BE
GOOD AND IT'S AN INDICATOR
PRECISE NOT. JUST EVEN SCALE
RIGHT ARE WE TALKING YOU KNOW.
WE KNOW WE HAVE A THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED TO BACK UP LISTENERS
WE'RE TALKING TENS OF THOUSANDS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. YEAH AND-
IS AT THE DATA THAT WOULD BE
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH- YEAH AND
- AND- PRETTY- YOU FEEDBACK AND
I THINK. REALLY ARE LOW AT OF
THAT CAN. AND I'LL PRETTY GOOD.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT DEPART
STATE HOSPITALS IS STILL TAKING
CARE OF SO THAT ONE END. SO WE
GOT THANK YOU WHAT WE'RE TALKING
OTHER AGENCIES KNOW HOW THAT.
THE WHAT WE CAN DO TO GO FARTHER
UPSTREAM THANK YOU. THE THING
THAT THE- AND POINT AS WELL TO.
EVER EVERY HEARING WITH WE
SHOULD BE ABOUT S. T. AND NOT
JUST WITH THE STATE HOSPITAL. UP
AND I WOULD AND I KNOW- DIGESTED
A AB WE ASKED ALSO THE QUESTION
ABOUT LIKE HOW MANY BEDS DO WE
WHAT'S THE FOR. AND THEY DID A
FULLY. THAT I THINK THE STAFF
FROM HAS HAD QUITE TIME YET TO
DIG INTO BUT SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION YOU'RE ASKING FOR
MAYBE MAYBE THERE WE KEEP
TALKING KEEP TALK ABOUT WEED.
HOW MUCH WE NEED OR WHAT EXACTLY
IS IT PER COUNTY SO I THINK I
THINK THE COUNTIES ARE DONE BY
WISHING THAT CAME TO THE STATE
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT. TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
ANSWER SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS-
TO AGAIN THANK YOU TO OUR
PANELISTS FOR TAKING THE TIME.
AND I KNOW THIS WASN'T JUST A
ONE SHOT THING FOR YOU I MEAN I
KNOW YOU YOU ALL LIVE IN THIS
WORLD. AND SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK AS WE
CONTINUE. TO TRY TO HELP THE
MOST VULNERABLE. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND HAVE A SYSTEM
THAT WE CAN ALL FEEL GOOD ABOUT.
OKAY SO THEN NOW WE WILL MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE- WHICH IS
THE- THE DIRECT RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES. DIRECTOR REBECCA
YOU I THINK UNLESS YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE. RESIDENTS TO. THANK YOU
YES I WILL BE TAKING THE LINE IN
I'M ALSO BY THE WORK. WHO IS OUR
- STATE MEDIC DIRECTOR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- OUR OPERATIONS. THE
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES SIXTY
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE ITS CO
THE NINETEEN RESPONSE. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC WE
HAVE ACTIVELY WORKED ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM TO RESPOND TO THAT COULD
BE NINETEEN CHEN DEMING AND
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM TO IMPLEMENT SECTION
CONTROL MEASURES ESTABLISHING
TESTING PROGRAMS FOR PATIENTS
AND STAFF. DEVELOPING TREATMENT
PROTOCOLS ESTABLISHING EMISSION
OBSERVATION UNITS IN ISOLATION
SPACE AT EACH OF THE HOSPITALS
IN EVALUATING AND REPAIRING H.
FAX SYSTEMS- ASKED ME OF MY MANY
. THINGS AND THERE IS AN ERROR
OF OUR HOUSE THAT HASN'T BEEN
IMPACTED BY A I CALLED IT
NINETEEN. DURING THIS PAST
CALENDAR YEAR WE IMPLEMENTED
VACCINATION AND BOOSTER
CAMPAIGNS FOR BOTH PATIENTS AND
STAFF AND NAVIGATED THE IMPACTS
OF BOTH PARENTS STILL TEN
OMICRON. INCLUDING RESPONDING TO
THE CONSISTENTLY CHANGING
SCIENCE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE WE CONTINUE TO CONSULT
AND WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
HEALTH CARE REQUIRED INSPECTIONS
TEAM. AND OUR LOCAL COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT I CAN'T
EXPRESS ON THE GREATEST AMOUNT
OF APPRECIATION FOR BOTH AND
THEY'VE BEEN GREAT PARTNERS AND
IT DEFINITELY HELPED US TO
EVALUATE AND INVOLVED. OUR
CALVET NINETEEN RESPONSE TO THE
CHANGING GUIDANCE IN CONDITIONS.
THE FUNDING REQUESTED IT WILL
COVER THE ESTIMATED DIRECTOR
RESPONSE EXPENDITURES IN THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR ABOUT PERSONAL
SERVICES AND TESTING- WE ARE
REQUESTING FIFTY POINT SIX
MILLION FOR PERSONAL SERVICES
FOR THE STAFF TIME WHO IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO COVER
NINETEEN RESPONSE. AND FOURTEEN
MILLION PROTESTING TO INCLUDE
PATIENT AND STAFF TESTING ALL
LOCATIONS. WERE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALEJO. THANK YOU SENATOR AT
- NO FROM THE IN THIS ISSUE
PARTNER FINANCE. NO COMMENTS
OKAY THANK YOU FOR MUCH. CAN YOU
JUST ME ABOUT ARE ASSUMING THAT
YOU'RE PRETTY MUCH A HUNDRED
BACK RATE FOR YOUR AND YOUR
PUPPY. AND HOW ABOUT FOR YOUR
STAFF. THERE ARE PATIENTS AHEAD
WE EIGHTY PERCENT- ARE
VACCINATED WITH THEIR ONE OR TWO
DOES AN 83% OF PATIENTS WHO ARE%
ELIGIBLE FOR BOOSTERS HAVE
RECEIVED THEIR MINISTERS HAVE
FOR STAFF WE HAVE 83% BETTER
VACCINATED IN 69% TO DATE- HAVE.
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR BOOSTERS
HAVE RECEIVED INVESTORS OKAY AND
IS ANY OF THE FUNDING THAT YOU
NEED RELATED TO- STAFF AVERAGES
BECAUSE OF LACK OF VACCINATIONS. I'M SORRY WAS DUE TO NOT BEING
FULLY VACCINATED AND THEREBY-
REPEATING TIME OFF FROM WORK.
SEVENTEEN ISOLATION IT YES SO
SOME OF THE REQUEST WOULD BE
THAT'S THE THING THAT MONEY
THAT'S BEING REQUESTED IS REALY
TO COVER HER STAFF COVERAGES I'M
RELATED TO A COUPLE NINETEEN BUT
GENERALLY MORE TOWARDS THE
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING PROVIDED
BUT ULTIMATELY AND WE CERTAINLY
DO HAVE- INDIVIDUALS THAT- YOU
KNOW HOW BOTH VACCINATED AND
UNVACCINATED AS A RESULT OF-
PARTICULARLY WITH THE OMICRON
VARIANTS THAT ARE EXPERIENCING A
CODE HONEST AND HAVE TO. BE I AM
OFF WORK. THANK YOU OKAY
TECHCRUNCH. OKAY WITHOUT
APPRECIATE THAT- AND WE WANTED
TO MINIMIZE THE TO THE PATIENT-
BUT A HIGHER RATE OF AN- IF YOU
BUT THAT'S ALSO BE DISCUSSED
ABOUT- PRESIDENT IN TO SO- IT'S
THEIR TO BEEN TO UP DELAYS OR
PUT MORE FILTRATION. YES WE HAVE
DONE- IN A- ACROSS ALL THE
HOSPITALS THE NEEDS THERE WERE
AND- RIGHT A BIT OF ACTIVITY
AROUND THE HOUSE THEY ARE EACH
FAX SYSTEMS- WE HAVE- REPAIRED
THINGS WE HAVE BROUGHT INTO. HAS
SCRUBBERS WE'VE CERTAINLY.
BROUGHT IN HELP WITH SELTERS
I'VE DONE QUITE A BIT AND
MODIFICATIONS AND IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE H. FAX SYSTEM SENSE THAT
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC OKAY
AND THE TERMS OF I KNOW WHICH
WHICH IS JUST GETTING OUT OF-
AKON HOW DID THE STATE HOSPITALS
FAIR IN TERMS OF OUTBREAKS. AND
SO FORTH- PLEASE TELL HER YOUR
UPGRADE ANNALY SYSTEM WE GOT. AL
JUST T. MAY BE PRETTY COMMON AND
IN THE PAST MONTH OR MONTH TO A
HALF A- I DON'T HAVE STATE
HOSPITALS FAIR. YEAH IT'S
CERTAINLY- WE KNOW WE ARE
CONGREGATE AND LIVING IN BY AND
ME HOW UNIT SIR JOHN- IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF ABOUT FIFTY BEDS
BUT THEY'RE USUALLY 325% DORMS
SO IT IS A VERY DIFFICULT ONE-
OMICRON OR ANY OF THE VARIANCE-
I GET AN ITS DEBT IT DOES.
PRESENT CHALLENGES- WE NEED VERY
MUCH ANY TIME THERE IS COMMUNITY
SEARCH EXPERIENCE A SURGE WITHIN
OUR HOSPITALS AS WELL I'M
CERTAINLY WE BEGAN TO SEE THE
IMPACTS REALLY TOWARDS THE END
OF DECEMBER AND BEGINNING OF
JANUARY WHERE AND MANY STAFF
WERE BECOMING POSITIVE I'M IN
YOU KNOW THE B. AS THE COMMUNITY
RATES ROSE- WE EXPERIENCED A LOT
OF STAFF OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST MONTH AND MONTH AND A HALF
THAT IT. BECAME. M. IMPACTED BY
COBIT. ALL TO THAT WE I'M THEY
ASKED READ HOW- WE DO IN IN. IN
TURNS TO THE PATIENTS DESPITE OF
THE PROTECTIVE FACTORS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE BUT I DO HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT IT WITH THIS THIRD
SHOT I'M- WE SAW LESS IMPACT TO
THE PATIENTS THAN WE HAVE IN
PREVIOUS SEARCHES- ULTIMATELY
WHAT WE NORMALLY SEE OR WHAT WE
HAD SEEN IN PRIOR IS THAT ONCE
THE AND- ONCE. I'M OUR STAFF
BECOME POSITIVE AND A COUPLE
WEEKS LATER WE START TO
EXPERIENCE PATIENT POSITIVES AND
OFTEN THOSE PATIENT POSITIVES
WILL REACH ALMOST TO THE SAME
LEVEL OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH
THE STAFF IN THIS YEAR BUT IN
WITH OMICRON WE SAW MATCHING
GREATER STAFFS- POSITIVES THEN-
WE SAW IN THE PATIENT POSITIVES
THIS TIME. AND WE ATTRIBUTE THAT
TO ALL OF THE A PROTECTIVE
FACTORS WE'VE PUT IN PLACE AS
WELL AS THE DAILY ANTIGEN
TESTING THAT WE ARE DOING FOR
OUR DIRECT PATIENT CARE STAFF.
TO HELP TO TRY TO PREVENT
INDIVIDUALS FROM WORKING WHO ARE
IN IDENTIFYING THAT THE EARLIEST
POINT- TO- T THEIR ILLNESS OKAY
THANK YOU AND I THINK IT PERHAPS
SPEAKS TO THE ALL THE GOOD WORK
HE DID BECAUSE THE FACT THAT.
THE INTENT OF THE STATE VIRGINS
BECAUSE OF COURSE THE STAFF IS
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY TO GO HOME.
IT'S AT- AND- ALONE THE PATIENTS
WHO ARE ARE CONFINED TO THE TO
THE HOSPITAL'S PERFECT THAT THEY
DID NOT EXPERIENCE AS MUCH OF A
SPIKE. I THINK SPEAKS TO THE
POWER OF THE VACCINATION REGIMEN
FOR THE FOR EVERYONE AND OTHER
EFFORTS THAT YOU'VE DONE AS WELL
AND JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION. AND
STATE ASK THIS BUT- DEBBIE HAD
ANY DEATH SUFFERING OF PATIENTS. FOR FROM CODED IN THE PAST
YEAR. IN THE PAST YEAR- YEAH I
KNOW EXACTLY HOW- IN THE THAT OF
THE NUMBER IN THE- YEAR OR-
ANYTHING. OVER THE COURSE OF THE
POUND. AND WE HAVE HAD- SIX TWO
PATIENTS THAT HAVE PASSED THE
MAJORITY THAT THOSE WOULD HAVE
BEEN DURING GOT CREAMED BAXEEN
OKAY AND I YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE
INDIVIDUALS- IN OUR SYSTEM. THAT
ARE YOU KNOW HAVE SIGNIFICANT
MENTAL CONDITION CONDITION SO
THERE STILL IS IT IS RISK AND
DESPITE ALL OF IT WE DO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE- THERAPEUTICS- WE
NEED TO YOU KNOW AND DESPITE
THE- COMING BACK SAYING THAT YOU
STILL HAVE- RISKS AND-
ULTIMATELY MOST OF THOSE ARE
GOING TO AND THEN I BRING THE
BACKSEAT. OKAY ALL RIGHT- TWELVE
BE TO FOLLOW UP AND PROVIDED
THAT NUMBER IF YOU'D LIKE NOT
YOU AND I THINK. AND TURN I
THINK YOU KNOW WE CAN YOU FOR
YOU DO TO KEEP PATIENTS SELF
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT'S ON TO ISSUE A
FOUR PROGRAM IN CASE. UPDATES
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE CA BRENT CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF. FOR THE EST HA.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE ITEMS WITH
AND- PROGRAMMING CASELOAD
UPDATES AS PART OF ISSUE FOR SO
I WILL TAKE THE FIRST SEVERAL
PROGRAM UPDATES AND THEN PASSED
THE PRESENTATION OVER TO CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR EVENS TO COVER
TO COVER THE REMAINING ITEMS. I
BEGINNING WITH THE METROPOLITAN
INCREASE SECURE BACK CAPACITY
PROJECT THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT PROVIDED FUNDING FOR
D. S. H. TO ACTIVATE THE
REMAINING THREE UNITS UP FIVE.
UNITS SECURE BED CAPACITY
EXPANSION WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL BEDS TO TREAT
INDIVIDUALS COMMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
THAT'S INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL. WE ARE EXPERIENCING A TEN
MONTH DELAY IN THE ACTIVATION OF
THE THREE REMAINING UNITS FOR
THIS PURPOSE AND ARE PROJECTED
TO ACTIVATE THOSE UNITS IN JULY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AS A
RESULT OF THESE ONE TIME
DISTILLATE THERE IS A ONE TIME
SAVINGS OF ABOUT TWENTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION AND CURRENT
YEAR. ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PERSONAL SERVICES SAVINGS THAT
WOULD STAFF THE ADDITIONAL THREE
UNITS UPON ACTIVATIONS. THE
DELAY IS A RESULT OF COMING
NINETEEN AND THE NEED FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY IN FIRE
ALARM UPGRADE SWING SPACE. THANK
YOU GOING. TO BRING TO THE
ENHANCE TREATMENT PROGRAM- THE
ENHANCE TREATMENT PROGRAM WAS
DEVELOPED TO TREAT PATIENTS WHO
ARE AT THE HIGHEST RISK OF
VIOLENCE IN CANNOT BE SAFELY
TREATED IN A STANDARD TREATMENT
ENVIRONMENT. BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND DATA STAGE WAS
AUTHORIZED TO CONSTRUCT FOR
ENHANCE. ASK THEIR OAKS AND ONE
TEN BED UNIT IDEA STAGE PATENTS.
ARE HAPPY TO REPORT DIAZ AGE DID
ACTIVATE ITS FIRST UNIT IDEA
SUCH A TOXIC AIR ON SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HOWEVER WE DO
REPORT- POSTPONEMENT OF UNITS
THIRTY THREE AND THIRTY FOUR AT
DSHS TASK THERE- DUE TO. BAD
CAPACITY PRESSURES GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF BEDS THAT WOULD HAVE
TO BE ON TAKEN OFFLINE TO
COMPLETE THAT PROJECT.
ADDITIONALLY DST H. REPORTS A
THREE MONTH DELAY IN THE
ACTIVATION IDEAS H. PATTON. AS A
RESULT OF THE POSTPONING OF THE
REMAINING UNITS AT ATASCADERO
AND DELAYS AT PATTON. CH IS
REPORTING AT ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
NINE POINT SIX MILLION IN
CURRENT YEAR AND ONGOING SAVINGS
OF ABOUT EIGHT POINT NINE
MILLION AND FIFTY SIX POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AND- A. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING.
CORRECT FOR THANK YOU. BRING ONE
FORMER GET ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
WELL DO ANOTHER BOOK REHAB
PROGRAM SERVES AS AT THE PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE A RANGE VOCATION
SKILLS THERAPY ANNA FOR I DURING
AT NINE BUT- HAVE A PRO REFER
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED THE
RESTRICTIONS ON PATIENT WORK AS
JOBSITES ACTIVITIES HAD TO LIMIT
THE AMOUNT OF PATIENT WORKERS
DUE TO SAFETY PRECAUTIONS. IDEAS
H. HAS RESUMED- PATIENT WORKER
PROGRAM SLOWLY AND NON KOBE
NINETEEN SEARCH TIMES ALTHOUGH
PROGRAMMING MAY BE MORE IMPACTED
DURING EXPERIENCES OF SEARCH ADS
THAT UNITS ARE ON QUARANTINE AS
AN EXAMPLE AS A RESULT OF THE
IMPACTS TO THE- TO THE
PARTICIPATION IN THIS PROGRAM
DSHS REPORTING A ONE TIME
SAVINGS OF TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY.
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
CURRENT YEAR- BUT NO ADJUSTMENTS
TO DSHS BUDGET. AND BUDGET YEAR
ON GOING. MOVING FOR TO THE
MEASURE BASE FOR STAFF STUDY
OVER THE PAST THREE BUDGETS. THE
DEPARTMENTS STATE HOSPITALS HAS
PRESENTED SEVERAL STOPPING
STUDIES RELATED TO DIRECT CARE
NURSING COURT EVALUATIONS AND
REPORTS TREATMENT TEAM OF
PRIMARY CARE AND PROTECTIVE
SERVICES. I'LL PROVIDE A BRIEF
UPDATE ON EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS. STARTING WITH CORE
EVALUATIONS AND REPORTS- BACK IN
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT THERE
IS NINETY FOUR POINT SIX
POSITIONS OF AND FORTY POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS BASED IN OVER A
THREE YEAR CALL. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO IMPLEMENT A
STAFFING STANDARDS TO SUPPORT
THE FORENSIC SERVICES WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH COURT DIRECTED
PATIENT TREATMENT- AN UPDATE AT
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET ACTOR
BY SYSTEM LIMITATION BASED ON
PERIOD TO A FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
AND YES I JUST REPORTING A ONE
TIME SAVINGS THAT AND CURRENT
YEAR ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ALTHOUGH DSHS BUILD SIXTY THREE
POSITIONS OF ABOUT SEVENTY NINE
POSITIONS AS AT. THE END OF
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WITH THE INVEST IN THESE. PSH
HAS BEEN ABLE TO INCREASE. TO
NEURO PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES FOR
PATIENTS DISPATCHES REPORTING AN
INCREASED NUMBER OF REFERRALS
COMPLETED AND LESS WAIT TIME FOR
PATIENTS AND RECEIVING THEIR
EVALUATION AS A RESULT OF THE
INVESTMENTS HERE. WILL BE ON THE
MISSION BASED REVIEW DIRECT CARE
NURSING PROPOSAL IN THE TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET D. S. ALSO WANTS FOR
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
SAVINGS IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. AS A RESULT IN SOME DELAYS
IN HIRING AND DOES REQUEST
POSITION OF AUTHORITY ONLY FOR
THIRTY TWO ADMINISTRATIVE
POSITIONS TO ALLOW LEVEL OF KERR
CLASSIFICATIONS TO RETURN BACK
TO ON UNIT POSITIONS. AND ALSO
REQUEST SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND ON GOING
TO ACCOUNT FOR UNDERFUNDED FACED
AND POSITIONS. YES IT HAS FAILED
A HUNDRED AND FOUR MEDICATION
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN POSITIONS
IN TWENTY SEVEN OF THE AFTER
HOURS SUPERVISING REGISTERED
NURSING POSITIONS AS AT THAT.
END OF SEPTEMBER. I JUST A BRIEF
UPDATE ON- THE MEDICATION PASS
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS GIVEN
THE RESULT OF THE POSITIONS
ADDED MORE TIME HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO MEDICATION
MINISTRATION CONTRIBUTING TO A
LOWER NUMBER OF MEDICATION
TRANSCRIPTION ERRORS. AND
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT REVIEWS OF
THE MEDICATION ROOM OPERATE
OPERATIONS. OF IDENTIFIED A FEW
LOCATIONS ARE BEEN ZERO CDPH
LICENSING DEFICIENCIES OR
CITATIONS DURING THIS REPORTING
PERIOD- AS A RESULT OF THE
INVESTMENT IN THE SUPERVISING
REGISTERED NURSES THEY'VE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN SUPPORTING.
MULTIPLE SPECIAL PROJECTS IN
ADDITION TO THEIR SUPERVISORY
DUTIES. SUCH AS KOBE NINETEEN
TESTING SITES. OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING ISSUE RESOLUTION ON
COBIT NINETEEN ISOLATION UNITS
AS WELL AS ENSURING OTHER
INFECTION PREVENTION AND
CONTROL- ASPECTS OF THE UNITS.
LOOKING FOR OUR TO THAT WORK FOR
THAT UP- BACK THE TWENTY BUDGET
ACT THERE WERE RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PSYCHIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AND EXPAND
RESOURCES FOR NURSING
RECRUITMENT TO MEET THE MISSION
OF PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO PATIENTS- THE
RESIDENCY PROGRAM AT SO. ST
JOSEPH MEDICAL CENTER IN PSH NAP
I DID RECEIVE ACCREDITATION FROM
THE ACCREDITATION COUNCIL FOR
GRADUATE MAGIC EDUCATION AND
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. OF
THE PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAM BEGAN ITS FIRST CO OR
AND JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF
SEVEN RESIDENTS. THE ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL ON THE CULTURE FOR
RESIDENTS PER PROGRAM WHICH WAS
AN ESTIMATE AT THE TIME BUT
WITHIN THE EXISTING PROGRAM
BUDGET THE STAGE WAS ABLE TO
FIND SEVEN RESIDENTS PER
PROGRAM. PER YEAR THROUGH FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. IN
THE RESIDENCY PROGRAM WE DO
REPORT A ONE TIME SAVINGS OF
AROUND THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR JUST A- MINOR
DELAYS IN PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
AT NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR-
REQUEST IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. FOR NURSING RECRUITMENT
DSHS APACE WANT A ONE TIME
SAVINGS A FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO DUE TO THE NURSE INSTRUCTOR
POSITION BECOMING BACON IDEA
STAGE NAPA. WILL NOTE NURSING
RECRUITMENT HAS BEEN IMPACTED
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC WERE
DSHS EXPERIENCED A DECREASE
DECREASE THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
GRADUATING HOWEVER. HAPPY TO
REPORT IN RECENT GRADUATING
CLASSES. THE NUMBERS ARE
REFLECTING. BACK UP PARTICULARLY
ARTISTIC TO TASK ERRO A
PARTNERSHIP WITH CUESTA COLLEGE
. I'M MOVING TO THE PART SIR.
OUR MISSION BASED GROUP AND BEST
AND THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNORS BUDGET DEAL PROJECTS A
ONE TIME SAVINGS OF ONE POINT
SIX NINE DOLLARS DUE TO HIRING
DELAYS IN THE CURRENT YEAR. AND
DOES REQUEST TEN POSITIONS
SPECIFIC TO HOSPITAL POLICE
OFFICERS AND THE ASSOCIATED
FUNDING OF TWO POINT THREE
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND TWO MILLION IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND BEYOND THE
REQUESTED BECAUSE ISSUES ARE
SPECIFIC TO THE PSH CALLING A
COURTYARD WHICH PROVIDES SECURE
OUTDOOR ACTIVITY IN TREATMENT
AREA FOR PATIENTS AT COALINGA
WHICH WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THEIR
ORIGINAL STOPPING STUDY EXTENDS.
THAT PARTICULAR PROJECT WAS-
STILL IN PROGRESS AND IS IT
ANTICIPATED. TO COMPLETE BE
COMPLETED THIS YEAR. I'M MOVING
ON TO THE TREATMENT TEAM BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND THE TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT YES
H. RECEIVED A POSITION OF
AUTHORITY FOR TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN POSITIONS AND FIFTY
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE PHASED IN OVER FIVE YEARS.
AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DSHS TO MAKE
THE CURRENT YEAR SAVINGS OF
ABOUT NINE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. AND DOES REQUEST
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND ONE POINT
TWO MILLION BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE- THE CURRENT
YEAR SAVINGS AS PRIMARILY
RELATED TO DELAYS IN HIRING AS
THE DEPARTMENT'S BEEN FOCUSED ON
HIRING THE- CLINICAL LEADERSHIP
STRUCTURE WHICH CONSISTS OF. THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR ASSISTANT
MEDICAL DIRECTOR AND CHIEF OF
PRIMARY CARE FOR MANY HOSPITALS
THOSE POSITIONS ARE BEING.
FINALIZED IN TERMS OF THEIR
HIRING. ONLY TWO MORE UPDATES
FOR ME BEFORE PASSING IT OVER TO
MISTY DANCE AND I WILL CONTINUE
ON TO THE TELE PSYCHIATRY
RESOURCES. THIS IS AN UPDATE
ONLY AND NO SPECIFIC POSITION
ADJUSTMENTS FOR FISCAL
ADJUSTMENTS PROPOSED AT THIS
TIME. OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE ESTATES HAS INCREASE
JUST USE OF TALENTS PSYCHIATRY
TO PROVIDE PSYCHIATRIC TREATMENT
REMOTELY TO PATIENTS AT
HOSPITALS WHERE. ARE THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION CREATES
DIFFICULTY HIRING PSYCHIATRIST.
IDEAS H. HAS BILLED THE
OVERSIGHT POSITION AND A
MAJORITY OF THE STAFF PSYCHIATRY
POSITIONS REPORTING TWELVE
EIGHTEEN STAFF PSYCHIATRIST
POSITIONS HAVE BEEN FILLED. THE
PATIENT OFF A IN EQUIPMENT
UPDATE DISTRICTS RICK ONE NINE
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AN ON GOING TO SUPPORT THE
INCREASE IN PATIENT TREATMENT
SUPPORT COSTS WITHIN THE DS H.
SYSTEM. WHICH INCLUDES BUT IS
NOT LIMITED TO THINGS LIKE
CLOTHING- PERSONAL SUPPLIES FOOD
LAUNDRY MEDICATION AND PATIENT
RIGHTS ADVOCACY SERVICES. DSHS
UTILIZING A METHODOLOGY THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET BACK TO INCLUDE
A FUNDING REQUESTING BUDGET YEAR
AN ONGOING BASED ON UPDATED
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES AND
PROJECTED CENSUS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. I WENT ALL PASS IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE EATING TO PROVIDE
THE REMAINING UPDATES OF THIS
ISSUE. WELCOME BACK MACHINES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO THE NEXT
STEP- IS A PROGRAM UPDATE FOR
THE CONDITIONAL RELEASE PROGRAM
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CONTRACT FOR
THE NON STP POPULATION. SO
SIMILAR TO THE EFFORTS BEING
MADE FOR OUR I. S. T. POPULATION
WE DO CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT A
BROAD CONTINUUM OF CARE TO
SUPPORT INCREASED PLACEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. FOR STATE
HOSPITAL PATIENTS TO TRANSITION
TO THE COMMUNITY. CONRAD WE'VE
BEEN WORKING A NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS TO DEVELOP NEW
PROGRAMMING WITH DEDICATED THAT
CAPACITY TO EXPAND OUR SERVICES
TO A HIGHER. LEVEL NEED OF
PATIENTS WITHIN OUR SYSTEM SOME
OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE ON TRACK-
WITH ACTIVATION TIMELINES AND
OTHERS HAVE BEEN DELAYED. TO
THAT END DSHS REFLECTING ONE
TIME SAVINGS AND SEVEN POINT
FOUR MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. I REQUEST
AN ADDITIONAL FOUR POINT SIX
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND ARE GOING. IS IT JUST
NETWORK COMPRISES THE FOLLOWING.
CONTINUED ACTIVATION. AND CAR
SEVEN EIGHT BED STEP DOWN I AM
DEEP IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THESE DELAYS ARE PRIMARILY
DRIVEN BY- PENDING LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION APPROVALS-
REDUCTION OF A PREVIOUSLY
PLANNED FIVE BAD. PROGRAM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH REHAB CENTER IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WERE NO LONGER
PURSUING THIS CONTRACT. AND
LASTLY WE DID FIND A NEW THIRTY
BAD WE ARE DEVELOPING A NEW
THIRTY BEDS STATEWIDE
TRANSITIONAL RESIDENTIAL PROGRAM
ALSO IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THE BAY AREA- THAT'S LICENSED AS
AN ADULT RESIDENTIAL FACILITY.
FOR AN ACTIVE CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS AND SHE'S PAYING
ACTIVATION. MISSIONS. TO OCCUR
BY APRIL OF THIS YEAR. LAST I'D
LIKE TO AN OF ON THE ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY EIGHTY BEDS.
ASSERTIVE COMMUNITY TREATMENT
FOR FACT LEVEL OF CARE THAT WAS
AUTHORIZED FOR CONRAD AND THIS
THE SCHOOL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
WE ANTICIPATED THIS PROGRAM TO
ACTIVATE ACROSS THREE REGIONS IN
THE STATE SIXTY BEDS IN EACH
REION ACTIVATION OF THE FIRST
SIXTY BEDS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
HAS OCCURRED. AND PATIENT
ADMISSIONS HAVE BEGUN THIS
SEASON THE NEXT SIXTY BEDS AND
SANDIEGO WILL BE. EXPECTED TO
RAMP UP IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
MONTHS AND THEN THE FINAL SIXTY
BEDS- WHICH ARE LOCATED IN THE
BAY AREA ARE PLANNED FOR FALL.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ACTIVATION.
THE NEXT ITEM IS AN OF TO THE
CONRAD S. PRO. IDEAS HE JUST AS
THE- TOTAL I'M- FIVE AS SPEECH
HE PATIENTS BE UNCONDITIONAL.
AND THE COMMUNITY BY THE END OF
THIS FISCAL YEAR JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ASSUMES THE
SAME CASE FOR GLOBAL ON IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED AN INCREASED TREND
OF COUNTY COURTS REQUESTING DSHS
LEGAL PRESENCE. AT CONRAD S. B.
P. OUR CLIENT PLACEMENT HEARINGS
AND IN COORDINATION WITH OTHER
COUNTY AND JUSTICE STAKEHOLDERS.
TO SUPPORT THIS INCREASE
WORKLOAD WE ARE REQUESTING TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
ONE ATTORNEY THREE POSITION AND
JUST CLEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND ONGOING. CURRENTLY
THERE IS NO DEDICATED TSA TO
TOURNEY ASSIGNED TO THIS PROGRAM
AND THE GROWTH IN THE WORKLOAD
IS JUST UNSUSTAINABLE FOR
CURRENT LEGAL STAFF WHO
PARTIALLY. SUPPORT PROGRAM. ON
THE NET ITEM IS AN OF THE FOR
JAIL BASED. TREATMENT PROGRAM.
WE DO CONTINUE PARTNER COUNTY
SHARE ACROSS THE STATE TO
PROVIDE COMPETENCY RESTORATION
SERVICES TO THE FELONY I S. T.
R. POPULATION. THE TOTAL J. B.
C. T. CAPACITY AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO IS ESTIMATED AT FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO BEDS
WHICH IS A NET DECREASE OF
THIRTY FIVE BEDS COMPARED TO THE
MAIN REVISION. AND THE TOTAL
CAPACITY IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE IS ESTIMATED AT SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR BEDS.
WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF NINETY
TWO BEDS OVER THE REVISED
CAPACITY IN THIS CURRENT YEAR.
WE ARE REFLECTING A ONE TIME
SAVINGS OF APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
MILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
TO REFLECT THE DELAYED
ACTIVATION TIMELINE OF PROGRAMS
THAT WORK. DO YOU TO INCREASE
THEIR EXISTING PROGRAM CAPACITY
OR ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAM
CAPACITY THIS YEAR HE'S ALWAYS
WORKING ON PART TWO CALL THE
CHALLENGES. IN THE JAILS- AND-
BE IMPACTED PROCUREMENT AND.
RECRUITMENT ACTIVITIES AS WELL.
ADDITIONALLY DS WORK ON A POINT
SIX INTO TWO THREE AND A- POINT
EIGHT ON GO. TO SUPPORT THE
FOLLOW ADJUSTMENTS INCREMENTAL
BED CAPACITY CHANGES AT FIVE OF
OUR EXISTING AND CURRENTLY
FUNDED U. B. C. T. PROGRAMS
WHERE THE INCREASED RATE OF
REFERRALS HAS DRIVEN THE NEED
FOR ADDITIONAL BEDS. AT 5% RATE
INCREASE AT TEN OF RGB SEE
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THE RISING
COSTS AND STAFF SALARIES AND
OPERATING EXPENDITURES. ARE TWO
NEW JVC D. PROGRAMS AND A
SERVICE EXPANSION AT SOME OF OUR
G. B. C. T. LOCATIONS TO PERFORM
THOSE STABILIZATION AND EARLY
ACCESS TREATMENT SERVICES FOR.
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PENDING IN
MISSION TRIP YES EACH PROGRAM.
ON THIS LAST COMPONENT REALLY AS
A COMPLEMENT TO THAT IS G.
SOLUTION PROPOSAL THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER. AND SO BY
LEVERAGING THE EXISTING JBC P.
TREATMENT PROVIDERS. STAND
SERVICES ALLOWS US TO BROADEN
OUR ABILITY. TO REACH MORE
PEOPLE ON THE WAITLIST- NOW UP
THAT AND UPDATE OUR COMMITTEE
BASED. PROGRAM WE ARE REQUESTING
THREE MILLION AND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
THREE POINT TWO MILLION ONGOING.
FOR THIS PROGRAM THE SUGGEST
MINISTER CORRECTED CALCULATION
ERROR AND FUND THE INCREASE
DAILY BAD RATES THAT ARE- COUPLE
COUPLE TO OUR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION PROGRAM OF THIS
TOTAL TWO POINT THREE MILLION
WILL FUND THE COST OF THIRTY
FOUR BEDS THAT WERE JUST NOT
INCLUDED IN OUR COST
CALCULATIONS. IN ADDITION SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ONGOING IS NEEDED TO FIND.
UPDATED DAILY THAT RATES FROM
THE ORIGINAL HUNDRED AND FIFTY
BAGS THAT WERE- ORIGINALLY
INCORPORATED FOR THIS PROGRAM.
BACK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. AND THEN PROVIDE YOU
BRIEF UPDATE THE STATUS OF THE
PROBE THE PLAN THREE HUNDRED BED
EXPANSION IN L. A. COUNTY HAS
BEEN COMPLETED TWO HUNDRED BEDS
WERE ACTIVATED AT THE END OF
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
THE REMAINING HUNDRED BEDS WERE
ACTIVATED ON BEGINNING IN
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
PROGRAM NOW OPERATES A TOTAL OF
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN BEDS-
IN ADDITION WE ALSO DID RECEIVE.
FUNDING THIS YEAR TO EXPAND TO
OTHER COUNTIES FIND ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO BEDS-
THOSE ARE PLANNED TO BE REALLY
PHASED IN OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS BUT WE HAVE BEGUN.
DISCUSSIONS WITH A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES ON THAT FRONT. AND THEN
LASTLY THE LAST UPDATE IS AN
UPDATE TO OUR STATEWIDE ICED TEA
OFFRAMP OR SISTER PROGRAM- DSHS
FROM REQUESTING TO ELIMINATE
THIS PROGRAM ARE SELECTING A
SAVINGS OF ONE MILLION- IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ONGOING. THESE EFFORTS REALLY
HAVE BEEN SUBSUMED UNDER OUR NEW
I. S. T. REEVALUATION SERVICES
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN
AUTHORIZED OR WAS AUTHORIZED IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. THIS OUR
TESTIMONY ON ISSUE FOUR HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAS BEEN BUSY. HELLO
THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN COREY
ISSUED WITH THE L. A. O- WE
ATTRIBUTE THESE PROGRAMMING
CASELOAD UPDATES- WITH NO CANCER
HISTORY. DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THE
NON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU STILL ARE
HAVING SOME TROUBLE HIRING BUT I
THINK WELCOME TO EVERYBODY
ELSE'S WORLD SOME OF THESE
POSITIONS THAT YOU HAVE THAT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HIRE FOR YET.
THAT'S CORRECT WE ARE REPORTING
SOME HIRING CHALLENGES I THINK
IT IT'S AS DIRECTOR CLENDENIN
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY ON ISSUE IT
REMAINS A CHALLENGE BEFORE KOBE
AND CERTAINLY HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED DUE TO KOBE BUT-
IT'S ALSO. AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT OUR
HIRING SO WE'RE CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT OUR- HIRING AND
RECRUITMENT PROCESS TO IDENTIFY
EFFICIENCIES FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE AND ALSO. TRYING TO
LEVERAGE THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
ALSO TRYING TO KNOCK CONTRACTORS
AND CONSULTANTS TO HELP US
ADVERTISE IN DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN DONE PREVIOUSLY.
ARTICULATELY NOT ONLY FOR OUR
LEVEL CARE CLINICAL
CLASSIFICATIONS BUT ALSO IN OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT THROUGH THE OLD
USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA. I THINK
THERE ARE SOME BEST PRACTICES
FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS WERE
TRYING TO LEVERAGE SO IT'S
CERTAINLY A FOCAL POINT A ZERO
POINT NINE MADAM CHAIR IT IS IT
IS A CHALLENGE. THANK YOU I'M
THANK YOU DOCTOR. I THANK YOU
AGAIN LOT OF PROGRAMS- AND
APPRECIATE QUESTION ABOUT HIRING
AND SIMILAR QUESTION JUST A
MAYBE SLIGHTLY RELATED TO THAT-
IN TERMS OF IN ADDITION TO
HIRING IN AND OF COURSE
ATTENTION- WHEN YOU HAVE IT'S I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO SINCE YOU
CAN'T YOU HAVING SOME CHALLENGES
FILLING POSITIONS SO FORTH.
LISTED IN THE GERMAN PARLIAMENT
. HOW MUCH OF IT ISSUES SAY
OVERTIME AND- YOU KNOW BECAUSE
AFTER ALL YOUR PATIENTS WHO HAD
SOMEONE HAS TO TAKE CARE OF THEM
SOMEBODY HAD NO PEOPLE STAFF. TO
DO WHAT THE GREASE THAT ISSUE
AND ARE YOU HAVING TO SPEND A
LOT OF MONEY ON CONTRACTING OUT
TO GET OF SOMEONE THE HOLES- OR
ARE YOU ABLE TO DO THAT WITHIN
YOUR OWN. WITH IN NEWTOWN
EXISTING STAFF SO- IT'S- PASSAGE
THE NO THERE ISN'T SOMETHING
EXPLICIT NOTHING TO A SECTION ON
THE APP. IT IS THAT IT IS THE
SENATE AND IS THAT EXPAND IT IS
SIGNIFICANT EXPENSE FOR THIS
DEPARTMENT. CHANCE OF THAT
QUESTION WE- WE DO NORMALLY RELY
ON SORT OF MULTIPLE AVENUES TO
BE ABLE TO MEET OUR STAFFING
NEEDS AND TRY TO PREVENT A
RELIANCE ON OVERTIME SO WE HAD.
CERTAIN TOOLS WHERE. INTERNAL
REGISTRY WILL WORK WELL WILL WE
WILL RELY ON. TIMES STAFF FOR
RETIRED A NEW WHICH TENDS TO
FILL IN THE GAPS SO THAT WE
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE TO RELY ON
OVERTIME AS WELL AS- VOLUNTARY
OVERTIME IS A AVAILABLE TO OUR
STAFF MEMBERS- SOME FOLKS DON'T.
RELY ON THAT IS WELL
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE TO
MANDATE OVERTIME AT TIMES IN
ORDER- IN CERTAIN SITUATIONS.
BUT WE ALSO DO CONTRACT OUT SO I
THINK OUT OF ALL OF THESE
OPTIONS IS SORT OF HOW WE TELL
OUR STAFFING NEEDS AND IT'S AN
ONGOING BALANCE- HAS BEEN BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC AND CERTAINLY IT'S
IS ALSO A BALANCE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. OKAY APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS- BE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING INTO THE
TO FIELD AGAIN OR BUDGET
COMMITTEE IS THE EXPENSE OF THAT
PARTICULARLY- TO WHAT DEGREE DO
YOU NEED- FIND YOURSELF HAVING
TO CONTRACT OUT VERSUS THE ON
THE USE I GUESS INTERNAL STAFF
FOR. OTHER TYPES OF OPTIONS AS
WELL SO- SO JUST TO APPRECIATE
OR SOME- INFORMATION CAN GET
BACK TO US ON THAT LATER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE STATE HOSPITALS COST TO
CARE AND TREATMENT. FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE POLICY. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRETT HAUSER CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
AGAIN I'LL BE PRESENTING ON
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. AS PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACTORS SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT WAS
DUE TO THE LEGISLATURE- AND AS
PART OF THE- INCLUDED IN THAT
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ACT WE DID
INCLUDE THAT REPORT WHICH IS
PROVIDING INFORMATION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING.
PATIENT COST OF CARE AND
TREATMENT AND THE STATE HOSPITAL
AND THE RECOMMENDED FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. THROUGH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ROOT THIS
REPORT WHICH INCLUDED REVIEWING-
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTIONS FEDERAL REGULATIONS
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
RESEARCH OF OTHER PUBLIC
ENTITIES- DIAZ AGE STATE IS
RECOMMENDING UPDATING AND
REMOVING OUTDATED STATUTORY
LANGUAGE THAT'S NO LONGER
APPLICABLE TO DSHS CURRENT
SYSTEM OF CARE. AND PROVIDING
PATIENT RELIEF- OF THAT WE DO
NOT BELIEVE WOULD JEOPARDIZE OUR
ABILITY TO COLLECT MEDICARE IN
MOST SUB SAMPLE YOU INCLUDED IN
THIS PROPOSAL BE A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS DEVELOPING A
STATUTORY AND POLICY FRAMEWORK
FOR IMPLEMENTING- FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE OR DISCOUNTED CARE
PROGRAM. I WOULD NOTE THIS
REPORT DOES BUILD ON STATUTORY
CHANGES INCLUDED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT THAT
REMOVED FINANCIAL LIABILITY FOR
FAMILY. MEMBERS OF STATE
HOSPITAL PATIENTS. MOVING INTO
WHAT THE SPUR RECOMMEND. ARE
BETTER OUTLINE IN THE AGENDA AS
WELL AS VIA TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT IS AVAILABLE THE
DEPARTMENT'S RECOMMENDING A
MULTIPLE MULTIPLE CHANGES
STARTING WITH. REMOVING PSH
HAVING THE AUTHORITY TO BE
APPOINTED AS THE CONSERVATIVE A
STATE AS WELL AS INVESTING FUNDS
AS THE EXECUTOR OF THE STATE.
WHICH D. S. H. BELIEVES IS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WHILE THIS
IS AN EXISTING PRACTICE THE LAW
IS STILL ON THE BOOKS AND
BELIEVE THAT SHOULD BE UPDATED.
ADDITIONALLY DSHS RECOMMENDS
CHANGING WELFARE INSTITUTIONS
CODE SEVENTY TO EIGHTY ONCE
REMOVED PSH IS THAT THE
AUTHORITY TO REMOVE ANY FUNDS
OVER FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS NOT
POLITE TO THE PAYMENT OF CARE-
THIS WILL ALLOW PATIENTS TO
RETAIN THEIR FUNDS TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY TRANSITION INTO THE
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES UPON
DISCHARGE. AS BRIEFLY
HIGHLIGHTED BEING FOR UP. A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS A
POLICY FRAMEWORK FOR
IMPLEMENTING A FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. A
SPECIFICALLY THIS FRAMEWORK
INCLUDES ALLOWING FOR PATIENTS
TO LEGALLY BE RELIEVED OF THEIR
DEBT IN FULL OR IN PART FOR THE
COST OF CARE AND TREATMENT. ESTE
HOSPITAL BED BASED ON SPECIFIED
CRITERIA. BASED ON RESEARCH FROM
OTHER FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
POLICIES- DSHS PROPOSING THAT
PATIENTS AT 3100% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL OR BELOW MAY BE
GRANTED A 100% DEBT RELIEF-
THERE WILL BE A SLIDING SCALE OF
DEBT RELIEF IN TERMS OF THE COST
OF CARE ACCOUNT BALANCE- FOR
PATIENTS WITH AN INCOME. MORE
THAN 3100% OF F. P. L. AS SOON
AS THIS. POLICY IS FINALIZED AND
PENDING APPROVAL TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THE BUDGET PROCESS DSHS
PLAN TO. POST THE PUB- THE
POLICY WITHIN HOSPITALS AND TO
OUR WEBSITE AS WELL AS WORK WITH
PATIENTS AND APPLYING FOR THE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THAT CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY ON
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALEJO. THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN- WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS TO RAISE ON THIS ISSUE
AND JUSTICE STREAMLINE THINGS A
LITTLE BIT AND WE ARE NOT
PLANNING TO RAISE ANY COMMENTS
ON ANY OF THE OTHER REMAINING
ISSUES ON THE AGENDA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THE PART OF FINANCING
OPTION FOR YOU. A FRESH. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS I
JUST I JUST BUT I JUST LEARNED
THAT WE WERE CHARGING PEOPLE
ANNA AND HOW. THIS IS KIND OF
OUTRAGEOUS SO I'M GLAD THAT
WE'RE CLEANING UP OUR BOOKS DR
PAN I WOULD DISAGREE THANK YOU.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SIX. ADMINISTRATIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICE WORKLOAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN HAMMER
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AND ALL
SPEECH OR ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES WORKLOAD BCP.
DEPARTMENT OF STAT HOSPITALS
REQUEST ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AT TWELVE POSITIONS
PERMANENT AND ONGOING TO PROVIDE
STAFFING RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASING WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH EMPLOYEE GROWTH
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. AS
NOTED IN THE B. C. P. THERE'S A
NUMBER OF PROPOSALS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDED AND WILL CONTINUE TO
PHASE AND POSITION. AS DIAZ AGE
GROWS SO DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT SERVICES
FOR EMPLOYEES IN THE AREAS OF
HUMAN RESOURCES. EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY BUDGETS
AND RESEARCH. THE POSITION
GROWTH INCREASES THE DEMANDS
ASSOCIATED WITH HR FUNCTIONS
LIKE RECRUITMENT HIRING
ONBOARDING OF EMPLOYEES.
ENSURING TIMELY AND ACCURATE
PAYROLL AND BENEFITS INCLUDING
IMPORTANTLY BENEFITS LIKE FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHTS ACT. ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
ALSO DRIVE A VARIETY OF OTHER
PROCESSES SUCH AS INCREASED
PERFORMANCE MANAGEMENT NEEDS E.
O. INVESTIGATIONS AND REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATIONS. ALSO POSITION
GROWTH DRIVES THE NEED FOR
BUDGET MANAGEMENT SUPPORT VIA
FISCAL OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND INCREASED
PROJECTION AND ALICE'S FOR
POPULATION WAIT LIST AND
STOPPING METHODOLOGIES. THIS
CONCLUDES MY TO. HOWEVER I'M
HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I DON'T KNOW ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS DR GRANT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE MOVE AND ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JENNA WATER BOND GO ACTING
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
HOSPITAL STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION I'LL BE
PRESENTING ON ISSUES SEVEN SAID
DATA GOVERNANCE IN THE
IDENTIFICATION COMPLIANCE
PROPOSAL. FOR THIS PROPOSAL DSHS
REQUESTING ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT SIX TWO YEAR LIMITED
TERM POSITION. POSITIONS
REQUESTED WELL ALLOWED ME ESTATE
STREET SOUTHWEST RESEARCH
DEVALUATION DATA INSIGHTS
PROGRAM INCLUDING A CHIEF DATA
OFFICER WHICH WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR LAUNCHING DATA
INITIATIVES AIMED AT MAXIMIZING
DATA QUALITY AND INTEGRITY WHILE
REDUCING AND MITIGATING RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH DATA QUALITY
TIMELINESS AND AVAILABILITY OF
DATA AND RISKS FOR EXPOSURE
PROTECTED HEALTH INFORMATION
WITH AN AGGREGATED AND PUBLICLY
SHARE DATA. DSHS MODE
CONSIDERABLE GAINS IN RECENT
YEARS TO FURTHER THE USE OF DATA
ANALYTICS TRUMP PARTICIPATION
MAKING AND POLICY DEVELOPMENT
BETTER ANALYTICS ARE HIGHLY
MANUAL AND VERY. TIME INTENSIVE
. BUY EXTRA DATA ACCORDING TO
STATE FEDERAL. WHICH HAS
CONTINUED TO GROW AND COMPLEXITY
OVER THE YEARS AN EXISTING
RESOURCES ARE UNABLE TO KEEP UP
WITH THE INCREASING DEMAND. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ENABLE DSHS TO
MITIGATE MITIGATION RESCUE AND
ADVANCE OUR DATA PRACTICES AS
YOU SAY JUST HEALTH INFORMATION
IT SIZEABLE AND EXPANDS FROM PRE
ADMISSION TO DISCHARGE WHICH
INCLUDES CLINICAL BONTA FORSMAN
ADMINISTRATIVE AND OPERATIONAL
DATA. ACROSS ALL OUR INPATIENT
AND CONTRACTED PROGRAMS. FURTHER
THESE RESOURCES WILL DRIVE DATA
AUTOMATION AND ADVANCEMENTS AND
ONE GROUP DSHS CAPABILITIES TO
STRICTLY PROVIDE QUALITY AND
BLINKERED DATA EXTERNALLY. HAPPY. TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
ASK. THANK YOU A MECHANISED CON
. YEAH I'M FINE WITH THE- A-
CERTAIN CERTAINLY- IT IS TALKING
VALUE AND I KNOW THE YOU HAVE
PIECE OF IT- YOUR DATA TEAM CAN
HELP. REFUTES TO VALUE. OF
WHAT'S GOING ON SCIENCE HERE
OTHER TYPES OF PROGRAMS THANK
YOU. WILL BE ON ISSUE NUMBER.
EIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS REQUEST ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR ON GOING TO
SUPPORT SIX PERMANENT POSITIONS
IN CONTRACT DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
AND MAINTAIN A SLOW RELEASING
MONITORING PROGRAM FOR THE WATER
HELD AT THE LAKE TO LAKE MURRAY
DAM LOCATED AT PSH NAPA THIS IS
DUE TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF CALIFORNIA FISH
AND GAME CODE SECTION FIFTY NINE
THIRTY SEVEN. FOR BACKGROUND
PURPOSES NAPA STATE HOSPITAL
MANAGE JUST FIVE DIFFERENT WATER
STORAGE FACILITIES WHICH HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN USED TO MEET.
THE NEEDS OF THE FACILITY BUT
ARE NOW ONLY USED TO EMPOWER THE
WATER. AND HOLDING THE WATER
BEHIND THE DAM HAS THE POTENTIAL
TO IMPACT DOWNSTREAM FISH
POPULATIONS AND- ON FEBRUARY OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WATER OUR
AUDITOR CALIFORNIA ALLEGED
VIOLATIONS OF OUR COMPLIANCE
WITH SECTION FIFTY NINE THIRTY
SEVEN FISHING GAME CODE.
RELATIVE TO THE EMPOWERMENT OF
THE WATER BEHIND PSH. NAPA'S
LAKE MURRAY AND LIKE KAMALA DAMS
AND TO COMPLY WITH THAT THIS
PARTICULAR. REGULATION DSA
TWENTY TO COMPLETE ONGOING
STREAM ASSESSMENTS AND MODIFY
THE OPERATIONS OF THE LAKE
MURRAY DAM. A NUMBER OF ACTIONS
ARE ANTICIPATED TO KEEP BE
CARRIED OUT BY THE DEPARTMENT TO
COMPLY WITH THIS CODE SECTION.
SPECIFICALLY OPERATION OF AN
INCH SCREENS FLOWING STREAM
HABITAT ASSESSMENT WHICH WAS
ALREADY COMPLETED IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. I HAD A COPY
OF THAT REPORT WAS REVIEWED BY
THAT CALIFORNIA. DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AS WELL AS
WATER ADDED AUDIT OF CALIFORNIA
DID NOT HAVE ANY MODIFICATIONS
OR SUGGESTIONS. BASED ON THE
FINDINGS OF THAT JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT PSH COMPLETED AN
OPERATIONS PLAN KNOWN AS THE
IMPLEMENTATION MONITORING DATA
TAPE. ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT PLAN
WITH INPUT AND REVIEW BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND GAME
WILDLIFE AND THIS PLAN IS REALLY
THE ROAD MAP FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO END AT TEMPLE MATT. THE FLOW
RELEASE AND MONITORING PROGRAM-
THE NECESSARY RESOURCE
REQUESTING THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
BE SPECIFIC TO ADDRESSING THE
IMPLEMENTATION MONITORING THE
FLOW OF THE FLOW RELEASE PROGRAM
IDEA STAGE TAMPA. ADMITTED TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WAS
VERY SURPRISED TO KNOW THAT WE
HAD RESERVOIRS ON OUR STATE
HOSPITALS. ECONOMIC AND WE
EVALUATED THE POSSIBILITY WE
LOOK AT TEXAS STATE GROUND OF.
SELLING PART OF THAT IF IT'S NO
LONGER USED AS A WATER SOURCE
FOR THE HOSPITAL WHY DO WE HOLD
ON TO THAT GROUND AND- AND SPEND
MORE MONEY FOR WATER QUALITY.
THERE ARE- POTENTIAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EVALUATING THE
PROPERTY WHICH WE ARE UNDERGOING
AN INFRASTRUCTURE MASTER PLAN SO
I THINK THAT'S- SOMETHING WE'RE
LOOKING AT BUT DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFICS ON A STATUS OF THE
CELL OF THE PROPERTY AT THIS
MOMENT BUT WE'LL CERTAINLY TAKE
NOTE OF THAT MADAM CHAIR. CAN
YOU TELL ME THE FULL ACREAGE OF
NAPA STATE HOSPITAL PROPERTY. I
DON'T KNOW THAT OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD AND WE DO HAVE OUR
ACTING CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
ROBERT HORSLEY IS ON THE LINE IF
HALF THAT DETAIL AVAILABLE
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO SHARE IF NOT
WE CAN CERTAINLY FOLLOW UP.
MISTER GORE THAT THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED TWENTY
ACRES AT NAPA TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
ACRES IN NAPA AND HOW MUCH-
GROUND IS THE HOSPITAL TAKE UP
IN PARKING. I'M NOT SURE WE KNOW
THAT NOT INSURANCE SO I THINK WE
MAY BE ABLE TO TAKE A- LOOK AT
HOW MANY ACREAGES UTILIZED FOR A
HOSPITAL SPECIFIC OPERATIONS AND
WHAT. MAY NOT BE MAXIMIZED IN
AND CAN REPORT BACK TO YOUR
STAFF ON THAT. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT AND THEN MAYBE DO FOR THE
REST OF THE HOSPITALS TO I MEAN.
AS WE LOOK AT X. AS WE LOOK AT
THE- NEED FOR HOUSING AS WE LOOK
AT THE NEED FOR A LAND FOR
HOUSING. IT IT'S JUST
INTERESTING TO THINK OF SOME OF
OUR STATE HOSPITALS OR A BIG
PIECES OF LAND AND WE'RE NOT
USING ALL OF THAT. PERHAPS I
COULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
CONSIDER. BUT PRINT. I WOULD TO
TOSSES. IS THAT- AND THIS IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE HAVE
SEVERAL ITEMS I CALL THIS THE
LANDLORD PART. OF THE- IN THE
HEARING- AND I KNOW THAT THE
VARSITY HOSPITALS AND- CERTAINLY
AS OVERSEE ELASTICITIES AND
PROPERTY. IF THIS ISN'T
NECESSARY FOR THE FUNCTION THE
HOSPITAL MORE WHETHER IT'S
SELLING IT FOR OTHER PURPOSES
ALL OR IS THERE ANOTHER AGENCY
IN THE STATE. THAT MIGHT HAVE
THE EXPERTISE. SO SIGNALED THE-
TO RETURN OPERATE THAT PROPERTY
IF FOR SOME REASON THE STATE
WHAT'S THE CONTINUE POSSESSION-
CERTAINLY AGAIN THE PARTY
HOSPITALS A LOT OF EXPERTISE BUT
I THINK WE WANT TO KEEP YOU
FOCUSED ON THE CARE OF PATIENTS
AND THEN OF COURSE THE
FACILITIES THAT THEY RESIDE IN.
BUT THE FACT THAT WE'RE NOW
HAVING TO GET ENGINEERS TO
SENSUALLY OPERATE RESERVOIRS-
HERE WHAT THEIR DAD IS BETTER
PLACED IN AN AGENCY THAT'S USED
TO. HANDLING WATER NOT THAT YOU
CAN'T DO IT BUT I THINK THERE'S
CERTAIN YOU KNOW CERTAIN
EXPERTISE. MAYBE AND OTHER
AGENCIES THAT MAY BE MORE
RELEVANCE- THAT AND TO MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT TO DO IT THAT
WAY. THANK YOU. IF YOU THINK
SOMETHING IS MORE COMPLICATED
THAN- OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA TRY WATER. SO IF
YOU WANT TO MIX THOSE TWO TOO
MUCH LONGER IF YOU CAN IF YOU
CAN NOT. OKAY LET'S MOVE ON. TO
THE NEXT ISSUE WHICH IS ISSUE
NUMBER NINE ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORDS. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN OF THE CA.
ANSWERING CALLS FROM OFFICE FOR
STATE- TODAY TO PRESENT ON THE
NINE OR FACE THREE BUT CHANGER
FOR CONTINUE MALEK TRY HEALTH
RECORD. PROJECT A LOT OF THIS
ASK IS MOSTLY AROUND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE'VE
DETERMINED WILL BE NEEDED FOR
THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
AND OPERATION OF THE EHR THE
OTHER BIG PIECES AROUND SOME
INITIAL POSITIONS THAT WE LIKE
TO HAVE ON BOARD. PRIOR TO THE%
H. R. CONTRACT BEING AWARDED IN
THE PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION
COMMENCEMENT AND THEN FINALLY
THERE'S A MINOR PIECE AROUND A
QUICK MINUTES AND SINCE HE DID
YOU OVERSIGHT COSTS. WERE
REQUESTING SIX POSITIONS IN TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TWO
POSITIONS AND NINETEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. TWO
POSITIONS IN TWENTY POINT EIGHT
MILLION IN FY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND THEN EIGHT POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING SH THESE
POSITIONS AND FUNDING WILL BE
CRITICAL TO PREPARE FOR THE
SUPPORT AND THEN EVENTUALLY
ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS. OF OUR EHR THESE
POSITIONS FALL UNDER TWO BROAD
CATEGORIES SO OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD WILL HIGHER NET OF
WIRELESS NETWORK ENGINEERS AT
EACH HOSPITAL AND WE WILL BE
FACING THE MEN IN THE ORDER OF
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
HOSPITAL'S. THESE FOLKS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HELPING WITH THE
DESIGN BUT THEN THE GETTING THE
ONSITE IMPLEMENTATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE ENHANCED
WIRELESS NETWORK OF ACTIVELY
THERE ARE NEEDED IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE NETWORK WHEN
WE IMPLEMENT THE EHR- PERFORMS
UP TO STANDARDS MEETS OUR
PROPOSED SERVICE LEVEL
AGREEMENTS. BUT THEN AT THE SAME
TIME DOES NOT THE GREAT THE
NETWORK THAT OUR STAFF PERSONAL
DURESS ALARM. SYSTEM RELIES ON.
THE OTHER HALF OF THE DAY. I
WOULD KIND OF. AS ARCHITECTURAL
NAY. SO THESE IN A- ARE. TO
SECURE AND NOW. INFRASTRUCTURE
YOUR LEVEL ARCHITECTS AS WELL AS
AN INTEGRATION SPECIALIST WHO'S
GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO
CONNECTING. THE DIFFERENT IT
SYSTEMS AND DATA SOURCES INTO
AND OUT OF THE HR. POSITIONS ARE
ARE NEEDED- SO THAT WE CAN
BASICALLY SET UP OUR SECURITY
TECHNOLOGY POSTURES AND ENSURE
THAT OUR EHR IS. IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENTED A MAINTAINED
PROPERLY. THE BULK OF THE FUNDS
BEING REQUESTED. FOR THE THREE
YEAR PHASED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE ENHANCED WIRELESS. THIS
BILL- CUT REQUIREMENT AND
CONTRACTS RELATED DIRECTLY TO
THESE ENHANCEMENTS. OUR SCHEDULE
HAS A PILOT HOSPITAL HAVING ITS
FIRST NETWORK REFRESH AND JUST
FOR YOUR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND THEN TO REACH ANOTHER
US SUBSEQUENT TO FISCAL YEARS.
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. I'M PONDERED.
DIFFICULT QUESTION OF THAT
SPECIAL TALK ABOUT TECHNOLOGY-
WE CONSTRUCTING THIS IN WAY AND
OUTSIDE TV HR IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWS EASY WE THINK ABOUT THE
FUTURE IN TERMS OF EASE OF
UPGRADING RIGHT SO WE'RE NOT
PUTTING TECHNOLOGY THAT AND-
WHEN WE HAVE TO UPGRADE IT'S
DIFFICULT SO WE'RE BUILDING THAT
UPGRADE INFRASTRUCTURE. UPGRADE
PATH WITH IT. YES SIR THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
OCCURRED WHILE LOOKING TO DO A
KIND OF A SERVICE WITH A WITH A
PARTNER SO THAT. THE UPGRADES
ARE FACILITATED WITH THEM OKAY
EXCELLENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AT ISSUE NUMBER TEN INCREASING
REGULATIONS RESOURCES TO IMPROVE
OPERATIONS AND MEDICATION REX
CAN MITIGATE RISK. AFTERNOON J.
C. THOMPSON DEPUTY DIRECTOR
HOSPITAL STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
EXPERT IS THAT REQUESTING FIVE
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND AND THREE POSITIONS
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. TO
SUPPORT RESOURCES TO POSITIONS
FOR THE REGULATION AND POLICY
UNIT AND ONE POSITION FOR THE
LEGAL DIVISION TO HELP MEET THE
DEPARTMENT'S INCREASING DEMAND
TO PROMULGATE REGULATIONS.
ADOPTION OF A REGULATION IS A
COMPLEX AND TIME INTENSIVE
PROCESS WHICH REQUIRES
SUBSTANTIAL ATTENTION TO DETAIL
AND INVOLVES THE DEVELOPMENT AND
THOROUGH REVIEW OF THE FACTUAL
AND LEGAL INFORMATION AS WELL AS
COORDINATION WITH OUTSIDE
STAKEHOLDERS AND FACILITATION
WORKERS. AS A RESULT OF AN
INSUFFICIENT STOPPING TO
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS DSHS
RECEIVED TWENTY UNDERGROUND
REGULATION CHALLENGES IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS. THESE ONGOING
CHALLENGES BROUGHT BY THE PUBLIC
AND ASSOCIATED INCREASED
WORKLOAD ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
ARE NEEDED TO CARRY OUT THE
FUNCTIONS MANDATED BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. I
THINK. REGARDLESS ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER- ELEVEN. CORRECT MR
HOUSER I BET YOU. RIGHT MOVING
TO ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN THE
DEPARTMENT STAY HOSPITAL'S
REQUEST TWO POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AN ON GOING TO
EXPAND PLANT OPERATIONS STAFFING
ACROSS ALL FIVE STATE HOSPITALS
OF THESE RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOGS REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE PROJECTS AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAMS RELATED TO
SERVICING INSPECTING- QUITMAN
RELATED TO FIRE AND LIFE SAFETY
SYSTEMS CRITICAL UTILITIES
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND END OF LIFE
ASSET REPLACEMENTS OF THE TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS REQUESTED SIX- OF
THE POSITIONS ARE FOR POSITION
OF PARTY ONLY AND NO FUNDING. AS
WE STARTED AGAIN TO IMPROVE IN A
PRIOR ISSUE IDEA STAGE OPERATES
FIVE STATE HOSPITALS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF COALING AT THAT
RANGE BETWEEN SIXTY SIX NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE YEARS
OLD. THESE FACILITIES CONTAIN
FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
BUILDINGS COMPRISING OF MORE
THAN SIX POINT SIX MILLION GROSS
SQUARE FEET OF SPACE- THESE
LOCATIONS ARE COMPRISED OF
BUILDINGS INFRASTRUCTURE IN YOUR
UTILITY SYSTEMS AT OUR AGE AND
IN MANY CASES CAN BE PAST THEIR
USEFUL LIFE EXPECTANCY. OTHER
DEPARTMENT OPERATES WITH A
LIMITED NUMBER OF CASH
OPERATIONS STAFF HAS NOT GROWN
OVER THE YEARS RELATIVE. TO THE
AMOUNT OF MAINTENANCE DEMANDS OF
DSHS PHYSICAL PLANT. THE
NECESSITY TO PRIORITIZE AND EVEN
REACT TO EMERGENCY TYPE
SITUATIONS ARE REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE ISSUES DIVERSE PLANT
OPERATIONS STAFF FROM COMPLETING
BASELINE ONGOING UNNECESSARY.
MAINTENANCE WORKLOAD JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF EMERGENCY TYPE
SITUATIONS THAT WOULD BE CORRECT
STAFF FOR H. FAQ ASSESSMENTS FOR
AIR FLOW ISSUES DUE TO COPE AT
NINETEEN- LEAKS TO THE HYDRONIC
LOOP OR A ROOFING ISSUES AND
OTHER COMPLIANCE FOR. RELATED.
PROJECTS SPECIFIC TO THE JOINT
COMMISSION. THE DEPLOYMENT OF
THESE WILL ALLOW THEM TO IMPROVE
OUR REALLY TO MITIGATING
EMERGENCY REPAIRS THE TRUSTING
REGULAR ONGOING SPECIAL REPAIRED
AND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ISSUES.
AND ELIMINATION OF I'LL BURKE
ORDER BACKLOG THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO KEEP OUR HOSPITALS
FUNCTIONING. AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH OF YOUR OF
TIME AND RESOURCES. IS SPENT.
IT'S BEEN UPDATING EQUIPMENT.
HEY I'M I'M GOING BACK TO THE
DAM THAT IS NOT DIRECTLY RELATED
TO PATIENT CARE. I DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC PERCENTAGE OF THE TIME
BUT CERTAINLY THE PRIORITY IS
AND ALWAYS WILL BE FOR THE STAFF
MEMBERS OF PLANT OPERATIONS
STAFF FOR MAINTAINING THE SAFETY
AND OF OUR PATIENTS TO MAKE SURE
THINGS ARE FUNCTIONING WHETHER.
THAT'S ON A UNIT OR EVEN THINGS
THAT ARE IN A KITCHEN THAT ARE
ARE THAT ARE IMPACTED THAT MAY
NOT BE. SPECIFIC TO THE PATIENT
OCCUPIED BUILDING BUT IS
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
SERVICES TO OUR PATIENTS I'D SAY
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE TIME OF
OUR PLANT OPERATIONS STAFF ARE
DEDICATED TO MAKING SURE THAT
OUR- PATIENTS ARE SAFE AND
SECURE AS WELL AS OUR STAFF
MEMBERS. OKAY THANK YOU DR
PEPPER. NOTHING THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION WE DO HAVE SOME
FAIRLY DETAILED WRITE UPS- SO
JUST AT THE HIGH POINTS THAT BE
GREAT THANK YOU. OKAY AS WE MOVE
ON TO THE TO THE FINAL TWO. WE
LEAVE THE FIRST EVIDENT
FANTASTIC GREAT UP SO IF YOU
COULD JUST. PUT A LITTLE MORE
SUMMERS ATION. LET'S MOVE ON
INTO ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M ELLEN BACHMAN YEP
YOU DIRECTOR STATEWIDE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM I'LL BE
PRESENTING ON ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE. BERMAN OF STATE
HOSPITALS PROPOSES ONE POINT SIX
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND ELEVEN
POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT STANDARDS COMPLIANCE
AND QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
OPERATIONS AND TO PROVIDE OUR
OFFICE ABOUT ITS WITH NECESSARY
RESOURCES. TO CONDUCT
INDEPENDENT FINANCIAL
OPERATIONAL COMPLIANCE AND
PERFORMANCE AUDITS THESE
RESOURCES WILL HELP DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN POLICIES THAT ARE
CRITICAL- TO OUR COMPLIANCE WITH
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS TO
MONITOR LICENSING AND JOINT
COMMISSION SURVEY FINDINGS. TO
ENSURE COMPLETION OF STATEWIDE
CLINICAL COMPLIANCE AUDITS AND A
WIDE RANGE OF PERFORMANCE
IMPROVEMENT ACTIVITIES AND
MENTORING CONSULT WITH OUR
HOSPITAL STAFF TO ENSURE
CONSISTENCY IN IMPLEMENTATION OF
REGULATIONS POLICY PRACTICE
STANDARDS AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THE ODDS AUDIT
THE MAJORITY OF THEIR FOCUS HAS
BEEN ON CONDUCTING WHISTLEBLOWER
AUDITS AND SERVING AS THE
LIAISON WITH EXTERNAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PERFORM
AUDITS OF PSH FUNCTIONS. SO
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED- TO ALLOW
THEM TO PERFORM MORE INTERNAL
AUDITS TO HELP US MITIGATE RISK
IN KEY AREAS- AND SO WE ARE.
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT THIS ESSENTIAL
FUNCTION AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS PROPOSAL.
NO QUESTIONS THANK YOU HUSBAND
BOND ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN. AND
I HAVE THIS ITEM AS WELL- WE ARE
REQUESTING SIX POSITIONS AND ONE
POINT SIX MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND ONE
POINT ONE MILLION ON GOING TO
SUPPORT COMPLIANCE WITH THE FIVE
STATE HOSPITALS. WITH REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT WERE CONTAINED
IN SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE CHAPTER EIGHT FORTY TWO OF
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND CALIFORNIA
CODE OF REGULATIONS SECTION
THIRTY THREE FORTY TWO WORKPLACE
VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND HEALTH
CARE. SB TWELVE NINETY NINE
REQUIRED SPECIFIED HEALTHCARE
SETTINGS TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT- WORKPLACE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION PLANS AND OTHER
REFORMS TO IMPROVE EMPLOYEE
SAFETY. IT HAD LANGUAGE THAT
EXEMPTED THE DEPARTMENT HOWEVER
IT DID NOT LIMIT THE AUTHORITY
OF THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH STANDARDS FOR TO REQUIRE
EXEMPT EMPLOYERS TO ADOPT THESE
PLANS IN PURSUANT TO S. B.
TWELVE NINETY NINE. OF THE BOARD
STEP THAT SUBSEQUENTLY DID
INCLUDE DÍAS STAGE IN-
CALIFORNIA OF REGULATIONS THIRTY
THREE FORTY TWO AND THE STATE
HOSPITALS WERE NOT RESOURCE TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THE
ASSOCIATED WORKLOAD INCREASE.
USAGE IS THE ONLY STATE
DEPARTMENT UNDER THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS REGULATION.
ARE WE APPLIED FOR A PERMIT
VARIANCE WITH THE OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS FOR
TO REPORT VIOLENT INCIDENTS ON A
MODIFIED SCHEDULE BUT AFTER A
LENGTHY PROCESS AND MULTIPLE
APPEALS SO BRING TO YOUR KERRY
AT THIS REQUEST WAS DENIED. SO
EFFECTIVE OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY
TWO THE U. S. H. WILL NEED TO
REPORT ON SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
SPECIFIC VIOLENT INCIDENT
INVESTIGATION FINDINGS TO CALLOW
SHOW WITHIN A TWENTY FOUR OR
SEVENTY TWO HOUR. PERIOD AFTER A
VIOLENT INCIDENT OCCURS THE
FUNDING REQUEST YOU WOULD
SUPPORT ONE POSITION HOSPITALS
AND ONE POSITION AT HEADQUARTERS
TO SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS NEW
OPERATION TURN REPORTING
SOLUTION. AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND ONE TIME
COSTS IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
PER CONSULTATION SERVICES TO
IMPROVE OUR DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING CAPABILITY TO MEET
THIS- REPORTING TIMELINE
REQUIREMENTS. AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. YOU'RE NOT A
I'M FOR. FULLY AWARE OF THE BILL
BUT I AM MISSING THAT THAT IS A
BY TO. STAFF AND OR CLIENTS AND
AMONGST CLIENTS AS WELL PATIENTS
CORRECT IT IS SPECIFIC TO
VIOLENCE TOWARD EMPLOYEES I'M
TOWARDS EMPLOYEES OKAY. THANK
YOU ATTACHMENT. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE ON TO
ATASCADERO AND THEY'RE SEWER AND
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANT AND
AGAIN WE HAVE A GOOD WRITE UP MR
HOUSER SO. SUMMARIZE DO AND I'VE
ISSUES FOURTEEN THROUGH EIGHT
TEAMS HOW DOING MY BEST. JOB AT
BEING BRIEF STARTING WITH THE
SEWER AND WASTEWATER TREATMENT
PLANT THE ESTATES REQUEST FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE PRELIMINARY
PLANS BASED PROVIDE UPGRADES TO
THE SEWER COLLECTION SYSTEM
INSTALLATION OF A GREEN
SCREENING SYSTEM AND CONNECTION
TO THE CITY OF. ATASCADERO THE
WASTE WATER TREATMENT SYSTEM.
YES AGES EXISTING WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANT CURRENTLY SERVES
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY PATIENTS APPROXIMATELY TWO
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES. AND HAVE NOT
MADE SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS TO
ITS RECOLLECTION OF WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANT SINCE THE EARLY
NINETEEN FIFTIES HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL- LET'S GET ON THE WASTE
WATER TREATMENT BUSINESS AND
MOVE ON HERE. MOVING ON TO THE
METROPOLITAN CENTRAL UTILITY
PLANT REPLACEMENT PSH REQUEST
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE PRELIMINARY
PLANS THAT. PLACEMENT OF SENTRY
CHILI PLANT AT YOUR STAGE
METROPOLITAN THIS PROJECT
REPLACE THE EXISTING CENTRAL
UTILITY PLANT AT METRO THAT
SUPPLY STEAM FOR HOT WATER AND
CENTRAL HOUSING AS WELL AS
CHILLED WATER FOR AIR
CONDITIONING TO THIRTY TWO
PATIENT HOUSING UNITS AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDINGS. KNUX
CONCLUSION OF ISSUE FIFTEEN
THANK YOU SIXTEEN. AGAIN IDEA
STAGE METROPOLITAN IDEA STAGE
REQUEST FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CULINARY PLANS
PHASE OF THE PSH METROPOLITAN
FIRE WATER LINE CONNECTION
PROJECT THIS PROJECT WILL
PROVIDE THE VOLUME OF WATER
REQUIRED FOR THE FIRE SPRINKLER
SYSTEM TO COMPLY WITH CURRENT
FOUGHT A FIRE CODE REQUIREMENTS
SPECIFICALLY THE REPLACEMENT OF
THE EXISTING SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND GALLON STEEL TANK WITH
THE NEW MILLION. GALLON
DEDICATED FIRE WATER STORAGE
TANK THAT WILL ALLOW US TO MEET
THE COMPLIANCE. REQUIREMENTS AND
IT JUST SAYS AS WE SIT IN THE
SPRING CALISTA ANNEX IN THE
CAPITAL RAISE A PATHETIC TO THIS
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH OKAY MOVING
ON MR HOUSER. FIFTY SEVENTEEN
FIFTY SEVENTEEN RELATED TO DSHS
PASCAL'S POSSIBLE WATER BOOSTER
SYSTEM THIS IS AN ONGOING
PROJECT THAT REQUEST ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE.
OF THIS PROJECT TO INSTALL
POSSIBLE WATER BOOSTER SYSTEM TO
IMPROVE THE PERFORMANCE OF THE
S. H. ATTACK ATASCOSA. MAIN
WATER SYSTEM- THREE. ISN'T THE
MAIN WATER WATER PRESSURE CAN
DROP VERY LOW- AND TURN OF WATER
WHICH IS WELL BELOW THE REQUIRED
OPERATING PRESSURE NECESSARY FOR
THE NORMAL FACILITY OPERATIONS
OF THE PROJECT COMPLETION IS
ESTIMATED FOR OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU AND WELL
ARE ALL OVER THE- STATE HOSPITAL
AT ONE POINT I'M ASSUMING HAVE
THEIR OWN WATER SYSTEMS. THE BIG
WATER TANKS. I'M NOT SURE IF
EACH HOSPITAL ROBERT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT ONE ON
THAT WATER SYSTEM AT EACH
FACILITY IT'S OKAY IT'S IT WAS
JUST CURIOSITY I JUST WE HAVE
ONE IN STOCK AND THAT'S IT IT IS
NOW UP ALL KINDS OF HEALTH CARE
CENTER AND R. C. ISSUE SATELLITE
BUT THERE IS A BIG HIGHLY.
HIGHLY DISPLAYED WATER TANK AND
I KNOW USED TO SUPPLY WATER FOR
THE HOSPITAL- BUT IS NOW WE USES
A RECIRCULATING FOR. SOME OF THE
PONDS. AND WE AND WE DO ACTUALLY
HAVE WATER SYSTEMS AT AGE OF THE
HOSPITALS THAT REPRESENT US GOOD
OR THE BAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OF A ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN.
NUMBER EIGHTEEN DIDN'T GET SIX
REQUEST A REAPPROPRIATION OF
NINE POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE THAT THE FIRE
ALARM SYSTEM UPGRADE PROJECT
THIS PROJECT REMOVES AND
REPLACES FIRE ALARM SYSTEMS IN
THE PARK FOR SECURE PATIENT
HOUSING BUILDINGS AND TREATMENT
AREAS A REAPPROPRIATION IS
NEEDED DUE TO DELAYS AND-
REGULATORY AGENCY REVIEWS AS
WELL AS THE IMPACTS OF CARPET
NINETEEN. I'M KIND OF THE CALM
OF A CUSTOMER ON ISSUE EIGHTEEN
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE CHEAP
ON THE FIRE SYSTEM. OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
DEPARTMENT FOR THEIR
PRESENTATIONS- IT WAS IT WAS
GOOD TO HEAR ALL THE UPDATES
YOU'VE BEEN VERY BUSY. AND I
KNOW CODE HASN'T BEEN EASY ON
EVERYBODY AND SO YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TO VERY
CHALLENGING TIMES. WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR ATTENTION
YOUR PROFESSIONALISM. AND YOUR
ABILITY TO KEEP ON GOING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS- AND AGAIN
PEOPLE HAVE ONE MINUTE TO
PROVIDE THEIR THEIR INPUT. AND
PLEASE KNOW THAT IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO GET IN ON
TIME OR YOUR TIME IS UP. THEN
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO CALL AND OR
TECH OR CALL OR EMAIL OUR-
CONSULTANTS AND THEY'LL BE I'M
GLAD TO BE ABLE TO TAKE YOUR
INPUT. SO MODERATOR ARE YOU
THERE. YES I IF YOU WISH TO MAKE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND HOW
MANY PEOPLE DO WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE ALREADY MODERATOR. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN Q. THANK.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT COMMENT THANK YOU. WHY AM
THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALEXANDER EGGMAN AND
THEN OR A HAND SHOT MUCH FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION I WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL ON THE INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL OR DIE IN THE
BACKLOG. OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND ELECTED
SHERIFFS HAVE BEEN PRODUCTIVELY
ENGAGED FOR YEARS OUR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN
PROVIDING TREATMENT AND
RESTORATION SERVICES TO BUILD
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
AND HE IMPROVE. THEIR SERVICE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE HAVE ALSO.
IN SEVERAL WORK GROUPS INCLUDING
THE MOST RECENT THE SOLUTION
WORKGROUP CONVENED AT THE RESULT
OF LAST YEAR'S BUDGET. ADDRESS
THE BACK WASN'T BACKLOG PATIENTS
WHO SERVICE IN THE AND WE CALM
TO BEING PART OF THIS PROCESS.
MORE DISCUSSION ON THE ICE HE
REFERRAL CAPS IS NECESSARY. NOT
BAD WE APPRECIATE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE COMMENT
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
ONGOING PROBLEM AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL INVOLVED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS CALLER. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE ONE MORE COMMENT THANK
YOU IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT COMMENT THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOUR COMBINED THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI JOSH DUGGAR RECORD
IN THE URBAN COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND IN REFERENCE TO ISSUE TO THE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
SOLUTION PACKAGE WEARING COURAGE
BY MANY OF THE ELEMENTS IN THE
PACKAGE ESPECIALLY THE
INVESTMENT IN RESIDENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ADDITIONAL
HOUSING. FUNDING FOR DIVERSION
COUNTY CONTRACT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE NEW COUNTY
CAPITAL BUDGET BEING CONCERNING%
ON THE SURFACE ESPECIALLY
ALONGSIDE. YES TRIGGERS INCLUDED
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND
CONSIDERING THE COMPLEX FACTORS
LEADING TO ADMISSION. BACK UP
TODAY. BUT WE ARE HOPEFUL CAL
THOSE BY IT MAKE THE BOX THE-
AND ACCOUNTED. TO MAKE MOBILE
PROBLEM IN. THE LOOKING FOR
FURTHER COME. THANK THANK YOU
MUCH ANY MORE COLORS MODERATOR.
YES ACTUALLY HAVE TO MORE AND
APPLY THIRTY FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. I GET AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIR COMMITTEE AND STAFF BRIAN
MOORE MANY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. WE'RE HERE TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT OF THE FIVE
MILLION SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ONGOING INVESTMENT
INCLUDING THE JANUARY BUDGET.
IMPLEMENTATION OF SOLUTIONS
WHICH PROVIDES EARLY ACCESS AND
TREATMENT. IMPROVES STATE AND
LOCAL COLLABORATION AND INCREASE
COMMUNITY CAPACITY TO ADDRESS
THE FELONY I HE WEIGHTLESS.
HOWEVER WE SHARE CONCERNS WITH
THAT IN THE BURKE COUNTY
AFFILIATE WHICH IS NOTED- WITH
THE INCLUSION OF UNSPECIFIED CAP
ON THE TOTAL NUMBER OF AYE IT HE
REFERRAL. AND THE POTENTIAL FOR
COUNTY COST SHARING OF THE
CABBAGE EXCLUDED. AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EFFORTS AND ONGOING INVESTMENT
THANK DIRECTOR CLINTON AND INNER
STAFF. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER CONVERSATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REMEMBER WHAT
PRESIDENT JOHNSON WE HAVE THE
COUNTY SAN JOAQUIN SABINA TO
WHAT I CAN EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO POTENTIAL TO
CONTINUE AND THEN COMMISSION OF
LPS. THIRTY TWO EIGHTY AT AGE
FACILITIES IN CONNECTION WITH
THAT I HAVE T. WENT ON WORKERS
ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED BEFORE
SETTLING THE CONFLICT BETWEEN.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOT STAFF
WORKER PASSED THE ASSEMBLY THE
POPULATION WE NEED TO AND SHOW
THAT CAN CAN I SUCCEED IN ANY
ARRANGE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH A LEADING AND THE
GOVERNOR ON ISSUE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS.
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO I WOULD THINK
THE STAFF IN EVERY WHO PER.
TODAY AND A THIS ME OF SUB.